THANK YOU.
AND SO SPECIFICALLY WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITIES INSTANCE INCIDENTS.
OF VIOLENCE AS WELL AS GANG
VIOLENCE -- WHERE WE WILL LOOK
AT THE DATA -- AND ALSO HAVE A
ROBUST CONVERSATION -- WITH OUR
PANELISTS -- ON PROGRAM TO COME
UP WITH SOLUTIONS -- THAT WEEK
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING -- SOLUTIONS IN
THEIR OWN PERSPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES -- THAT HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS WE WANT --
TO EXTRACT FROM THOSE SUCCESS
AND SO WE INVITE -- THAT THOSE
PALACE TO COME UP -- TO THE
TABLE IN ADDITION TO THAT ON THE
COMMUNITY THOSE WHO ARE PRESENT
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO
WAY HAND BECAUSE THE PUBLIC IS
IMPORTANT INTO PROVIDING
SOLUTIONS -- TO THIS ISSUE THAT
WE BELIEVE EXISTS IN COMMUNITIES
OF CALLERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- SO THE COMMUNITY
YOU WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE INPUT -- WE WILL ALSO
PROVIDE -- I'M SOME PAPER FOR
YOU SO THAT YOU CAN WRITE DOWN --
AT YOUR PARTICULAR THOUGHTS SO
THAT YOU'LL FORGET THOSE
THOUGHTS SO YOU CAN SHARE THOSE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WE HAVE
A LOT OF TIME AT THE INDIA THE
AGENDA -- FOR THE THE COMMUNITY
INPUT AND SO AGAIN -- YOU WILL
PARTICIPATE.
IN THIS PROCESS AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE HERE TODAY --
LET ME PAUSE FOR A MOMENT WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE -- WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS JUST SITS ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
ON THERE'S A NUMBER OF HEARINGS
GOING ON COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
SO PEOPLE WILL BE FLOWING IN AND
OUT -- SOMETIME IS JUST BE ME.
AND THAT'S OKAY WE WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE IN ALL THE INPUT
AND ALSO THE INFORMATION WE WILL
ALSO HAVE SOMEONE TAKING NOTES
SO DO WE WILL HOPE THAT -- YOUR
COMMENTS -- GET YOUR COMMENTS OF
BACK WILL BE CAPTURED -- BY YOUR
TESTIMONY AND ALSO TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOUR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
WILL BE CAPTURED AS WELL AGAIN
OUR DESIRES TO ONE HAVE -- THIS
HEARING HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL AND THEN WILL BE MORE
WITH THE NEXT HERE'S A LOS
ANGELES AND THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE.
AND OUR DESIRE AND OUR GOAL IS
TO HAVE IT COME OUT A WITH A
WHITE PAPER -- THAT -- WOULD
BEST PRACTICES WITH SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
CLAIMING EXTRACTED OF FROM THESE
HEARINGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT WE CAN PRESENT THIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND HOPES IT WILL BE A ROAD MAP
FOR US TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES OF GUN VIOLENCE -- IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLORS.
WE WILL HAVE A ALSO -- PANEL OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO -- WHO SPEAK
VERY AUTHORITATIVELY -- IN THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AREAS OF EXPERTISE
AND WE WELCOME.
THEM TO DO SO I'M GOING TO
POSSIBLE MOMENT AND IT ALSO
WOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MY
COLLEAGUES -- TO WAY AND TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES TALK ABOUT
THE DISTRICTS IN THE CITIES IN
WHICH THEY REPRESENT AND WHY
THIS TOPIC IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
THEM.
AND SO WITH THAT I WANT -- TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
COOPER FREEZE INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NOW I
THINK THE CHAIRMAN -- FOR THING
IS COMMITTEE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC A LOT GOING ON
WITH GUN VIOLENCE.
IN OUR COMMUNITY SPECIAL
COMMITTEES OF COLOR -- PARTY
COMING LEGISLATURE SPENT THIRTY
YEARS AS A CAPTAIN WITH SECOND --
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND DOCTOR
MOFFETT MEANS THE SECOND
APPROVED BY MY WORK WITH THEM SO
I KNOW DOCTOR.
MOFFETT VERY WELL AND WITH THE
GUN VIOLENCE -- OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF DIFFERENT WELL DIFFERENT
BALLS IN THE AIR.
BUT THE ONE THING THAT HE REALLY
KEEP COMING BACK TO IN MY IN MY
VIEW IS -- DIVIDE.
BETWEEN THE HAVES AND HAVE NOTS --
IS A SURE SPOKESMAN FOR FOUR
YEARS OUT EVERY MURDER IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
KNOWS DOT FIFTY FOUR HOMICIDES
PER YEAR.
AND THE QUITE OFTEN INVOLVE --
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THOSE REALLY BIG ISSUE AND
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS WE GOT A
BRAND NEW ARENA DOWNTOWN THAT'S
VERY NICE HERE AND FROM
SACRAMENTO.
THAT'S VERY NICE AND
REVITALIZING DOWNTOWN BUT OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WOULD BE IT IN SECOND THE GOOD
SCHOOLS WITHOUT NEIGHBORHOODS
GONNA FOOD THE TABLE AND ALL
THESE COMMUNITIES LACK THAT.
THIS IS BEEN THAT FOREVER.
SO THAT'S PROBABLY MOST
FRUSTRATING THING -- I WAS OTHER
THIRTY YEARS AGO. THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO AND THE SAME ISSUES
THAT WERE GOING ON THEN AND LONG
BEFORE THAT.
ARE STILL OCCURRING NOW ALSO HOW
DO WE CHANGE THAT HOW DO WE FIX
THAT.
THEN THE DAY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS ONE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT CHOI GOES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
YEAH WE DON'T HOPEFULLY WE DON'T
WE WON'T NEED A LOT FOR HIM
THERE ARE SOME POINT. TO BE TO
DO WITH THOSE ISSUES BUT HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE SEPARATE THAT.
YOU STILL HAVE A CALLS FOR
SERVICE.
I'M MORE WORK ALL OF YOU LAW
ENFORCEMENT LAW LAWS OF CHANGE.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SAFE AND
HAVE A CHANCE TO GROW UP IT WAS
INTERESTING -- SO I REPRESENTS
ALL SACRAMENTO L. GOLD GOLD LODI.
SO I LIVE ABOUT -- TO CROW FLIES
PLUG OUT FOR MILES FROM MANY OF
YOU.
IN NO GROVE YOU FIFTEEN THOUSAND
KIDS PLAYING YOU SPORTS.
THE LARGEST YOUTH SOCCER
REGISTRATION IN THE COUNTRY FOR
ONE LEAGUE OF THE BIGGEST CAL
RIPKEN BASEBALL LEAGUE WHAT'S
THE MISSISSIPPI [inaudible]
MEADOW VIEW.
THE IMPACT AREA A FREE BREAKFAST
FREE LUNCH FOR DINNER.
IT'S JUST A LOOK AT THAT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OVER THERE AND HAS
NEVER CHANGED.
AND OUR GIRLS A LOT OF ART
ARTISTIC STUFF.
TOO WHEN I WOULD I WOULD ARGUE
WITH YOU WITH THOSE KIDS THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY.
THEIR LIVES BE DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT BUT THEY ARE GETTING
THAT.
SO HOW DO WE CHANGE THAT
NARRATIVE.
REQUIRES MONEY.
AND I DO BUT I DO BELIEVE IS A
PER SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
ISSUE SO WE'VE GOT A LOT FOR THE
ADULTS.
BUT AS FAR AS THE CHILDREN GO
THAT PIPELINE IS STILL WIDE OPEN.
KIDS ARE FLOWING IN THE SYSTEM
HOW DO YOU STOP THAT.
HOW DO YOU STOP THAT IT'S A LOT
CHEAPER? TO DEAL WITH OUR KIDS
AND EDUCATE THEM AND GIVE THEM
WHAT THEY NEED.
THE HEALTH OF THE PRISON SO HOW
DO WE CHANGE THAT NARRATIVE
BECAUSE A LOT OF FOLKS AND
THAT'S BEEN A LONG TIME.
SELECT A SACRAMENTAL Là FOLKS
GIVE A LIP SERVICE.
BUT WERETHEY DONE.
TO CHANGE ALL NEIGHBORHOODS AND
MAKE THOSE KIDS LIVES BETTER.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE THAT
POLITICIANS HAVE DONE THAT NO
ONE'S DONE THAT.
NO SEVEN CLARK SHOOTING CITY PUT
IN WHAT I THINK. TO A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR SOMETHING
SOME AMOUNT. FOR FOR PROGRAMS
WILL THIS PROGRAM SHOULD IN
EARLIER.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THAT.
SO HOPEFULLY THROUGH THIS --
COMMITTEE WE CAN COME UP WITH
SOME IDEAS AND AND REALLY CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE BECAUSE GUNS ARE
GONNA BE AROUND GUNS ARE GOING
AWAY LOT OF GUNS OUT THERE.
ILLEGAL ILLEGAL GUNS.
SO HOW TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
SHOOTING EACH OTHER.
IN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT ALSO THE
WAY YOU STOP THAT IS.
TO GIVE THOSE KIDS NEIGHBORHOODS
A CHANCE.
EDUCATE THEM.
THERE'S ONLY TOOLS WE CAN DO WE
TALK ABOUT NUMBERS FOR NOT
READING A THIRD GRADE LEVEL.
BUT TIME IN THIRD GRADE IS A
GOOD CHANCE YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SUCCEED HOW WE CHANGE THAT
NARRATIVE.
THERE'S SO MUCH TO DO WITH SO
MANY BALLS IN THE AIR SO I I'M
EXCITED.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET UP TO LEAVE
OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE TO GO TO
BUT LOVE TO HEAR FROM SOME OF
YOU FOLKS IN YOUR IDEAS AND
THOUGHTS BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW AT
ALL.
EVERYONE EXPERIENCE THE TABLE
BUT I DON'T KNOW EVERYTHING AND
NOW I'M GOING THE LISTEN AND SO
WE CAN CHANGE THIS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SUMMER
COOPER AND FOR ME VERY BRIEFLY --
ONE GROWING UP IN THE WHAT'S IN
LOS ANGELES I'M CERTAINLY GONE
BY THIS IS VERY PREVALENT --
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I GOT INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT AYE
SIR -- AS A POLICE OFFICER AND
RAY WOULD PLEASE DEPARTMENT AND
ALSO -- I PROBABLY WOULD SAY
THAT -- I'M THE ONLY ONE OF
WHOSE PARTNER WAS ACTUALLY SHOT
AND KILLED AND SO I SPEAK FROM --
TO DIFFERENT LANDS IN TWO
DIFFERENT SPACES -- AND JUST
REPRESENTING WATTS WILLOWBROOK
ROB WAS BORN AND RAISED
REPRESENTING -- COMPTON -- WHICH
JUST LAST FRIDAY A RAPPER --
SOMETHING -- FOUR HUNDRED WAS
SHOT EIGHT TIMES -- IN COMPTON --
THE CITY WHICH I REPRESENTS AND
IS VERY REAL I'M IN TERMS OF THE
GUN BODIES TAKES PLACE THERE ARE
REPRESENT CARSON WILMINGTON
NORTH LONG BEACH -- SOME OF LIN
WOOD GARDENA AND ALSO TORRANCE
AND SO THIS ISSUE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME -- IS IMPORTANT
TO ME -- NOT ONLY FROM THAT
LANDS BUT ALSO ONE WHO -- WHEN I
WAS A POLICE OFFICER A YOUNG MAN
WHO WAS SITTING IN HIS CAR WAS
GIRLFRIEND IN A SOMBER -- JUNE
IT WAS IN JULY AND A SUMMER
LISTEN TO A RADIO -- ISSUE HE
WAS SITTING IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT.
SINCE GIVING HIS GIRL FOR SAID
IN A DRIVERS THAT HE WAS HIS
MOTHER'S CAR AND HE WAS IN A
PASS OR SEEN SOMEONE CAME UP TO
THE WINDOW.
AND SHOPPING HERE AND ICE.
ROAD UP RESPONDED AND PULLED HIM
OUT IN HERE HEARD -- HIM
GARGLING IN HIS OWN BLOOD AND I
STAYED THERE WITH HIM ALL THE
WAY INTO THE WENT TO THE
HOSPITAL TO THE PARENTS HAD TO
BE NOTIFIED -- THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING ELSE THAT COULD BE DONE
THE WAS LIVING ON A RESPIRATOR
HEADED -- TO DISCONNECTED YEAH
AND HE WAS FIFTEEN YEARS OLD BUT
THESE THINGS LIKE THAT HAPPENS
TOO OFTEN AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND I WANNA GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT WE WANT TO HEAR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO SOLUTIONS -- AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE -- THAT WE
AGAIN HEAR YOUR VOICE IS NOW
YOUR VOICES BUT ALSO OTHER
PEOPLE'S VOICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT
BEING SAID.
I WANT TO BEGIN THE FIRST PANEL
OF GUN BATTLES BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITY.
WHICH WE WILL START WITH A CASE
STUDY OVERVIEW OF BACKGROUND IN
DATA THAT WILL -- THAT WE WE
HEAR UP AND PERSONAL TESTIMONY
CONNECTED -- WITH LOCAL PROGRAMS
AWARE OF THE PANEL HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES -- FIFTEEN MINUTES TO
TALK AND SHARE WITH US WE WANT
TO START THAT OFF BY INTRODUCING
DOCTOR STATE MARTINEZ ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO.
DR MARTINEZ THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US AND YOU CAN
TAKE AWAY.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING -- SO I
WANT TO START OUT IN JUST A LIKE
TO SEND YOU BRING THE MICROPHONE
CLOSE TO YOU SO WE CAN CAPTURE
YES PEOPLE WATCHING THIS IS.
BEING RECORDED LIVE OR SEEN LIVE
ALRIGHT SO -- LIKE TO THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OFFICE FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK HERE TODAY --
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK --
CORNELIUS BOWSER AND TASHA
WILLIAMS IN IN SAN DIEGO FROM
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE.
SUPPORT TEAM -- THEY'VE BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF ADDRESSING
VIOLENCE IN SAN DIEGO AND I'VE
BEEN A FEEDER GREATLY FROM MY
PARTNERSHIP WORKING WITH THEM AS
WELL.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I THINK
THIS SESSION IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
THERE IS VERY LITTLE RESEARCH
EVEN AMONG ACADEMICS.
ON GUN VIOLENCE THAT'S TROUBLING
BUT WHAT'S MORE TROUBLING IS
THAT THERE'S LITTLE RESEARCH
CONDUCTED BY BLACK AND LATINO
SCHOLARS AND RARELY DO WE HEAR
THE VOICES FROM PEOPLE OF COLOR --
FROM THE COMMUNITIES WHAT THE
GUN VIOLENCE IS CONCENTRATES OF
THIS HEARING I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT -- IN BADLY NEEDED.
TODAY I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT WERE
FOR THIS PORTION OF THE OF THE
DISCUSSION I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT
THREE THINGS TODAY.
I'M GONNA START BY DEFINING WHAT
IS GUN VIOLENCE IT'S A TERM
THOUGH A LOT OF PEOPLE USE I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
CLARITY.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE MEAN WHEN WE
USE THE TERM GUN VIOLENCE --
THEN I'M GOING TO BRIEFLY LOOK
AT SOME DATA FROM SAN DIEGO FROM
THE CORONER'S OFFICE.
IN TRYING TO EXPLORE HOW MUCH OF
THE HOMICIDES IN SAN DIEGO ARE
TRIBUNE HERBAL TO FIREARMS.
AND THEN IN THE THIRD PART OF MY
DISCUSSION HERE TODAY I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT THE LINK.
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND AND AS
A PRESSING ISSUE THAT SOME OF
YOU MENTION ALREADY I'M GONNA
TRY.
TO BRING IT TO THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR DISCUSSION TODAY.
SO LET ME START WITH WHAT IS GUN
VIOLENCE.
IN THE LITERATURE ON GUN
VIOLENCE AND IN SOCIOLOGY
THERE'S A TERM.
KNOWN AS THE AVAILABILITY
HYPOTHESIS IN THIS IS THE IDEA
THAT DANGEROUS PEOPLE WILL FIND
IT EASIER TO GET A FIREARM.
IN GUN RICH ENVIRONMENTS -- AND
THERE'S LOTS OF STUDIES THAT
SUPPORT THIS -- AND WHAT I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THOUGH IS THE
CONCLUSION IS NOT THAT MORE GUNS
PRODUCES MORE CRIME IT'S A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED -- WHAT
THE RESEARCH HAS BEEN CONSISTENT
IN DEMONSTRATING IS THAT GUN
PREVALENCE IS UNRELATED TO RATES
OF ASSAULT?
AND ROBBERY WHY BECAUSE THAT
THOSE ARE FORMS OF VIOLENCE.
SO THE STRONG FINDING IS THE GUN
USE INTENSIFIES VIOLENCE MAKING
IT MORE LIKELY THAT THE VICTIM
OF AN ASSAULT OR ROBBERY WILL
DIE IN THE MEAT I THINK THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS PROBABLY
THE BEST EXAMPLE.
THERE ARE SOME -- INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE PREDISPOSED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THEY WILL COMMIT
VIOLENCE.
BUT YOU PUT A GUN IN THEIR HAND
THEN A PERSON IS MORE LIKELY TO
DIE AND THAT'S THE SORT OF WAY
WE NEED TO START THINKING ABOUT.
GUN VIOLENCE.
SO IT FOLLOWS THAT IF WE COULD
CURTAIL THE UNDERLYING CAUSES OF
CRIMINAL VIOLENCE THAN GUNS
WOULD DO LESS DAMAGE. FOR
EXAMPLE A DROP IN THE OVERALL
RATES OF VIOLENCE AS BEEN
COUPLED WITH AN EQUALLY SHARP
DROP IN GUN VIOLENCE ROBBERIES.
RAPES AND ASSAULTS DECLINED 75%
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY THREE IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AT TWENTY
NINE POINT ONE PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO SEVEN POINT NINE PER.
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND END GUN
VIOLENCE DECLINED LOCK STEP WITH
THE OVERALL VIOLENCE PROBLEM.
SO LET ME TRY TO GET TO THE
POINT HERE WHAT WE MEANBY GUN
VIOLENCE.
THE PROBLEM ISN'T JUST THE
AVAILABILITY OF GUNS BUT THE
OVERALL AMOUNT OF VIOLENCE.
IT'S THE COMBINATION OF GUNS AND
VIOLENCE THAT PRODUCES HIGHER
MURDER RATES AND THAT'S THE WAY
THAT I'M GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
GOVERNMENTS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. FOR PEOPLE TO KIND OF
YOU WHERE THOSE TWO COMPONENTS --
SO WITHOUT A DOUBT THE ONE
STRATEGY FOR REDUCING GUN
VIOLENCE IS TO REDUCE CRIMINAL
VIOLENCE GENERALLY -- TAKING
STEPS TO REDUCE ALCOHOL AND DRUG
ABUSE.
BETTER TREATMENT FOR MENTAL
ILLNESS REDUCE SCHOOL DROPOUT
RATES AND DEPLOYED POLICE
RESOURCES MORE STRATEGICALLY.
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT AND WHAT I'M GOING TO
EMPHASIZE TODAY.
IS THE IMPORTANCE OF POLICE
COMMUNITY RELATIONS THAT
PARTICULAR FACTOR HASN'T BEEN
EMPHASIZED ENOUGH IN THE
LITERATURE AND I'M GONNA SAY
MORE ABOUT THAT IN JUST A BIT.
SO IF YOU DIFFERENTLY GUN
VIOLENCE IS ABOUT ACCESS THE
SUPPLY.
AND IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
MOTIVATIONS.
THROW GUN VIOLENCE RESEARCH
SHOULD FOCUS ON BOTH.
OKAY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT -- SO
I'M USING THE THE DATA FROM SAN
DIEGO TO TRY TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT A BIGGER PROBLEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE UNITED STATES EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE LOOKING AT SAN
DIEGO I THINK WHAT WE SEE IN SAN
DIEGO WE CAN SORT OF GENERALIZED
TO LOTS OF CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND TO THE COUNTRY.
SO THE QUESTION THAT I'M TRYING
TO EXPLORE HERE IS HOW MUCH DO
GUNS ACCOUNT. FOR THE OVERALL
SHARE OF HOMICIDES SO I'D LIKE
TO EXPLORE THIS ISSUE IN HERE WE
HAVE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF DEATHS.
THIS IS DATA FROM THE CORONER'S
OFFICE AND FROM THE SAN DIEGO A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
ROUGHLY ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE DIE EVERY YEAR -- IN
ABOUT ACCIDENTS ACCOUNT FOR THE
LARGEST PERCENTAGE BUT 46%.
OF NATURAL CAUSES OR NEXT AT 34%
SUICIDE. 14% NOW JUST TO BE%
CLEAR I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
SUICIDE TODAY.
BUT ONE IMPORTANT SEEM RELATED
TO GUN VIOLENCE IS SUICIDE AND
USUALLY SUICIDE.
IS AT LEAST TWO TIMES HIGHER
THAN -- HOMICIDES AS A RESULT OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE.
OKAY SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE
PICTURE LOOKS LIKE HOMICIDES
ACCOUNT 44%.
OF A MOST DEATHS EACH YEAR IN
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO.
LET'S LOOK AT THE HOMICIDE
METHODS.
JUST TO SORT OF ESTABLISH WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE FOCUS ON
FIREARMS WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOMICIDES IN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR.
IN WHAT WE SEE HERE AND THIS IS
A CONSISTENT PATTERN THAT OF ALL
THE HOMICIDES IN SAN DIEGO WE
HAD NINETY THREE CASES WERE
MISSING SOME CASES BUT I THINK
THIS PATTERN GENERALLY HOLDS
TRUE -- OF ALL THE HOMICIDES IN
SAN DIEGO. 48% WERE FIREARM
RELATED.
CUTTING STABBING KNIVES --
CONSTITUTE ABOUT 21% AND BLUNT
FORCE ABOUT 16% SO WHAT'S THE
TAKE AWAY FROM HERE FIREARM IS
THE LEAST FIREARMS ARE LEADING
SOURCE OF HOMICIDE JUST WANNA
THAT.
IN WE SEE SOMETHING SIMILAR IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN JUST SOLD
SO WE KNOW THIS ISN'T JUST A
TREND IT'S A CONSISTENT PATTERN --
IT THE SAME STORY IN -- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE HAD ROUGHLY
THREE THOUSAND DEATHS. 47% OF
ARM OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF
ACCIDENTS. 33% WERE NATURAL
CAUSES SUICIDE 14% AGAIN
HOMICIDE -- WAS 4%.
AND IT'S THE SAME STORY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN NEARLY HALF
THE HOMICIDES PRODUCED WERE
PRODUCED BY FIREARMS.
CUTTING AGAIN STABBING WAS 22%
BLUNT FORCE 19%.
IN A SIXTY ASIAN 7% SO WHY WHY
IS THIS IMPORTANT.
SAN DIEGO IS A WINDOW INTO A
CONSISTENT PATTERN WHERE
FIREARMS OVERWHELMINGLY ARE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR HOMICIDES.
US IN WE SEE THE SAME PATTERN IN
MOST CITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
SEE.
A SIMILAR PATTERN THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY SO THIS IS WHEN I SAY
STANDING AS A WINDOW INTO THE
COUNTRY I THINK THIS IS A IT
MAKES ANNUAL RELEVANT IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT.
IT'S NOT JUST A LOCAL ISSUE.
ALL RIGHT NOW I WANT TO TURN TO
PART THREE OF MY TALK HERE.
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY.
AND I WANT TO SPEAK TO A
PRESSING ISSUE -- REGARDING
POLICE COMMUNITY RELATIONS FROM
MY RESEARCH.
POLICE USE OF FORCE.
IS THE MOST PRESSING ISSUE
FACING BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE SEE THIS.
AND MICHAEL BROWN -- WE SEE WHAT
HAPPENED TO ERIC GARDNER.
OF FULL LANDAU CASTEEL IN
RECENTLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
STEFAN CLARK.
THE QUESTION IS HOW IS POLICE
USE OF FORCE RELEVANT TO GUN
VIOLENCE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LET
ME TRY.
TO INVESTIGATE OR SAY LITTLE
SOME PROVIDE LITTLE INSIGHT ON
THIS ISSUE FROM A QUOTE.
FROM A CRIMINOLOGIST NAME
RICHARD ROSENFELD HE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE.
AND HE WROTE A PAPER RECENTLY TO
EXPLAIN THE RECENT SPIKE IN
HOMICIDE IN AMERICA.
AND HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
HE SAID WHAT IS CERTAIN IS THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE MUCH LESS
CONFIDENCE IN THE POLICE THEN TO
WHITES.
COMPROMISED POLICE LEGITIMACY IS
INSTITUTIONALIZE FEATURE.
OF DISADVANTAGED BLACK
COMMUNITIES.
IT HELPS TO EXPLAIN THE
PERSISTENCE THE PERSISTENCE OF
RELATIVELY HIGH LEVELS OF
VIOLENCE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
AND WHAT I WANT TO SUGGEST HERE
HERE'S THE CONNECTION WITH USE
OF FORCE AND GUN VIOLENCE.
IS THAT AFTER HIGH PROFILE USE
OF FORCE INCIDENTS.
TRUST OF POLICE IN BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES.
DECREASES.
SOME IN THE MEDIA AND SOME
ACADEMICS HAVE REFERRED TO THIS
AS THE FERGUSON EFFECT SO THERE
IS A TERM FOR THIS -- AND LOW
TRUST IN POLICE HAS BEEN A
FEATURE HOWEVER IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES FOR SOME TIME BUT
THE POINT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS
THAT THESE USE OF FORCE.
INCIDENTS ONLY DEEPEN MISTRUST.
AND WHERE THE GUN VIOLENCE FITS
INTO THE PICTURE IS IT PEOPLE
ARE LESS INCLINED TO COOPERATE
WITH THE POLICE WHEN THERE IS A
SHOOTING.
AND THIS IS WHAT DRIVES UP.
GUN VIOLENCE IN THIS IS NOT A
TRIVIAL FACTOR -- ROSENFELD WAS
DIRECTOR OF AN AYE JAYE
SUGGESTED THAT THIS WAS ONE OF
THE TOP THREE REASONS THAT MAY
BE DRIVING HOMICIDES IN THE
UNITED STATES BUT WE DON'T TALK.
ANOTHER ABOUT IT.
THE BEATING OF FRANK JUDE'S A
TWELVE YEAR OLD BY AN OFF DUTY
MILWAUKEE POLICE OFFICER WROTE
ROCK THE CITY LEADING TO THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF FIRINGS AND
DEPARTMENT HISTORY.
FEDERAL CONVICTION OF SEVEN
OFFICERS IN A SERIES OF REFORMS.
A NEW STUDY PUBLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN REVEALED
ANOTHER ON SCENE BUT FAR
REACHING IMPACT RESIDENTS IN
PREDOMINATELY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MILWAUKEE WERE
FAR LESS LIKELY TO CALL.
911- AFTER BEATINGS THE DROP IN
NINE ONE ONE CALL SUGGESTS THAT
THE INCIDENT ERODED TRUST IN
SHARPLY DAMAGE THE RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE POLICE AND
NEIGHBORHOODS -- AFTER USE OF
FORCE INCIDENTS SO THIS IS THE
KEY HERE IS USE OF FORCE ISN'T
JUST ABOUT -- MISTREATMENT OF
PEOPLE BUT IT HAS THE EFFECT OF
POTENTIALLY DRIVING UP GUN
VIOLENCE -- AS WELL.
AND SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT SOME
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN SACRAMENTO WITH TALKED ABOUT
OTHER CITIES BUT WE DON'T HAVE
TO LOOK VERY FAR. TO SAVE MORE
ABOUT THIS -- AND SO WHAT I WANT
TO DO IS BRIEFLY TAKE A LOOK AT
SOUTH SACRAMENTO THE MEADOW VIEW
AREA.
AND I ALSO WANT TO LOOK AT THE
DEL PASO HEIGHTS AREA.
WHAT THESE TWO AREAS HAVE IN
COMMON LET'S START WITH MEADOW
VIEW IS IT THEY HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST POVERTY IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO SO WHERE THAT CIRCLES
DRAWN THERE?
THAT'S A ONE MILE RADIUS AROUND
WERE STAFF ON CLARK WAS KILLED
BY THE POLICE.
AND THE AREAS WITH A HIGH YOUR
OF RED SHADINGS THE RED AREAS
HAVE HIGHER RATES OF POVERTY.
WE ALSO SEE SOMETHING SIMILAR --
WHEN WE LOOK AT DEL PASO HEIGHTS
SO THAT CIRCLE AT THE TOP OF THE
CITY THERE IS WHERE JOSEPH MAN?
WAS KILLED BY POLICE.
I BELIEVE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND LIKE.
THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO AREA IT
ALSO HAS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
POVERTY IN THE CITY AS WELL AND
THERE'S THERE'S THREE THINGS.
THAT THESE TWO PLACES HAVE IN
COMMON THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
[inaudible]
FIRST.
THESE ARE PLACES WERE THERE ARE
THERE HAS BEEN A HIGH PROFILE
USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS MENTIONED
JOSEPH MANA MENTIONED STEP ON
CLARK -- THESE ARE ALSO AREAS
THAT ARE AMONG THE POOREST AND
MOST SEGREGATED BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO.
THEY ALSO HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
GUN VIOLENCE.
MAC ROAD IN THE SOUTH IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH SACRAMENTO -- IS
AN AREA THAT CONSISTENTLY HAS
SOME OF THE HIGHEST COMBINES IN
SACRAMENTO AND ONE IT'S NOT MAC
ROAD.
IT'S USUALLY THE DAHLE PASO
HEIGHTS AREA -- IN THESE TWO
AREAS HAVE THE HIGHEST RATES OF
GUN VIOLENCE AND THE THIRD THING
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THAT
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE SOME OF
THE LOWEST LEVELS OF PERCEIVED
TRUST.
TOWARDS THE POLICE.
I CAN'T ELABORATE ON THIS
FURTHER BUT I RECENTLY COLLECTED
LARGE SCALE SURVEY DATA WE GET
REGARDING THE PERCEPTIONS OF
NEIGHBORHOOD RESIDENTS WHICH I
WHICH I PLAN TO RELEASE.
AT A LATER DATE BUT LET ME JUST
SAY ANECDOTALLY THAT THESE AREAS
WE WE'VE I'VE.
COLLECTED SOME.
GOOD DATA IN THESE AREAS HAVE
NOTICEABLY LOWER RATES OF TRUST
THAT QUANTITATIVE DATA ON THIS
THEN THE REST.
OF THE CITY SO THE KEY POINT.
IS THAT BOTH GEOGRAPHY AND RACE
MATTER WHEN IT COMES TO PERCEIVE
TRUST TOWARDS POLICE.
AND POOR BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT HAVE LOWER RATES OF TRUST
TEND TO HAVE HIGHER RATES OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN THIS IS I THINK
SOMETHING.
THAT WE NEED TO EXPLORE FURTHER.
ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA SAY ONE LAST
THING HERE -- I THINK I'M DOING
OKAY TIME RIGHT NOW YEAH YOU'RE
FINE -- AND THAT IS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT.
COMMUNITY GUN VIOLENCE IS
TYPICALLY THE TURN IT'S USED TO
EXPLAIN GUN VIOLENCE IN BLACK
AND LATINO COMMUNITIES -- WE
ALSO HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW IT
AFFECTS POLICING.
AND SO -- COMMUNITY VOIGTS ALSO
HAS AN EFFECT ON THE POLICE.
THE RECENT UNPROVOKED SHOOTING
OF NATALIE CORONA AND TORRENT
TERRORIST.
ARE THE CLEAREST EXAMPLES OF
WRIST OFFICERS FACE GIVEN THE
LARGE NUMBER OF HAND GUNS IN
CIRCULATION.
COMMUNITY VIOLENCE AFFECTS
POLICE AND THIS MUST BE PART OF
THE DISCUSSION AS WELL.
A CENTRAL QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
RISK DO POLICE FACE REGARDING
GUN VIOLENCE.
AND THE ASSUMPTION IS IF THEY'RE
EXPOSED TO A LOT OF RISK MAYBE
THE USE OF FORCE IS JUSTIFIED.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO COMMENT ON BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY -- WORTH EXPLORING LOT
OF PEOPLE WOULD SAY THAT THAT
IT'S NOT JUSTIFIED BUT IT STILL
NEEDS TO BE EXPLORED. TO ADDRESS
ISSUES RELATED TO BUILDING TRUST
WE MUST ASK WHAT TYPE OF RHYS
OFFICERS FACE ON PATROL IN DOES
IT JUSTIFY USE OF FORCE.
ADDITIONALLY HOW DOES EXPOSURE
TO THE POTENTIAL COMBINES A
AFFECT THE WAY POLICE PATROL
THEIR BEATS AND HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT THEIR ABILITY TO TRUST TO
BUILD TRUST.
IN AREAS THAT WE NEED TO REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE AS WELL.
AND I WANT TO SUGGEST IF THEY'RE
NOT PART OF THE DISCUSSION.
POLICE FATALITIES CAN WIDEN
MISTRUST EVEN MORE WITH THE
COMMITTEE COMMUNITIES WHO SUFFER
FROM GUN VIOLENCE AND POOR
RELATIONS.
WITH THE POLICE.
OKAY LET ME -- TRY TO WRAP THIS
UP HERE I HAVE A COUPLE OF
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS -- THAT
MAYBE WE CAN CIRCLE BACK TO YOU --
SO THE MESSAGE HERE TODAY THAT
I'VE GIVEN IN THE SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME IS THAT POLICE USE OF
FORCE UNDERMINES TRUST.
AND RESIDENTS THEREFORE SETTLE
CONFLICT OUTSIDE THE LAW OR
DON'T CALL THEM AT ALL.
IN THE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
WOULD BE.
TO LIMIT POLICE USE OF FORCE.
I KNOW THE BILL PASSED AB THREE
NINETY TWO I THINK WHAT'S GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT IS TO LOOK AT
HOW THIS IS ENFORCED WE SAW THAT
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE PASSED
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE.
TRANSPARENCY TO THE POLICE BUT
NO ONE HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET
RECORDS TO FIND OUT WHAT KIND OF
POLICE MISCONDUCT HAS OCCURRED
SO IT'S NOT JUST PASSING THE LAW.
BUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
THREE NINETY TWO THAT I THINK IS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL.
SECOND POLICY RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HAVE MORE DEMOCRATICALLY
CONTROLLED POLICING.
AND POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY VIA
ENHANCE COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION.
AND THEN THE THIRD THING THAT I
WOULD RECOMMEND IS MORE FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS CAST OF
THESE ARE VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS -- TO BUILD TRUST FOR
THE TO BUILD TRUST BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY AND THE POLICE.
AND THEN THE LAST THING I WANT
TO SAY TO KIND OF WRAP IT UP.
IS WE NEED MORE FUNDING FOR GUN
VIOLENCE RESEARCH THE FOCUS IS
NOT JUST ON GUN VIOLENCE BUT HOW
IT AFFECTS.
BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITIES ARE
IS RESEARCH THE PEOPLE -- JUMP
ON WHEN THERE'S A MASS SHOOTING.
OF VOTE IN THEIRS THE LARGE
AMOUNT OF GUN RIGHTS AS IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT
LARGELY GOES IGNORED ON A DAILY
BASIS AND THAT SHOULD BE A
PRIMARY FOCUS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
DOCTOR MARTIN IS A VERY
INFORMATIVE PRESENTATION --
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS
FOCUSED ON WAS THERE IS A SECOND
WILL MEADOW VIEW AND DAHLE PASO
HEIGHTS.
SO IF YOU GO BACK. FOR FORTY OR
FIFTY YEARS RIGHT THAT IS BEEN
THE SAME IN ALL THE AREAS.
THEY PLAY PRETTY MUCH BEEN
PROVERBS FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
SO WE HAVE NUMBERS FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR INSTANCE YOU HAVE THEM
FROM THE CORNERS OFFICE HAVE YOU
HAVE YOU GONE BACK THOSE AREAS
THAT WERE SEVERELY IMPACTED. TO
SEE WITH THOSE NUMBER WORK
NUMBERS WERE BACK THEN.
THERE'S THERE'S A HISTORY OF LOW
TRUST.
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ME I
THINK WE'RE JUST SORT OF
STARTING TO SEE THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
BUT IT'S EXISTED. FOR A LONG
TIME AND I THINK NOW WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
IT'S SORT OF SHEDDING LIGHT ON
HOW EXTENSIVE THE PROBLEM REALLY
IS FAR AS NUMBERS GO SO.
DO YOU THINK I I AGREE WITH A
LOT OF YOUR POINTS THAT YOU SAID
HERE BUT ALSO.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN THOSE AREAS
ARE SO IMPOVERISHED RIGHT?
WHAT THE POLITICIANS DONE TO
HELP WITH THAT THAT TO ME THAT
PLAYS A PART IN IT TOO NOT
INVEST THOSE COMMUNITIES WHEN
THE SCHOOLS ARE IN PERFORMING?
I HAVE NO SUPERMARKETS NO BANKS
NO SPORTS PROGRAMS DOORS
PROGRAMS FOR KIDS.
THAT THAT PLAYS IN THE FACTOR
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
SECOND THE PICTURE YOU ADD
THERE'S OTHER AREAS WE DON'T SEE
THAT AT WELL THERE IS A WILL
MORE WEALTHIER.
SO IT COMES BACK STILL DO.
PART IS THAT INCOMING CALL
ANYTHING ELSE I MEAN WE'VE DONE
A LOT WE PASSED THROUGH.
NINETY TWO LIKE I SAID THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE IS
STILL WIDE OPEN SO NO ONE SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE FIVE YEARS AND
I'VE BEEN SACRAMENTO NO ONE EVER
TALKS ABOUT REVIVING THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
YES WE WILL BRING YOU READ IT
OUT DOWN THERE THROWING A TON OF
MONEY DOWNTOWN.
I WILL SAY NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
THE PROBLEMS ARE THERE IS ZERO
MONEY GOING TOWARDS THEIR AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WE AS DEMOCRATS
WORKS WE'RE SUPERMAJORITY HERE
SIXTY ONE OUT OF EIGHTY ASSEMBLY.
NO ONE EVER TALKS ABOUT THAT
PUTTING MONEY THERE THEY WANNA
PUT MONEY EVERYWHERE ELSE.
EXCEPT RULES NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO I MEAN CAN YOU CAN YOU JUST
ADDRESS THAT PART OF IT YEAH SO
I MEAN I ONLY HAVE FIFTEEN
MINUTES I HAD TO FOCUS ON YOUR
SHIRT THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
WHICH IS THE USE OF FORCE AND
ITS ROLE IN POLICING BUT THERE
IS.
RESEARCH AMONG SOCIOLOGISTS I
GIVE EXAMPLE IN PHILADELPHIA FOR
EXAMPLE THERE WERE HIGH A
NUMBERS OF HOMICIDES IN PARTS OF
PHILADELPHIA THAT HAD.
ABANDONED EMPTY LOTS AND SO WHAT
PEOPLE STARTED DOING IS -- THEY
STARTED IN EMBARKING ON
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT PUTTING
HOUSING PUTTING BUSINESSES IN
THOSE WANTS AND LO AND BEHOLD.
OF GUN VIOLENCE WENT DOWN SO
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THERE IS
SOME RESEARCH TO SHOW THAT IT
MATTERS IT ABSOLUTELY MATTERS
AND I THINK THAT HAS BEEN
OVERLOOKED BY A LOT OF GUN
VIOLENCE RESEARCHERS AND POLICY
MAKERS AS WELL AND IT HAS TO BE.
AT THE FOREFRONT AS WELL WE'RE
PUTTING SIX OR FIFTY BILLION
TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS.
BUT WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUE OR THE
MIDDLE HEALTH ISSUE THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE I CAN SCRATCH MY KNEE.
ARGUED A COUGH AND GO TO MED
CLINIC AND GET FIXED UP OF
SOMEONE'S HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THERE'S REALLY NO PLACE
TO GO.
AND IT THE STATE.
AND LOCALS DON'T REALLY FUND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT OR
MENTAL HEALTH WITH THAT.
CAN YOU SPEAK ON THAT.
SO YES OVER TALKING ABOUT -- GUN
VIOLENCE YOU KNOW -- THAT THAT
TENDS TO BE KIND OF A SMALLER
PERCENT OF PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
GUN VIOLENCE BUT COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND SERVICES ARE
CRITICAL FOR ANY HEALTHY
COMMITTEE THAT'S REALLY.
I THINK THE ANECDOTE TO IN
ADDITION TO BUILDING TRUST IS
BUILDING BUILDING UP HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES SO.
THAT I THINK ABSOLUTELY -- THERE
IS SOME RESEARCH THAT SHOWS A
BUILDING COMMUNITIES UP.
OF MAKE SOME MORE RESILIENT.
TO VIOLENT CRIME AND MAYBE AT
ANOTHER TIME I CAN COME AND
SPEAK MORE TO THAT ISSUE BUT I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE AND AND THERE
IS RESEARCH.
TO BACK UP WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING CURRENT THANK YOU I
WAS WAS VERY FOR MISTER CHAIR
HE'D.
HAD SOME -- VERY -- UNIQUE
INFORMATION SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
APPRECIATE IT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
BACK SO WHAT APPRECIATE ALSO I
WANT -- TO CONSUMER COOPER
FORGOT TO MAKE MENTION THAT HE
IS HE CHAIRS THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNITY RELATIONS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND SO IS HIS ROLE BEING ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE WITH ME IS VERY --
IMPORTANT BECAUSE HE BRINGS ALL
THAT PERSPECTIVE -- TO THIS
COMMITTEE TO HELPING US -- HAVE
A ROBUST CONVERSATION AS WELL AS
FINDING OUT REAL SOLUTIONS --
MOVING FORWARD -- DOCTOR
MARTINEZ IS ANY FINAL COMMENTS
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH US
BEFORE.
WE BRING UP OUR NEXT PANEL.
BUT I THINK THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
IT THANK YOU THANK YOU CAN USE
THE KEY HELP ME GIVE DOCTOR
MARTINEZ A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
FOR NEXT -- LIKE -- TO INVITE UP
TO THE PADDLE Là WILL BE
DEALING WITH A PERSONAL IMPACT
AND LOCAL SOLUTIONS -- WILL LIKE
TO INVITE A OKAY WHAT OUR MISTER
ACCU OF THE SEA [inaudible]
ACTUALLY ACCESS.
FTS PLEASE THANK YOU OF A VOICE --
OF THE YOUTH AND ALSO JOSH WHO --
JOSHUA ROBBINS PRESIDENT OF THE
BLACK STUDENT UNION OF
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND ALSO --
DOCTOR SHOW BE.
MOFFETT -- DIRECTOR OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CANADA IT
SCHOLARSHIP -- SCHOLAR PROGRAM
WAS A PLEASE -- JOIN ME AT THE
TABLE.
HEY THERE [inaudible]
YES.
SO WE HAVE FIFTY MINUTES FOR
YOUR PANEL -- IF WE COULD --
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
INITIAL CELLS FOR THE AUDIENCE.
AND JUST PURSUITS REPRESENTATION.
SURE -- MY NAME IS -- DOCTOR
SHELBY MOFFETT I AM A THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAñADA SCHOLARS PROGRAM I'M
CURRENTLY.
A PROFESSOR SEVERAL STATE
UNIVERSITY I AM A RETIRED
SEVERAL POLICE OFFICER NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS SO I TRY TO BRING
AS MUCH BACKGROUND AS YOU'D
MENTIONED -- NUMBER GIPSON AS
FAR AS OF FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER AND NOW I'M IN THE
ACADEMIC WORLD AS WELL AS BEING
A PERSON OF COLOR SO TRY TO GIVE
A COMPLETE PERSPECTIVE.
FEDERAL INTEGRATOR JUST CONTINUE
ON WE ARE.
VERY AXES -- FOUNDER VOICE OF
THE YOUTH COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS --
VERY MUCH A PART OF A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
REMEMBERING THE TIME IN -- TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHEN --
TRAYVON MARTIN WAS KILLED AND
THEN WHEN YOU HAD MIKE BROWN
KILLED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND SAYING TO OUR FORMER MAYOR.
THAT SACRAMENTO IS WINE NATIONAL
MOMENT.
OF BEING JUST LIKE FERGUSON AND
WITH A SMIRK HE SAID NO AND NOW
WE HAVE THE STUFF ON CLARK AS
MANY AS WELL AS MANY OTHER
OBJECTS HEARING SACRAMENTO MY
IDEA.
OF IDENTIFYING NOT ONLY THE
CAUSES OF THE VIOLENCE THAT HAS
BEEN INFLICTED ON ON AFRICAN
AMERICANS BY POLICE BUT HOLDING
A POLICE OFFICER ACCOUNTABLE
WHEN LETTING IT KNOWN.
THAT GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY -- IS ALSO POLICE
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
JOSH WILL ROBINSON A COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE STUDENT ORGANIZER
SECOND MOSTLY BECAUSE BLACKS IN
UNION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR MY OFFICE
WOULD YOU PLEASE START OUR
PRESENTATION SURE.
I I HEARD A DOCTOR MARTINEZ TALK
LOOK AT ABOUT A SACRAMENTO AND
SOMEWHAT THE HISTORY OF GUN
VIOLENCE ARE I HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT I AM THE A CREATOR AND
FOUNDER OF AGAIN AS I SAID IT'S
CALLED THE LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
AS SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
SO I'M HERE.
A DOCTOR MORE ABOUT SOLUTIONS
ANOTHER RETIREMENT GUN VIOLENCE
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THE WAYS I
TRIED -- TO CREE SOMETHING
BETTER BETTER OPTION FOR A YOUNG
WOMEN AND MEN THROUGHOUT THE
CITY SECOND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT I DID A HISTORICAL LOOK
BACK AGAIN AND THROUGH WRECKED
FIFTY PLUS YEARS AGO YOU HAD THE
COMMISSION THE ADVISORY
COMMISSION ON CIVIL DISORDER.
AND ONE OF THINGS THEY TALKED
ABOUT FIVE DECADES OR SO AGO WAS
THE FACT THAT.
AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINOS.
OF WERE IMPOVERISHED AND THEY
WERE POVERTY PRIMARILY BECAUSE
OF INSTITUTIONALIZED RACISM --
PRETTY MUCH IN THE KERNEL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE COUPLE
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY TALKED
ABOUT WE GIVE HEM BETTER
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES ONE
THINGS I BUY MORE TIME I TALKED
ABOUT AS WELL.
ALSO TO GET THEM A JOB IS ALL
ABOUT ECONOMICS WE LIVE IN A
CAPITALISTIC SOCIETY SO THESE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN NEED
EMPLOYMENT AND THEY SAID.
IF YOU'RE IN THE PRIMARY.
MARKET WE'RE AS FAR AS MAKING
WAGES YOU'RE GONNA DO OKAY IF
YOU'RE IN THE SECONDARY WAGE
LABOR MARKET YOU'RE GONNA NEED
ASSISTANCE GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE
AND THEN OF COURSE THOSE PERSONS
WHO DON'T MAKE AS MUCH AND DON'T
DO AS WELL.
DON'T HAVE A GOOD EDUCATION THE
LIKELIHOOD IS THEY'RE GONNA FIND
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY OR PRODUCTIVE
IS GOING TO FIND THEM.
SO ONE OF THINGS THAT I WAS
LOOKING.
FOR IS THAT WITH THE KERNER
REPORT -- THAT THEY WROTE UP
BACK IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT IT TALK ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE NEED TO DO
BETTER FOR THESE YOUNG MEN AN
WOMEN IN THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
AS WE DID HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BACK IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
WITH THE MASTER PLAN WHICH IS
WHY COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
A WHILE AGO WERE FREE -- THEY
ALSO TALK ABOUT AGAIN EMPLOYMENT
SOLD RECOMMENDATIONS WERE TO
FIND THESE FOLKS ARE JOB
PARTICULARLY IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GIVE THEM A JOB IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE LIKELIHOOD OF
ANOTHER PERSON OR PERSONS OF
COLOR.
BEING INVOLVED IN THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY IS GONNA LESSEN BECAUSE
THE ALL THE ARTICLE OR SOME OF
THE REPORT ALSO TALKED ABOUT AN
OCCUPATION OF ARM -- OFFICERS
PARTICULARLY -- WHITE OFFICERS
WERE INVOLVED IN PRIMARILY --
RACING AT THE MINORITY --
NEIGHBORHOODS TO SAY WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING AGAIN TO DEFUSE THE
TENSIONS WE NEED TO CREATE
GREATER DIVERSITY WILL ALSO NEED
TO CREATE A GREATER PUBLIC IMAGE
THOSE OF THE MAIN
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY TALKED
ABOUT.
BUT MANY OFFICES BACK IN THE
PAST TALKED ABOUT IS NOT OUR
PROBLEM NOW IS THE MANTRA WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT THIS ARE
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR PROPERTY
WHEN A RESPONSE OF RADICALISM.
WE'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE -- FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
SO.
I STARTED LOOKING AT FROM THAT
ASPECT OF HOW I WAS GOING TO
CREATE THE PROGRAM SO I STARTED
TALKING -- TO MANY OF MY
STUDENTS -- AND AND I WAS WONDER
WHY THEY WERE NOT GETTING JOBS.
IN ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THEY
WEREN'T GETTING JOBS WAS THAT.
THOSE WHO TRIED THEY STILL
DIDN'T HAVE A GOOD GRASP OF THE
LAW THE LEGAL SYSTEM THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT A CARAMEL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY.
SO LOOK TO THAT SAME WE NEED TO
DO A LOT BETTER WE NEED TO NOT
JUST HAVE THEM GO THROUGH THE
CLASSES THEN TRY TO APPLY TO
BECOME AN OFFICER.
THEN THERE LACK IN CERTAIN
SKILLS ALSO TALKED TO OFFICERS
ARE ALSO ON THE DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY ON THE DEPARTMENT THEY
TALKED ABOUT.
OF THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN ARE
NOT READY OR PREPARE FOR THE
RIGORS OF THE JOB -- THEY MAY
PASSED THE CLASSES THEY STILL
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WERE THE
IMPORTANT SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
THINGS HAPPENING.
IN LHASA TALK TO ME IN THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND THEY WERE
TELLING ME THAT THE OFFICES IT
DID PASS AND DO WELL.
THEY DO NOT HAVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY ONE OF THINGS I LIKE
TO SAY THEY DIDN'T HAVE NOT HAVE
THE CULTURE HUMILITY.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE SOCIAL
CULTURAL AND EMOTIONAL ASPECTS
OF WHAT IT WAS LIKE FOR PERSONS
PARTICULAR OF COLOR -- TO
WORKING THERE SO THAT THAT'S
WERE PRETTY MUCH GOT THE IMPETUS
TO CREATE THE PROGRAM THAT I
HAVE TODAY SO WHAT THE LAW FOR
SOME KIND OF SCHOLARS PROGRAM IS.
IT IS A A PATHWAY PROGRAM TO
CREATE GREATER ACCESS AND
AWARENESS. TO THESE YOUNG FOLKS
SO CREATED A COMBINATION OF TENT
WORKSHOPS FOR THEM DID VERY FROM
LEADERSHIP -- TEST PREP.
OUR LITTLE WE HAVE A A WOMAN WHO
COMES IN VISIT EVERY YEAR SHE'S
A RETIRED ENGLISH TEACHER.
SHE WILL TEST THEM ON HOW TO
PASS THE EXAM WE HAVE LEADERS
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE UNITED STATES
TO COME IN AND TELL THEM ABOUT
THE NOBILITY OF POLICING AND
WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
AND WHAT'S THE IMPORTANCE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS MONEY MANY OF
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN THAT
IDEA WITH PARTICULARLY IN
COLLEGE BUT ALSO GO TO THE HIGH
SCHOOLS.
AND ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS AS WELL.
THEY'VE GOTTEN A SOME SOMEWHAT
OF THE NOT THE GREAT THE
GREATEST NEAR TO THE LAW FOR SIN
AS YOU'RE PROBABLY GOING TO HEAR.
SO IF YOU ASK MANY PEOPLE AND
REYES WHETHER MINORITY COMMUTE
PREDOMINATELY OUR OUR RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE DIFFICULT OF THE COPS
AND ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO PUBLIC
TRUST WE DON'T TRUST THE COPS.
SO WHEN TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M
IMPACT THEM AS BEST I CAN TO
GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AND ALSO ONE OF THEM
HAVE ACCESS. TO LONG FOR SAUCES
ARE SELF.
WHEN I ATTENDED?
SOME SCHOOLS IN THE PAST ONE OF
THE THINGS I TALKED AS YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN ABOUT IN -- IN HIGH
SCHOOL I ASK THEM HOW MANY OF
YOU WANT TO BE A LAW FOR SAUCE.
AND MANY OF THE CLASS WILL BE
8090% OF CLASS RAISE OUR HANDS
BUT THEN I ASK THEM HOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE BEEN APPROACHED BY A
LONG FORCE ALSO TO ADD TO HELP
YOU BECOME AN OFFER AND NONE AND
RAISE YOUR HANDS AND THAT'S
WRESTLE THE DISCONNECT.
IS THAT EVERYONE WILL SAY OH YES
YES I AM THIS I WANT TO HELP I
WANT TO PARTICIPATE BUT THEY DID
NOTHING AFTER THAT.
AND THIS IS WHAT THE PROGRAM
DOES IT CONNECTS.
THESE YOUNG FOLKS TO MAKE THEM
OF MORE -- PREPARED AND MORE
ADVANCE SO THEY CAN BECOME GREAT
CADETS AND MOVE INTO -- LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO.
THE PROGRAM IS ALL ABOUT WHAT I
CALL A WEED AND SEED AFFECT.
I REALIZE THAT AND WHAT'S
CURRENTLY HAPPENING NOW.
THAT CHANGE AS FAST BUT I'M
HOPING THAT THE YOUNG OFFICES
THAT I'VE ALREADY PUT THROUGH
AND HAD GONE TO THE SECOND
PLEASED FORMS ACADEMY AND CAL
FOR HER PATROLS ACADEMY.
BUT I CAN GET THEM. TO BE BETTER
PREPARED MORE CULTURALLY DIVERSE
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY TO DEAL
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AS ONE
OF THINGS WE DO WE WORK ON A LOT
IS -- MENTAL HEALTH PREPARATION
WE HAVE BEEN GOING TO THE
ACADEMY'S WERE THEIR TRAINING
AND PREPARING TO DEAL ALL
ASPECTS OF LIFE AND TO DEAL
PARTICULARLY WITH THOSE IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHERE THERE
ARE.
DISADVANTAGES WHETHER THEY BE
SOCIAL CULTURAL ADVANTAGES
THAT'S JUST.
PART OF THE PART OF WHAT THE
PROGRAM DOES AND IT'S A IT'S A
TWO YEAR PROGRAM THAT GETS THEM
THROUGH COLLEGE -- THE GRADUATE
THE CAT THEIR DEGREE THE GOING
TO THE ACADEMY AND OF COURSE WE
HAVE THE MORE WELL PREPARED IN
THE AND WE KNOW IT'S BEEN A
SUCCESS HAS BEEN GONE FOR THREE
YEARS.
AND WHAT WE'VE HAD SO FAR IS THE
FACT IT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS THAT
HAVE GRADUATED -- THEY'VE GONE
ON BEEN AND DONE VERY WELL THUS
FAR IN THE PLEASE PROMISE AND
WE'RE OPEN TO THE YEARS TO COME
THEY CAN DO MUCH BETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS ATKINS --
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HISTORY WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY GET DEEPER
INTO THE HISTORY OF POLICING?
IN AMERICA FIRST ALL LIKE TO SAY
THAT POLICING IN AMERICA.
IS A PUBLIC EPIDEMIC OF KILLING.
OF GENOCIDE ALL OF ONE WARRANTED
ARRESTS -- BIAS.
pGUILTY.
BOB OFFICERS THAT KILL.
BLACK PEOPLE.
THIS LABEL TROLL.
IF WE LOOK AT OUR HISTORY THE
SLAVE PATROL WAS ORGANIZED AN
ORGANIZED GROUP OF WHITE MEN WHO
MONITORED AND ENFORCED
DISCIPLINE UPON BLACK SLAVES.
THEIR MAIN FUNCTION WAS POLICE
THE SLAVING FOR SLAVE COLDS
PREVENT.
LARGE GATHERINGS INSTALL FEAR
AND CATCH ONE WAYS.
SLEEPER TROLLS LED DIRECTLY INTO
THE KKK.
AND NOW AS WE SEE OR MARTIN DAY.
POLICE SYSTEM.
SEOUL IF WE'RE GOING TO DIVE
INTO THE HISTORY OF POLICING
LET'S NOT FORGET THE ORIGIN OF
POLICING AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE KIND TO DEFER.
IN A SENSE OF UNDERSTANDING THAT.
TRAINING.
OVER AND OVER AND HAVING A
DIVERSE POLICE FORCE WOULD ALL
OF A SUDDEN CREATE THIS CHANGE
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT.
WE'VE HEARD IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN MATTER OF FACT A LOT OF
OUR FUNDING GOALS INTO EXTRA
POLICE TRAINING.
AND TO NO AVAIL.
AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE MORE
BLACK BODIES LAY DOWN DEAD IN
THE STREET.
SO I ASKED THIS QUESTION WHAT IS
REALLY TRAINING.
AND WHO WAS DOING THE TRAINING.
AND WHY DO WE CONSIDER TO THINK
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
BLACK OFFICERS THINGS WILL
CHANGE.
I POINT THIS DIRECTION BECAUSE
EVERY TIME. FIVE I'VE WOKEN UP.
IN THE LAST WEEK.
I'VE HEARD THIS THING.
AND IT CONFUSES ME.
IT SAYS A BLUE LIVES MATTER.
SO THAT RIGHT THERE PARTICULARLY
TELLS ME THAT ANY OFFICER BLACK
WHITE OR IN DIFFERENT WHO PUTS
ON A UNIFORM.
IS NOW CONSIDERED A BLUE LIFE IS
NO LONGER CONSIDERED A BLACK MAN
OR BLACK WOMEN OR LATINO MAN A
LATINO WOMAN THEY'RE CONSIDERED
BLUE.
AND THIS SAME NOTION OF BLUE
LIVES MATTER CAME IN A DIRECT
CORRELATION OF ATTACKING THE
MOVEMENT A CAMPAIGN THAT SAID
BLACK LIVES MATTER BECAUSE BLACK
LIVES MATTER BUT IT WAS NOT
BEING SHOWN ACROSS AMERICA WHEN.
NUMEROUS KILLINGS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHAT'S HAPPENING.
FROM THE TIME OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN TO CURRENTLY IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SO WHEN WE
DECIDE TO HAVE THE REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT POLICING IN
AMERICA LET'S GO BACK TO OUR
HISTORY.
POLICE WERE CONSIDERED SLAVE
PATROL ACHEI A SLAVE CATCHERS.
THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED AS BLACK
PEOPLE.
BY THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN TO BE
TARGETS.
NO KIND OF TRAINING.
CAN DEVELOP THE CHANGEABLE
CULTURE.
FILLED WITH BIAS.
PREJUDICE AND LED BY CERTAIN
STEREO TYPES SO YOU CAN BE A
BLACK MAN TRAINING.
YOU COULD BE A BLACK POLICE
OFFICER BUT AS SOON AS YOU PUT
THAT BACK I JOIN YOU CONSIDER TO
BE BLUE.
AS A BLUE LIFE WHO LOSES THEIR
LIFE IN THE CALL OF THEIR DUTY.
IS CONSIDERED A HERO.
NOT MATTER IN IF THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN THE FIELD FOR TWO
WEEKS OR BEEN A A A A PRODUCTIVE
OFFICER FOR TWENTY YEARS.
THEY'RE CONSIDERED A HERO.
BUT WHEN A BLACK LIFE IS TOOK IT
AWAY BY A POLICE OFFICER FOR
KNOLL REASON WHATSOEVER BECAUSE
OF THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
AUTOMATICALLY IN MEDIA.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE POLICE HAVE
NOW REPORTED TO MEDIA OR
WHATEVER THE MEDIA DECIDES TO
PUT OUT THEY ARE CALLED.
CRIMINALS.
AND THEIR SUSPECTS.
WHAT IN ONE REGARD ON OFFER
SERVERS ALWAYS CALL THE HERO?
AND EVEN OFFER SO WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW IF THEY REALLY WERE HERE --
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SO WHEN WE LOOK.
AND WE WE CHALLENGED THESE IDEAS
THESE CONTENT IDEAS OF TRAINING
MORE TRAINING DIVERSE CITY
DIVERSE CITY WE HAVE PLENTY.
BLACK POLICE CHIEFS.
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE BLACK MARKS.
AND IF WE LOOK AND SAY
[inaudible]
WELL.
MAYBE IN BALTIMORE.
THAT HAS A BLACK POLICE CHIEF
THERE WEREN'T THAT MANY MURDERS
OF BLACK PEOPLE I CHALLENGE THE
FACT THAT.
ANY MURDER OF A BLACK PERSON ON
ARM IS MORE THAN WE NEED THERE
SHOULD NOT BE ONE MURDER.
SO THE FACT THAT WE ARE
CHALLENGING OURSELVES A FIGURE
THAT WE'VE HAD LESS.
MURDERS IN CERTAIN CITIES AND
APPLAUDING OURSELVES IS
RIDICULOUS.
IT'S FRUSTRATING AND IT ANGERS
ME THAT WE HAVE JUST
CONTINUOUSLY HAD THESE
COMMITTEES THESE CONVERSATIONS
AND ONE THING HASN'T BEEN DONE.
WHEN POLICE VIOLATE THE COLDER
PROTECTING AND SERVING WHEN THE
POLICE?
USED EXCESSIVE FORCE WHEN POLICE
DO NOT HAVE THEIR BODY CAMERAS
INDIVIDUALS THIRTY SOME ODD
TIMES AND DON'T HAVE A REAL
REASON OF WHY THEY SHOT AN
UNARMED BLACK PERSON THIRTY ALL
TIMES.
WE HAVE THAT POLICE OFFICER
CONTINUING TO WALK OUR STREETS.
WE HAVE NO GUILTY VERDICTS.
WE HAVE NO TRANSPARENCY.
AND POLICE RARELY SEE A NIGHT IN
JAIL.
THE FUNNY THING IS POLICE
ACTUALLY GET CELEBRATED WHEN
THEY'RE KILLED ON ON OFFICER
THEY GET GOAL FUNDING THESE.
DAVE BASICALLY HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT THEY ARE HEROES AND THEY
DID THE RIGHT THING THEY PUT
SERVE THEM BE PROTECTED THE
COMMUNITY.
THE SAME COMMUNITY THAT THESE
POLICE OFFICERS CONTINUE
[inaudible] TO REGULATE.
CONTINUE TO TERRORIZE.
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH IS POLICE TERROR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AS I'VE WORKED WITH.
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND ASKING ME WHY MY SON.
AND I THINK BACK OF DARYL
RICHARDS.
WHO I SPOKE TO THE MOTHER JUST
THE OTHER DAY?
WELL SHE HAD A SURE ON IN
CONTINUES ASK ME WHY.
SHE HAS NO IDEA.
AND FOR HER TO WATCH
[inaudible]
THE CELEBRATING [inaudible]
THIS OFFICER.
WHO WAS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY?
ED FOR HER SON.
SHE NOT.
GOT A SORRY [inaudible]
AN APOLOGY.
SHE GOT TOLD OR SOME WITH THE
SUSPECT.
AND OUR SON CAN NEVER COME BACK.
I THINK ABOUT A MARSHALL MILES.
WHOSE MOTHER PLAYED.
AND ASKED THE SHERIFF TO PLEASE
BRING HIM INTO A FACILITY. TO
GET TO MEDICAL ASSISTANCE. TO NO
AVAIL THEY SENT HIM TO THE
COUNTY JAIL.
AND LATER ON HE WAS HOG TIED.
BROUGH REALIZE IN HIS CELL IS
THIS WHAT WE CALL GOOD TRAINING.
THIRTY SECONDS I THINK ABOUT
[inaudible]
STEFAN CLARK.
GOING BACK HOME TO HIS
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE.
BEING CALLED A SUSPECT IN BEING
TOLD. TO THE MEDIA SAYING THAT.
HE WAS A PERSON THAT BROKE
WINDOWS.
AND I ASKED DOES MURDER
CONSTITUE BREAKING WINDOWS.
HIS GRANDMOTHER.
HIS MOTHER [inaudible]
HIS BROTHER.
MOVES WITH THE DEATH OF STEP ON
CLARK AS THE CITY MOVES WITH THE
DEFICIT UP ON CLARK I THINK
ABOUT BRANDON SMITH.
WHO WAS ALSO?
KILLED BY POLICE OFFICERS.
BECAUSE OF HIS INCIDENT.
I ASKED WASTHIS AGAIN CONSIDER
GOOD TRAINING.
SO MIGHT AS I IN THIS.
I SAY THAT IF WE DON'T IDENTIFY
THE PROBLEM IS WE ARE NO LONGER
WAITING. FOR WHAT.
MY GOOD PUBLIC PEOPLE HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO TO
CHANGE WE ARE DEMANDING THAT YOU
START FIRING.
POLICE OFFICERS GETTING
MANDATORY DRUG TESTING TWO
POLICE OFFICERS WHO USE THEIR
FIREARMS AND NOT WAIT IT
CONTINUE TO ALLOW COMMUNITIES TO
COME BACK. TO THESE ASSEMBLY
MEETINGS COR CREATE MARCHES AND
TO TALKING TO PETITION ABOUT WHY
OUR LIVES MATTER DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT AND THAT'S HOW YOU STOP.
POLICE.
KILLINGS OF BLACK PEOPLE AND
OTHER MINORITIES THANK YOU
AS WE
CONTINUE DOWN THE TIMELINE AND
WE GO TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
AND TODAY WE COMMAND MARTIN
LUTHER KING FOR BEING ONE OF THE
GREATEST CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVISTS
OF THIS TIME.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PICTURES.
IT WAS POLICE WHO WAS OFTENTIMES
THE ADVERSARY OF MARTIN LUTHER
KING AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WE HEROES CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST
TO THIS DAY.
SO TO CULTURAL POLICING IS NOT
BEING TALKED ABOUT A POLICE ARE
NOT BEING TRAINED ON THEIR OWN
CULTURE.
I WAS ACTUALLY WANTED PEOPLE WHO
WAS ARRESTED IN A FAIR FORTIES
RIGHT.
AND WHILE WE SAT ON A BRIDGE FOR
HOURS MY BROTHER WAS.
HE WAS WITH ME MY YOUNGER
BROTHER AND I BY SOME NOT TO
TALK TO THE POLICE BECAUSE WHEN
YOU SAY THINGS SOMETIMES THE USE
THAT AGAINST YOU.
IN A COURT OF LAW BUT HE CAME
OUT HE KEPT TRYING TO EDUCATE
THE POLICE ON WILL YOU KNOW THE
THE ORIGINS OF POLICE ARE RIGHT.
YOU KNOW THAT YOU STARTED AS
LAKE CATCHES YOU NOTICE COOL AND
THE POLICE WERE OBLIVIOUS TO
THIS KNOWLEDGE.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THE
FOUNDATION OF POLICING.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
HISTORY OF THEIR RELATIONS
WITHIN BLACK COMMUNITIES AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES.
SO WHERE BLACK PEOPLE REAL
PEOPLE TRUST THE POLICE.
WHAT ARE THE POLICE LOOKING AT
IT IS ALWAYS A NEGATIVE CULTURE?
DON'T HAVE A CULTURE OF NOT
TRUSTING THE BUT ARE YOU BE A
TRAINED IN YOUR FUNDAMENTAL A
MANDATORY TRAINING ON YOUR
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
NOW I REALLY APPRECIATE IT WOULD
THAT THE MARTINEZ SAID TO SAY
BECAUSE HE BROUGHT UP SOME
REALLY GOOD POINTS.
SOME OF WEEKS.
HE TALKED ABOUT.
GUN VIOLENCE REALLY BEING A
PRODUCT THE LOW RESOURCES
ALCOHOL DRUG ABUSE -- POOR
EDUCATION PIC POLICE COMMUNITY
RELATIONS AND MENTAL HEALTH.
AND SO AGAIN WE FOLLOW THE
TIMELINE AND WE LOOK AT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN POLICE AND
COMMUNITY.
GUN VIOLENCE WITH THEIR POLICE
HAS A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP IN OUR
COMMUNITIES YOU COULD.
YOU CAN TRACE POLICE GUN
VIOLENCE AND POLICE MURDER OTHER
BLACK PEOPLE BACK TO THEIR
FOUNDATION.
BUT IT ALSO HAS AN INDIRECT
RELATIONSHIP WITH BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES RIGHT SO AFTER
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT HAD A
BLACK POWER MOVEMENT WE HAD A
WHOLE BUNCH OF BLACK ACTIVIST
MIGHT AFFECT WE HAD A WHOLE
ORGANIZATION.
THAT WAS CREATED A WHOLE
ORGANIZATION OF BLACK STUDENTS
OKAY FOR TO SAY LOOK THIS GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
TO STOP.
THE ORGANIZATIONS KNOW THE BLACK
PANTHER PARTY.
NOON WHEN HE GOT HIS EDUCATION
HE GOT HIS DOCTORATE EDUCATE THE
WITH THE DOCTOR.
AND FOR SOME REASON INSTEAD OF
STANDING WITHIN THE ACADEMY
INSTEAD OF JOINING WITHIN SOME
OF THE SYSTEM TO CAME BACK WITH
COMMUNITY CREATED AND A WHOLE
ORGANIZATION DEAL WITH POLICE
GUN VIOLENCE IN THAT COMMUNITY.
THIS IS DOCUMENTED HISTORY.
SO WHAT WAS THE PLEASES RESPONSE
TO IT THEY ANALYZE HOW THEY
PARTICIPATE WITH A GUN VIOLENCE
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEY SAY WELL LET'S LET'S CHECK
OUT SOME OF THE REASONS WE
CHANGED SOME OF OUR POLICIES WE
HAVE MORE TRAINING NO.
THEY WENT UNDER COVER Q. THESE
BLACK PANTHER PARTY MEMBERS THE
STUDENTS AND AFTER THEIR THE
GOVERNMENT OF WHICH THE POLICE
IS COMPLICIT WHICH WAS A PART OF
THE CIA CONTRA SCANDAL WAS PUT
DRUGS INTO OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND BROKE UP FAMILIES AND HELP
SUPPORT MASS INCARCERATION.
SO THESE THESE.
THESE THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALCOHOL ABUSE DRUG ABUSE
EDUCATION POLICE COMMUNITY
RELATIONS MENTAL HEALTH THAT'S A
BY PRODUCT OF A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
SIXTIES SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
THE POLICE HAVE A DIRECT.
INDIRECT CONTRIBUTION TO THAT
WHOLE MORE.
TODAY DAMAGE TO THEIR
DESTRUCTION.
IT'S SO WHEN WE START TALKING
ABOUT REPAIR TOWARD JUSTICE WE
START TALKING ABOUT REPARATIONS
POLICE TO BE FRONTLINE ANNALS
CONVERSATION.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE FRONT
LAWN IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS THEY
SHOULD TRAIN OFF TO THE SAY WELL
LOOK YOU KNOW WE'RE ABOUT
PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES TO BUT WE
HAVE HAD A HAND.
IN RACISM WE HAVE HAD A HAND IN
VIOLENCE WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE HAVE DESTROYED SOME
THINGS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE
HAVE WE ORDER PRIMARY
DESTRUCTION OF THE TRUST WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
UNIQUE POLICE AFTER ALL NAY
UNTIL POLICE ARE READY TO ALL
NET ANY TALK WITH DIVERSE CITY
THAT WE HAVE WILL BE TRAINED OFF
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAVE
TODAY.
THE BLACK PEOPLE HAVE A NEGATIVE
CULTURE THAT WE DON'T TRUST
POLICE OFFICERS BUT THERE'S NO
REASONING AS TO WHY WE DON'T
TRUST POLICE OFFICERS THERE'S NO
REASONING AS TO WHY THIS CULTURE
HAS BEEN CORRUPTED OVER THE LAST.
TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE
IS AS MUCH AS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT NOW BACK IN THE FIFTIES
FORTIES AND THIRTIES WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THE DRUG VIOLENCE THAT IS
THE GREAT A CULTURE.
THAT PEOPLE LIKE TO PUT ON THE
BLACK COMMUNITY WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT IS A BY PRODUCT OF THE
EIGHTIES THE CRACK COCAINE
EPIDEMIC AND THE VIOLENCE THAT
CONSISTED WITHIN IT.
A POLICE HAVE TO TAKE ACCOUNT
STATE IT WE PLAYED A HAND WITHIN
THAT IS WILL.
THEY HAVE TO IF THERE'S NO REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT THEN
THERE'S NO REAL CONVERSATION AT
ALL IS PANDERING GUESS LET'S
TAKE PICTURES THAT THE COMMUNITY
CENTER.
LET'S START TALKING THE KEY IS
LET'S TRY TO GET SOME MORE BLACK
PEOPLE SOME MORE BLACK FACES ON
ON A ON OUR PLATE ME.
LET LET'S GET SOME PEOPLE IN THE
PICTURES THAT'S WHAT IT IS WE
HAVE TO START TALKING ABOUT
REPAIRING THESE RELATIONSHIPS.
AND PUSH A POLICY THAT REPAIRS
IT IS WILL.
WE LIGHT LIKE I SAY I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A PICTURE THE STEP WHEN
IT COMES TO PASS A POLICY THAT
COMMUNITIES ADVOCATE FOR WE
TALKED ABOUT POLICE UNION
SUPPORT IN THINGS LIKE
REPARATIONS.
SUPPORT THINGS LIKE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE SUPPORT THINGS LIKE --
NOT LETTING -- FAMILIES
NONVIOLENT FELONS MARK IN IT BOX
ONE EIGHT GO TRY TO GET A JOB TO
GET SOME RESOURCES PLEASE YOUNG
IS OFTEN TIMES AGAINST THE SIDES
OF POLICIES.
SO YOU'RE NOT FOR ANY TYPE OF
RESTORATIVE REPAIR TôI JUSTICE
YOU JUST WANT PEOPLE TO BE QUIET.
THIRTY SECONDS.
I'M THE RIGHT THERE.
THANK YOU LIST.
LET ME SAY THAT THE BATTLE
CERTAINLY GIVEN US A YEAR FULL
AND I APPRECIATE THE PASSION.
AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE -- WHAT
YOU'VE COMMUNICATED THAT THUS
FAR I WANT TO ASK TO THE BODY --
THE PANEL -- QUESTION WHOEVER
WANTS TO CHOOSE TO A RESPOND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO DO SO -- IS
ONE OF THINGS WE TRYING IS IS
GAP INFORMATION AGAIN NOTES ARE
BEING -- SUBSCRIBE AND IN TAKEN
SO WE CAN CAPTURE -- ALL OF YOUR
THOUGHTS THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
VIDEO TAPE SO WE CAN GO BACK AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE PICKED UP OF
ALL THE POINTS YOU BROUGHT OUT.
BUT IN TERMS OF SOLUTION -- HOW
HOW CAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
CANDIDATES BE TRAINED BETTER IN
HIGH STAKES SITUATIONS -- SO
THAT GUN VIOLENCE IS NOT THE
FIRST.
RESORT.
HOW CAN PLEASE OFFICES RETRAIN?
SO THAT -- GUN VIOLENCE IS NOT
THE FIRST RESORT NOW CERTAINLY
DOCTOR WHEREVER PUT FOR THE BILL --
THREE NINETY TWO IS GOING TO LET
THAT PROCESS AND IT ALSO THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL DELIVER TRAINING --
WHICH SB TWO THIRTY TO GIVE ME
YOUR THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF HOW DO
WE ADDRESS THE TRAINING ASPECT
OF IT -- FROM YOUR LANDS.
WELL -- LIKE A LIKE I MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS IS A SOLUTIONS
BASED I UNDERSTAND I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO FIND A SOLUTION
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE AGAIN WE'RE NOT A
MONOLITH WE ALL DON'T HAVE THE
SAME IDEAS AS SAME UNDERSTAND MY
PROGRAM THAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW.
IS SEXUAL STATE.
THE MAJORITY OF THE STUDENTS
INVOLVED OF THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BAD THUS FAR WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE 80% A RECENT OF
MINORITIES THEY HAVE TOLD ME
STORIES.
OF OVER AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT HOW
THEIR PARENTS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS IN TRAFFIC STOPS
INVESTIGATION ONE OF THINGS THAT.
IT TELLS ME.
IS THAT IN SPITE OF THE TERRIBLE
OR RIFIC THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN
THEIR PAST ARE CURRENTLY
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE LIKE
I SAY I I WOULD BE IN THE SAME
CATEGORY.
THEY HAVE NOT GIVEN UP THEY ARE
SAID I WANT TO DO BETTER NOT
ONLY FOR MY FAMILY BUT FROM OUR
FRIENDS AND AND FOR MY COMMUNITY
AND THAT'S WHAT THE PROGRAM DOES
US WHY SOME PORN ABOUT.
TRYING TO CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY
YOU CAN LOOK ANY DAY OF THE WEEK
YOU CAN LOOK ON YOUTUBE OR LOOK
ON GOOGLE OR SOMEPLACE.
AND SEE A SOCIAL MEDIA OF VIDEO
OVER OFFICERS ARE DOING TERRIBLE
THINGS NO WAS DISCOUNTING THAT
THE DOING TERRIBLE THINGS MY
GOLDEN MY MY OBJECTIVE IS. TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE TO CHANGE
ALL TERM SAY YES THIS IS WHY WE
NEED A PROGRAM LIKE THIS TO GET
RID OF A REMOVED ELIMINATE.
THESE BAD OFFICERS SO IF YOU GET
A POINTS AND THEIR BAD I GET
THAT.
WHEN YOU DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INVIGORATE THE NEXT GENERATION
TO HELP PREPARE THESE YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN BECAUSE YOU TAKE THE
ATTITUDE OF?
I HATE THEM THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HELP ME THEN THE ONLY THING YOU
HAVE LEFT AS WE GET TO THE POINT
OF AN ARC AND I DON'T WANT TO
GET IN THAT POINT ONE CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT AGAIN USE ARE
IMPORTANT IN THIS COUNTRY AND
LAW FORCING THE POOR TO PROTECT.
AND TO SERVE SO THAT'S WHAT WE
DON'T WORK ON A MENTAL HEALTH
ASPECT OF ALSO WORKED ON
CULTURAL COMPANIES AND I REPEAT
THAT OVER OVER AGAIN ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WE HAVE.
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHATEVER
THESE -- MEN TO COME AND CAN
TALK TO THE STUDENTS AT IT'S NOT
ABOUT WHO YOUR WE WANT THEM TO
LISTEN TO EVERY ASPECT EVERY
PERSON I TALKED TO IN AMERICA OR
ON THE STREETS A SEGMENT WHEN I
WORKED.
I WANNA MAKE SURE THESE YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN AND THAT'S
WHAT THE PROGRAM IS ALL ABOUT
HOW DO WE ADDRESS WHEN IT COMES
OUT TO PLEASE OFFICER TRAINING
ABOUT -- SENSITIVITY TRAINING
SPECIAL IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THIS DIVISION RAIN IS EXTREMELY
POOR BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
A LOOK THE POLICE CULTURE ITSELF.
IS BASED ON PROBABLY THREE
pTHE POLICE.
CHIEF HIM OR HERSELF.
WHAT HE SAYS OR WHAT SHE SAYS
MATTERS -- I'VE BEEN AROUND.
CHIEFS IN THE PAST THEY'VE BEEN
ASKED ABOUT THE RACISM THE
TRAFFIC STOP THAT HAVE AN EXCESS
NGUYEN AND RACIAL MINORITY ARE
RAISING OF MINORITY COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY -- BLACK AND LATINO.
AND THEY ALSO SAID YOU THINK
YOU'RE DEPARTMENTS RACES AND THE
CHIEF RESPONDED BY SAYING.
WELL WE HAVE ISSUES OKAY THAT
WAS RESPONSE EVEN SAY WE ARE
RACES HE JUST THAT WE HAVE
ISSUES HE WAS TRYING.
TO WATER DOWN I GUESS IS THE
ANSWER THEN THEY ASKED ME WELL
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO WHAT WOULD
YOU CAN DO WHAT'S YOUR SOLUTION.
AND HE HE HE HIM AND HAUNTING
FINALLY SAID WELL MOST OF WHAT
WE DO IS CORRECT AND I GOT
CONCERNED WHEN I ACTUALLY READ
THAT WE SAID MOST WHAT WE DO IS
A FIFTY POINT 1% IS IT 708090%
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE CONCERNS
EVEN AS I AS A BLACK.
OFFICER THAT I HAD TO DO WITH IN
THE SUIT SACRAMENTO I'M STILL
LOOK FOR MY TOOK MY UNIFORM OFF
A LOOK THE SAME AS ANYONE ELSE
WHATEVER OF CULT AND I'M SURE
THE SAME THING HAPPEN TO YOU TOO
WHEN YOU'RE IN UNIFORM.
SO YOU HAVE A ROLE I HAVE I'M
TRYING TO DO WITH OTHERS AS WELL
TO MENTOR.
THESE YOUNG MEN TO DO THE RIGHT
THING SO THE CHIEF.
HIS POLICIES ARE HER POLICIES
AND THEN IT'S THE RANK AND FILE
THE RANK AND FILE DO WHATEVER
THE CHIEF SAYS.
SO IF WE CAN CHANGE THE CULTURE
OF THE CHIEF OKAY AND GET HIM
AND HER OR REMEMBER TO SAY IT'S
NOT MY PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT HAVE
THE DATA THAT WE HEARD FROM --
DOCTOR MARTINEZ AND OTHERS TO
TELL ABOUT THEIR STORES NO ONCE
ELIMINATE THE STORES THAT'S NOT
THE POINT THE POINT IS TO SAY
WHAT WE DO WITH THIS INFORMATION
HOW WE'RE GONNA GO FOR IT AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO.
WITH THE PROGRAM THAT'S WHY SAID
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL THUS FAR
BECAUSE THE GROUP OF PEOPLE THEY
COULD THEY READ THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY YEARS OF AGE.
THEY COULD EASILY SAY.
I DON'T LIKE HOPS WITH THESE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
COME FROM LOW ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS MOST IN THE IN THE
PROGRAM THEY SAID.
I WANT THE OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO
IS CHANGE THE OUTCOME AND HOPE
AND THEY DO THE SAME THING.
WHO YOU TRYING TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME?
FOR I'M NOT.
I'M JUST SAYING.
I JUST I KNOW I I KEEP WE KEEP
ON HEARING THE SAME KINDA LIKE.
IT'S GOING BACK TO TRAINING
TRAINING TRAINING THE OUTCOME
HAS TO BE.
OUR MY BOTTOM LINE SOLUTION IS
YOU HAVE TO FIRE THE OFFICERS --
WHEN THEY'RE BEING TRAINED THEY
HAVE TO KNOW?
THAT THERE'S A CERTAIN POLICY OF
YOU BREAK YOU WILL GET FIRED YOU
GET TERMINATED.
AND THAT'S NOT BEING DONE
BECAUSE OF THE POWERFUL POLICE
UNION BECAUSE THE POLICE BILL OF
RIGHTS THESE THINGS THAT ARE IN
PLACE THIS POLICIES THAT ARE IN
PLACE THAT PROTECT POLICE.
SO WE KEEP ON TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO TRAIN PEOPLE TO NOT BE
RACIST.
TRYING TO REPROGRAM A CULTURE
THAT HAVE PROBABLY BEEN THERE
BEFORE CHIEF WE HAD ARMED POLICE
SUMMERS THAT WAS HERE BEFORE --
CHIEF HAN WAS HERE CHIEF HAN
JUST CAME INTO ANOTHER QUOTE TO
ARE THE CULTURAL SUMMERS HE HAS
TO TAKE YEARS TO CREATE THE
CULTURE HE'S TRYING TO IDENTIFY
WHICH THE REALITY IS WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH.
IS IF THERE IS NO ALL
CONSEQUENCES POLICE CONTINUE TO
RUN ROLE.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE WE HAD A
LAW THAT WOULD BE THE PLACE FOR
THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO SEE WHO
ARE THE OFFICERS THAT HAVE HAD --
YOU'LL MISCONDUCT AND IT WAS A
FIGHT FOR EVEN THAT TO COME OUT
AND THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
BEING PLACED IN LAW FORGET WHAT
THE LAW WAS.
BUT IT WAS JUST PASSED LAST YEAR
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO SEE THE
OFFICERS THAT HAD MISCONDUCT ON
THAT WERE MISPLACED WITH THIS
THAT.
I FORGET.
OKAY YOU SAID THANK YOU SO THESE
KIND OF THINGS WHEN YOU HAVE A A
WHOLE COLLECTION OF OFFICERS
THROUGHOUT AMERICA NOT JUST HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE WILLING
TO PROTECT THEIR OWN.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SERVICE
SINGING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BETTER TRAINING THIS IS NOT
GOING TO WORK IT'S EASY FOR
POLICE OFFICER TO TO GIVE OUT
TURKEYS AT ON THANKSGIVING IT'S
EASY FOR POLICE OFFICERS TO GIVE
OUT BIKES ON CHRISTMAS WHEN
THESE KIDS ARE FIVE YEARS OLD.
WHEN THAT KID NOW BECOMES
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DEAL WITH THAT NUMBER
TO BE PUSHED BACK ON ON
SOMETHING YOU SAID?
IS IT PUT TRAINING WON'T WORK
WHAT TELL ME WHAT WILL WORK
BECAUSE BY YOUR THE OFFICERS
THAT COULD MEET.
VIS A NEUTRAL SHOES THINGS THAT
HAPPEN TO OUR COMMUNITY IF AN
OFFER SIR HOLD ON IF AN OFFICER
SARS IMPLEMENTED WOULD GET OUT.
OFFICER KILLS AN UNARMED BLACK
PERSON OR ANY PERSON.
AND THERE WAS NO THREAT THEY USE
EXCESSIVE FORCE.
THAT OFFICER SHOULD BE DRUG
TESTED SO WE CAN FIND OUT WHAT
IN THE OFFICES SYSTEM BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND POLICING IS A
DIFFICULT DO WE WE HAVE OFFICES
PROBABLY WORK A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
SHIPS.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT ALL
OFFICERS ARE JUST DRINKING
COFFEE SO LIFT.
DRUG TEST OFFICERS SO TO BE NO
SHADOW OF DOUBT TO FIGURE OUT
THE MINDSET AND IF THERE WAS NO
REASONABLE RESENTFUL OFFER SIR
TO USE THIS TYPE OF EXCESSIVE
FORCE.
THE OFFICER SHOULD BE FAR
WITHOUT A SHADOW OF A DOUBT.
SO A PERSON CAN BE TERMINATED
FOR BREAKING RULES OF BREAKING
POLICIES WHAT ABOUT TRAINING
WHAT ABOUT AN INMATE IS ALSO SAY
THIS WHEN I WAS A POLICE OFFICER.
I HAD TO ENGAGE I KNEW
EVERYBODY'S.
EVERY LEADER IN THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH I REPRESENTED AS A POLICE
OFFICER I KNEW MAMAS AND DADDIES
NAME.
I KNEW THEIR SONS I HAD TO GET
OUT A CAR I HAD TO WALK THE
STREETS WE HAD COMMUNITY BASED
POLICING WHERE BY WHICH WE
ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY SO WE KNEW.
THAT IF.
MR LOPEZ SON WAS ACTING UP OR HE
WAS SEEN SOMEWHERE YOU SHOULD BE
INSANE AND WE CAN PICK HIS LOW I
CAN'T THAT ON TV.
OKAY WE PICKED HIM UP.
AND WE TOOK A MOM AND TOLD MOM
AND DAD.
AND BUT THAT WAS THE TRAINING
THAT WAS INGRAINED IN IN ME AS A
POLICE OFFICER BUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE TRAINING IN ORDER TO CHECK
TO TRYING TO CHANGE THE CULTURE
THE YOU SPEAK OF AND I BELIEVE
THAT A STARTS THERE.
TELL ME SOMETHING IN TERMS OF OF
ANOTHER SOLUTION IF IS NOT
TRYING TO BECAUSE WE CAN FAR
EVERYBODY BUT WHO DO WE NARAL
CREATE AND TEACH.
THAT'S GOING TO COME IN AND TAKE
OVER THE SERVICES TO BITTER THAT
WHEN PEOPLE CALL 911- THERE'S
PEOPLE RESPOND WHO'S BEEN
TRAINED.
BECAUSE EVERY PERSON OF COLOR
EVERY MAN WHO WALKING DOWN THE
STREET WAS PASSING IT I'M YOU
KNOW SAGGING IS NOT INVOLVED IN
GANGS BUT YOU DON'T WE KNOW THAT
IF YOU'VE BEEN TRAINED TO TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT PERSON NOT
AFFILIATED WITH GANGS.
IF THE FAT IS THE FASHION
STATEMENT RIGHT.
IT GOES TO TRAINING AND SO I
JUST NEED SOMETHING ELSE WE
CAN'T DESPITE EVERYBODY WE HAVE
TO TRAIN SO HELP ME.
WITH RESPECT TO OTHER SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS EITHER TRAINING OR
SOMETHING ELSE AS WELL WHAT WHEN
WERE YOU A POLICE OFFICER.
I'M SORRY WHEN WE WERE POLICE
OFFICER WHERE DO YOU MAY WOULD
MEAN EIGHTY FORM.
WITHIN EIGHTY SO IS THE NINETIES
NICE.
YOU WANT TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
A LOT.
WE WANT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE --
ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- CITY COME LIKE
A DOVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL FOR BEING HERE AND SHOULD BE
A WAY IN A FEW MONTHS MISTER
ROBERTS.
A YEAR -- I THINK WHEN IT COMES
TO TRAINING WILL WILL FOR SOME
SPEAK ON A A LITTLE BIT OF
DISPARATE OF THE ACTIVITY SO I
THINK THAT.
I JUST FIND A LITTLE BIT
HYPOCRITICAL JUST BECAUSE WE
WANT DESIRE SOCIAL OUTCOMES WE
SET LAWS AROUND THOSE OUTCOMES
THAT WE WANT.
WHEN WE SAY THAT WE DON'T WANT
MURDER IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE
WON'T WANT VIOLENCE WE DON'T
WON'T -- BURGLARIES WE DON'T
WANNA ROBBERIES WE SAID A
PUNISHMENT FOR DAY AND WE'RE
STRICT ON IT WE ANYTIME TO
PEOPLE VIOLATE THOSE TALK TO
TERMS WE SAY.
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES FOR
WE HAVE TO KIND OF THIS PUNITIVE
NATURE OF DEALING WITH AND
CREATING A SOCIAL ENVIRONMENT
THAT WE SEE FIT.
WHEN IT COMES TO POLICE GUN
VIOLENCE WE DON'T HAVE THAT WE
START TALKING ABOUT STRICTLY
TRAINING YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
PUNITIVE WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE
ANY?
PUNITIVE -- CONSEQUENCES FOR
THESE ACTIONS UNLESS YOU KNOW
THEY'RE JUST EVEN WONDER SUPER
BLATANT YOU KNOW ON AREN'T DO
DIDN'T HAVE A GUN HE DID HAVE A
WEAPON.
WE KILLED HIM WE DIDN'T DE
ESCALATE HOW ARE TRAINING TELLS
US TO DE ESCALATE TWO YEAR OLD.
WE DID WE DIDN'T ANNOUNCE
OURSELVES AS POLICE OFFICERS WE
DIDN'T.
WE DIDN'T TELL IT WOULD YOU KNOW
A WHOLE BUNCH OF THE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES THAT WE HAVE AN ALL
POLICING AND WE DID IT.
ABIDE BY THOSE RULES BUT IT'S
STILL NOT ENOUGH TO SAY THAT
OKAY WE'RE SORRY WE'RE GOING TO
PLAY FEET LET YOU GO SOMEONE
LOST THEIR LIFE.
YOU WORK IN MAKE DONALD AND YOU.
SLEEP BEING YOU KNOW YOU TO LET
YOU SOBRE SLEEP DON'T HIT THE
CLARK YOU KNOW YOU FAILED TO
SHOW UP TO YOUR SHIFT HEY YOU
DON'T COST AS A THIS COMPANY.
CASTING LOSS AND SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO LET YOU GO YOU SLIPPED
INTO LATE BUT WHEN YOU MAKE A
MISTAKE THEY KILL SOMEONE THAT
TAKES SOME OF LIFE IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY'RE NOT COMING
BACK.
YOU AFFECTED THE THE WHOLE
FAMILY IN THIS COMMUNITY YOU MAY
AFFECTED A WHOLE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THERE'S NO MANDATORY THING GOV
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LET
YOU GO MOST TIMES.
WE ACTUALLY KEEP GOING TO FORCE
YOU GET PAID LEAVE THINGS OF
THAT NATURE SO THERE'S NO TYPE
OF PUNITIVE.
PUNITIVE CONSEQUENCE FOR IT OR
NO INCENTIVE I MEAN BECAUSE WHEN
IT COMES TO CREATE SOME TYPE OF
SOCIAL BEHAVIOR THAT'S DESIRABLE
THERE'S REALLY TWO WAYS TO LOOK
AT IT RIGHT YOU CAN CREATE A
SENTENCE TO IT OR YOU CAN CREATE.
A PUNISHMENT FOR BUT THERE'S
NEED THE WAR IS JUST LEFT TO
WILL YOU KNOW LESS WORK ON
TRAINING.
SO I THINK THAT TRAINING IS
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK THAT WHEN
TRAINING FALL SHORT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THESE THINGS ESTABLISH HIS
WILL WHEN IT COMES A TRAIN NOT
THINK THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME TO GOOD THANK YOU YOU HAVE
MITCHELL CRISIS IS FOR SHOW.
BUT I THINK THAT NGUYEN
ANALYZING THE PROBLEM WITHIN
HOLE THEN WE HAVE TO START
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE BIGGER
THINGS THAT WE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT WITHOUT START TALKING
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF POLICING WE
HAVE TO START TALKING ABOUT THE
CULTURE OF POLICING.
WE HAVE TO START TALKING ABOUT
THE RESOURCES IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND EDUCATED
OFFICERS BASED OFF OF STAMP
POINTS.
WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU GUYS
HAVE GIVEN US A GREAT DEAL OF
INFORMATION TO PONDER OVER AND
FOR US TO CAPTURE -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE OF THEM
BUT OUR NEXT PANEL UP -- WE
WOULD ASK YOU STAY CLOSE YOU MAY
WANT TO ASK OTHER QUESTIONS --
OVER A POSSIBLE MATCH SO --
ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- CITY COME LIKE
A DOVE CAN INTRODUCE HERSELF AND
HERE YOU GO HERE'S THANK YOU --
WELL THANK YOU ALL.
FOR MISTER CHAIR MISTER GIBSON --
FOR CONVENING THE SELECT
COMMITTEE AND FOR INVITING ME TO
BE A MEMBER -- MY NAME IS SYDNEY
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF I AM THE SIMPLY
WOMAN FOR THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES
LOS ANGELES -- SOME PARTS OF
INGLEWOOD AND ALL OF CULVER CITY --
WHY IS THIS ISSUE IMPORTANT TO
ME AND MY DISTRICT -- WELL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE I AM THE
WIFE OF A BLACK MAN AND THE STEP
MOTHER OF TWO BLACK CHILDREN.
AND I WANT TO SEE THEM GROW OLD
AND FEEL SAFE.
IN ANY COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY
TRAVEL -- AND FROM WATCHING
MOVIES ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE FROM
HEARING STORIES -- WHEN I'M AT
HOME ABOUT VICTIMS OF GUN
VIOLENCE AND ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT ARE BLACK AND
ARE BROWN AND ARE ASIAN BROTHERS
HAVE -- WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
WITH GUNS WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT IT AND I THINK IT'S
EQUALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE TALK
ABOUT THOSE SPECIFIC
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT BLACK AND BROWN MEN AND
WOMEN IN COMMUNITIES HAVE WITH
GUNS IN GUN VIOLENCE -- AND THAT
IS BOTH.
AT THE INTERACTION THAT FOLKS
HAVE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT
THEN JUST THE INTERACTION WE
HAVE WITH GUNS.
I TALKED TO FOLKS ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN INORDINATE
NUMBER OF GUN BILLS THAT COME
THROUGH PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND PART OF THE CONVERSATION WE
HAVE TO BE HAVING IS IS
INHERENTLY RACIST AND
DISCRIMINATORY SYSTEM THAT
FOCUSES HEAVILY ON PROFILING.
AND IT IS VERY HARD TO CREATE
GOOD POLICY ON TOP OF QUICKSAND.
AND TO ASSUME THAT THAT GOOD
POLICY IS GOING TO SOMEHOW
SUPERSEDE THIS INHERENTLY RACIST
FOUNDATION UPON WHICH WERE
PLACING THESE NEW LAWS.
AND SO WHY DON'T WE BEGIN TO
UNRAVEL ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND
HAVE VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
A SPECIFIC VERY GENDER SPECIFIC
VERY TRAUMA SPECIFIC
CONVERSATIONS AROUND TRAUMA AND
VIOLENCE IN COMMUNITIES.
PEOPLE LIKE TO ASSUME THAT BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE LIKE TO SHOOT
FOLKS UP EVERY DAY AND EVERY
NIGHT.
BUT I WILL ALSO ARGUE THAT BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES ARE SOME
OF THE MOST CONSERVATIVE WHEN IT
COMES TO CERTAIN PRINCIPLES AND
VALUES SYSTEMS AND SO THERE IS A
DISCONNECT WITH HOW WE ARE
TREATED.
AND HOW WE ARE PROFILED IN HOW
WE ACTUALLY ACT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE TREAT
EACH OTHER AND ABOUT HOW WE
HANDLE CONFLICT.
AND HOW WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRAINED
TO DO.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD WE SHOULD
DO AND WHAT IS PART OF WHO WE
ACTUALLY ARE IN OUR CULTURE AND
WHAT WE WANT TO DO?
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WE AS A CULTURE ONE AT A
RADIC KATE.
ARE OUR FUTURE.
BY KILLING.
YOU KNOW OUR NEXT GENERATION WE
ARE FOCUSED NOW ON TRYING TO
HEAL.
AND TO MOVE OURSELVES INTO THE
SPOTLIGHT TO SAY WE ARE HERE.
AND WE ARE HOLE.
WE ARE HURTING.
BUT WE ARE HOLE.
I'M NOT LESS OF A HUMAN BECAUSE
I'M A BLACK MAN -- SO WHY DON'T
WE HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
VIOLENCE IN BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE IT LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT
THREE WEEKS AGO A GENTLEMAN IN
BEL AIR.
WAS FOUND TO HAVE OVER A
THOUSAND GUNS.
IN HIS HOME.
THAT WAS ON THE NEWS FOR THIRTY
FIVE SECONDS AND THEN NO ONE
TALKED ABOUT HIM.
NO ONE TALKED ABOUT THOSE GUNS
NO ONE TALKED ABOUT WHAT HE WAS
DOING WITH THEM [inaudible]
WHY NOT?
SO THAT'S WHY I'M HERE I KNOW
I'VE TALKED A LITTLE LONGER THAN
I WAS SUPPOSED TO BASED ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- ASSEMBLY ONE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE UP
THIS THE NEXT PANEL -- GUN
VIOLENCE.
IN GANGS AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES --
IF DOC MARTINEZ I WAS A PLEASE --
COME BACK AND JOIN US AGAIN WE
WANT ALSO INVITE -- SAM BOND
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF
RICHMOND -- OFFICE OF
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFETY AND KENNY
GREEN I'M PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
GANG INTERVENTION FOR DEPARTMENT
OF THE TOBIN MEN --
NEIGHBORHOODS -- CENTER WHICH
YOU AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US AND PLEASE JOIN US AT
THE TABLE.
WE WILL START OFF WITH -- MISTER
GREEN YOU CAN JUST -- PLEASE
INTRODUCEYOURSELF AND THEN WE
WILL INVITE MR BONTA NEWS
HIMSELF AND THEN -- WILL HAVE
DOCTOR MARTINEZ -- WHICH ARE
DATA WITH REGARDS TO A GAL GUN
VIOLENCE IN GAMES AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
OF THANK YOU GERMAN -- VERY
HONORED TO BE HERE SHARING THE
SPACE WITH YOU ALL THE HERE AND
NOW SACRAMENTO.
MY NAME IS KENNY GREEN AND ALL
OVERSEE ALL THE GANG
INTERVENTION -- ACTIVITIES DOWN
IN THE HARBOR OF THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES --
AT TOBER NEIGHBORHOOD CENTER
KIND OF BEEN AROUND FOR A COUPLE
DAYS SINCE -- NINETEEN OH THREE
DOING SOME GOOD WORK AND THEN
MOVING TO SAN PEDRO AND I'LL
CONTINUE THAT WORK.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME HERE SAM ON THE CITY OF
RICHMOND OFFICE NEIGHBORHOOD
SAFETY PROGRAM MANAGER ALSO
RESIDENT OF RICHMOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WITH US -- DOC MARTINEZ
[inaudible]
OKAY -- GOOD TO BE BACK.
AGAIN SECOND TIME TODAY -- AND
TODAY'S OR IN THIS PORTION OF
THE DISCUSSION.
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT -- ACCESS
IN MOTIVATIONS. FOR GUN VIOLENCE --
IN SAN DIEGO.
AND WHAT THIS TALK AGAIN EVEN
THOUGH MY DATE -- AND RESEARCH
IS BASED IN SAN DIEGO IT HAS
BROADER IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
LOT OF PARALLELS WHAT WE SEE IN
SAN DIEGO -- THAT WE SEE AN LOS
ANGELES AND ALL THE OTHER MID
SIZE CITIES -- IN CALIFORNIA.
SO LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT -- SOME OF MY RESEARCH --
SO STARTING IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I CONDUCTED.
AN ETHNOGRAPHY OF THREE
DIFFERENT POLICE GAIN UNITS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THIS IS THE WAY
THAT I GATHERED MOST OF MY DATA --
I RODE WITH UNITS FOR ABOUT FOUR
TO FIVE HOURS ON THURSDAYS AND
FRIDAYS.
AND ADDITIONALLY I SPENT CLOSE
TO TWO YEARS OBSERVING THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO'S POLICE
DEPARTMENT GANG UNIT.
RIDING WITH THEM TWO TO THREE
TIMES PER WEEK EVERY. SIX SIX TO
EIGHT WEEKS I KNOW THE OFFICERS
ARE THE GANG UNITS PRETTY WELL
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AS WELL.
SO THESE FIRST HAND ACCOUNTS
OBSERVING PLEASE GANG UNITS
INFORM MY WORK TODAY.
AND GIVEN THE SEEM OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN GANGS I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO DISCUSS --
WHAT MY FINDINGS WERE?
AND WHEN I WAS COLLECTING DATA
WAS TRYING TO ANSWER TWO
QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS -- WHERE
DO GUNS COME FROM USED IN
HOMICIDES OR SHOOTINGS AND
SECOND WHY DO PEOPLE CARRY THEM
WHAT ARE THE MOTIVATIONS FOR
KAREN SO?
IF THIS SOUNDS FAMILIAR ON
BUILDING ON THE TALK I GAVE
EARLIER TALKING ABOUT ACCESS AND
MEANINGS -- FOR HAVING GUNS --
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FINDINGS.
SO -- MY FINDINGS ARE.
BASED ON PATROL OBSERVATIONS
WERE PART OF THE DATA CAME FROM
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
DISCOVERED.
WAS ABOUT 3240% OF ALL WEAPONS
RECOVERED FROM SHOOTINGS -- FROM
SHOOTINGS IN HIGH HOMICIDES WERE
TRAFFICKED [inaudible]
FROM ARIZONA AND NEW MEXICO SO
HERE ARE MOSTLY TALKING ABOUT
SAN DIEGO -- AND SO THESE ARE
JUST -- INTERVIEWS I DID WITH
POLICE OFFICERS FROM THE GANG
UNIT.
AND I WAS KIND OF SURPRISED TO
HEAR THAT THAT LARGE PERCENT
PERCENTAGE OF HAND GUNS CAME
FROM OUT OF STATE PRIMARILY
ARIZONA -- THE REMAINING GUNS.
WERE STOLEN -- AND WEIRD WHEN
WERE TAKEN FROM FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO OWNED FIREARMS MOST OF THE
WEAPONS USED WERE SMALL HAND
GUNS SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY TWOS FORTY
FIVES AND NOT TYPICALLY THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS THAT WE HEAR
ABOUT IN MASS SHOOTINGS.
SO SOME OF THE OTHER DAY THE
THAT I HAVE THEM WITH TALK ABOUT
TODAY WAS EXTRACTED FROM THE
DA'S OFFICE AS WELL AS WE
ACTUALLY WENT THROUGH SOME OF
THE THEIR HOMICIDE FILES.
NOT SO I WAS ABLE TO GET THE THE
DATA ON THE TYPES OF HANDGUNS
USE.
SO THE POINT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
FIRST IS IT WE SHOULDN'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THE NEED TO REGULATE
SMALL HAND GUNS SINCE THEY ARE
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE. FOR MOST
HOMICIDES BUT THAT STILL BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULDN'T
REGULATE ASSAULT WEAPONS BUT
MOST OF THE GUN ONCE IN
COMMITTEES OF COLOR ARE
COMMITTED BY SMALL HANDGUNS AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT -- MY FINDINGS NEED TO GO
FURTHER AND WE NEED TO
INVESTIGATE WE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS INVESTIGATE NOT ONLY THE
SECONDARY SOURCES.
BUT THE PRIMARY SOURCES WHEN I
SAY PRIMARY SOURCES WE NEED TO
NOTE DIRECTLY WHICH GUN DEALERS.
IN PLACES LIKE ARIZONA WHERE
THESE GUNS ARE COMING FROM SO
THAT WE CAN PROSECUTE -- THOSE
BUSINESSES FOR SELLING THEM OR
TRY TO INVESTIGATE HOW THEY
ENDED UP IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO USE THEM -- FOR HOMICIDES.
SO WHAT MY OBSERVATIONS
SUGGESTED THAT A LARGE AMOUNT OF
GUNS USED TO COMMIT MURDER IN
BLACK AND BROWN NEIGHBORHOODS --
THERE ARE USING GANG RELATED
ACTIVITY COME FROM OUT OF STATE.
SO THIS SUGGESTS THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR FEDERAL POLICY REFORM
TO DEAL WITH GUN VIOLENCE.
SO -- HERE'S AN ILLUSTRATION
THIS IS FROM -- THE NEW YORK
TIMES -- IN RESEARCHERS HAVE
PICKED UP ON THIS FIRST FOR
QUITE SOME TIME -- BUT IF YOU
LOOK OVER TO CALIFORNIA IF YOU
pINTO SAN DIEGO YOU CAN SEE HOW A
LOT OF THE ERROR WAS GOING FROM
ARIZONA TO CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
BECAUSE A GUN LAWS TEND TO BE.
MORE LAX IN PLACES LIKE ARIZONA
END OF THAT AND SO IT'S A LOT
EASIER TO GET.
HAND GUNS [inaudible]
LEGALLY.
AND THEN TO TRANSPORT THEM INTO
PLACES.
LIKE -- SAN DIEGO [inaudible]
SO -- THE GRAPHIC ILLUSTRATES
THE TRAIN WE SEE IN SAN DIEGO
FARMS BEING TRAFFICKED TO
CALIFORNIA FROM ARIZONA BECAUSE
OF THE WEEK LAWS.
IN MANY OF THE GUNS ARE LEGALLY
PURCHASED ACCORDING TO THE
OFFICERS THAT I SPOKE WITH.
AND IF GOING TO SORT OF RELATE
THIS TO GANG VIOLENCE OR GANG
VIOLENCE IS A PROBLEM BUT IT IS
FURTHER FUELLED.
WHEN GAINING WHEN GANGS ARE ABLE
TO GAIN ACCESS TO WEAPONS?
AND THERE'S IT'S NOT A SERIOUS
IMPEDIMENT SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS --
THE ACCESS TO GUNS AS WELL FOR
GONNA TALK ABOUT GANG VIOLENCE
AND HOW PEOPLE GET THESE HAND
GUNS -- I ALSO DID SOME HAVE
BEEN DOING SOME RESEARCH IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ON A RELATED
PROJECT -- AND A IT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO DID GETTING
ENFORCEMENT TEAM PEOPLE THAT
I'VE TALKED TO AN INTERVIEW THAT
TOLD ME THAT.
MOST OF THE HAND GUNS USED IN
HOMICIDES IN SHOOTINGS IN
SACRAMENTO COME FROM NEVADA.
SO THAT'S ALSO ONE OF THE FLOW
CHARTS YOU SEE THERE ARE THERE'S
AN ARROW COMING FROM THE VADA
BUT FROM THE OFFICERS I TALK TO
YOU.
THERE'S A LOT OF HAND GUNS
COMING FROM THE VET -- INTO
SACRAMENTO AND FEELING A LOT OF
THE VIOLENCE IN THE PLACES THAT
I TALKED ABOUT EARLIER -- IN
SOUTH SACRAMENTO AND IN -- DEL
PASAL HEIGHTS.
NOW LET ME JUST SAY THIS NOW
BECAUSE I KNOW POLICIES
IMPORTANT -- FOR FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND IT FOR YOUR
OFFICE SO WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR OF MY FINDINGS
HERE.
WELL WHAT CAN BE DONE SO THE ATF
TRACES THE SERIAL NUMBER TO FIND
OUT THE SOURCE OF THE
MANUFACTURER IN DEALER. TO THE
WEAPON WAS PURCHASED FROM BUT AS
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW OR MAYBE
SOME OF YOU DON'T KNOW THERE IS
NO FEDERAL.
DATABASE THAT KEEPS TRACK OF
GUNS THAT ARE PURCHASED SO I
THINK THAT'S AN ONGOING --
PROBLEM -- PEOPLE THINK IT'S SO
YOU CAN JUST TYPE THE NUMBER
INTO A COMPUTER IT'S NOT THE WAY
IT WORKS ARE LITERALLY.
YOU HAVE TO USE LIKE A CARD
INDEX I WAS JUST FROM THE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY REALLY
HAVE TO GO TO A CARD INDEX.
AND MAKE A REQUEST AND IT TAKES
MONTHS SOMETIMES FOR THE A TF --
TO GET THE SERIAL NUMBER ON
THESE WEAPONS.
WHAT ABOUT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
STRAYS DATA FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS IS COLLECTED BUT IT'S
NOT DONE IN A SYSTEMIC
SYSTEMATIC ORGANIZED HUESO
THAT'S ONE THING THAT CAN BE
DONE.
IS -- TO HAVE A CALL FOR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO HAVE
A DEVELOPED DATABASE TO TRACK
WEAPONS COMING INTO THE CITY
HOMICIDE DETECTIVES ALREADY DO
THAT BUT THEY DON'T IT'S NOT
REALLY FULLY DEVELOPED.
DATABASE THAT'S MEANT TO BE
SHARED.
WITH OTHER POLICYMAKERS AND THEN
AT THE STATE LEVEL MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A DATABASE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW FULLY DEVELOPED
IT IS BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE
WORTH.
REVSITING WHAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S DATABASE LOOKS LIKE.
FOUR SERIAL NUMBERS -- AND HOW
THE STATE CAN COOPERATE WITH
CITIES TO TRY TO FIND OUT THE
ORIGINS OF GUNS USED.
IN SHOOTING SO THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE THREE THINGS.
THE POLICY IN.
THE SOLUTIONS THAT CAN BE I
THINK FURTHER EXPLORED THAT
MIGHT BE A TAKE AWAY -- FROM THE
STOCK.
SO -- FOR THIS PORTION OF THE
TALK WHAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE IS
CLEARLY STRICTER GUN REGULATIONS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL ARE NEAT
ARE NEEDED.
AND THERE'S A TAKE AWAY FROM
THIS AND THAT IS RED STATES AND
THEIR GUN LAWS ARE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR GUN VIOLENCE IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND IT'S NOT THE OTHER WAY
AROUND WE GET A BAD RAP IN
CALIFORNIA IS BEING A VIOLENT
PLACE -- YOU KNOW FULL OF KINGS
BUT IT TURNS OUT A LOT OF THE
VIOLENCE ITS FUEL THAN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONS FROM
GUNS IN NEIGHBORING RED STATES
THAT HAVE.
WEAK GUN LAWS SO I THINK THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING -- THAT
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED A PROGRAM
TALK ABOUT GANGS IN GUN VIOLENCE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEREFORE
IS CONTRIBUTING TO GUN VIOLENCE
IN AREAS OF DISADVANTAGE.
RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
TALK ABOUT.
WHERE HOW GUNS ARE REQUIRED ON
THE STREETS THAT ARE USED?
IN HOMICIDES.
SO THE SECOND LEADING WAY
FIREARMS ARE REQUIRED IS THROUGH
THEFT.
BASED ON INTERVIEWS AND FIELD
OBSERVATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT STAFF THAT THIS IS
THE SECOND MOST COMMON WAY IN
THIS USUALLY HAPPENS.
IN HOME ROBBERIES OF TALK TO
POLICE OFFICERS INTERVIEWED THEM
IN WHAT PEOPLE DO IS I'LL TRY TO
GAIN INTEL ON PEOPLE IN A VERY
DELIBERATE WAY. ONE EXAMPLE I
WAS GIVEN -- IS SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WILL GO TO SHOOTING RANGE.
THEY'LL SEE WHO HAS THE
EXPENSIVE GUN LOOKS LIKE THEY
HAVE MONEY AND PEOPLE FOLLOW
THESE INDIVIDUALS HOME THE CASE
THEIR HOME.
AND WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT THEY
MIGHT ROB THAT HOUSE FOR THAT
GUN OR IT COULD BE SOMEBODY
DOING SOME WORK IN YOUR HOME IF
THEY HEAR THERE'S A GUN THERE.
THEY'LL ROB THAT HOUSE -- THE
SECOND MOST COMMON WAYS WHAT'S
KNOWN AS A SMASH AND GRAB -- SO
IN SACRAMENTO THERE WAS A RASH
OF ROBBERIES AT GUN STORES WERE
PEOPLE WOULD BACK THEIR CARS UP
INTO A GUN STORE.
AND THEN JUST A PILE OF PEOPLE
WOULD JUMP OUT AND THEY WOULD
TRY TO JUST PACK AS MANY GUNS AS
A KIDS OF THEFT.
IS A VERY COMMON WAY THAT GUNS
GET IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM -- THEN THE
THIRD MOST COMMON WAY IN THIS IS.
GONNA BE THE CHALLENGE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE
COUNTRY NOW IT WHAT'S KNOWN AS
THE GHOST GUNS.
GHOST GUNS -- ARE INCREASINGLY
USED IN HOMICIDES IN IN GAME
VIOLENCE AS WELL -- IN THE FIRST
THERE'S THREE DIFFERENT WAYS OF
THREE VERSIONS OF GOES GUNS I'LL
SHARE WITH YOU THAT I'VE
DISCOVERED IN MY RESEARCH THE
FIRST.
IS THE THREE D. PRINTERS.
SO -- THREE D. PRINTERS ARE NOW
BECOMING MORE COMMON YOU CAN
PRETTY MUCH PRINT ANYTHING WITH
A THREE D. PRINTER.
AND GUNS ARE INCREASINGLY BEING
USED IN THE BLACK MARKET AND AND
THERE'S NO WAY OF TRACING SERIAL
NUMBERS BACK BECAUSE THERE ISN'T
ONE RIGHT SO THAT'S THAT'S THIS
IS GONNA BE A CHALLENGE I THINK
FOR POLICY MAKERS.
THE SECOND TYPE OF GOES GUN IS
WHERE MAYBE A PERSON HOUSE THE
BOTTOM PART OF A GUN.
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO PURCHASE THE
OTHER PART ONLINE SO YOU CAN BUY
GUNS IN PIECES -- THIS IS A
PROBLEM FOR THE GANG IT WAS
ACTUALLY THE TYPE OF GUN THE
KILLED TERRIBLE SOLD IN I THINK
IT WAS AN A. R. HE WAS AN
ASSAULT RIFLE THAT HAD DIFFERENT
PARTS.
THAT WERE PURCHASED ONLINE IS A
HOMEMADE GUN.
AND THEN THE THIRD TYPE OF GOES
GUN -- ARE THESE ARE GUNS THAT
ARE STOLEN IN BULK FROM
FACTORIES THEY GET IN BEFORE --
SERIAL NUMBERS ARE PRINTED ON
THEM -- AND THERE'S NO WAY TO
TRACE THEM BACK SO ALL THESE ARE
VERSIONS OF GOES GUNS THEY'RE
VERY PROBLEMATIC THEY CAN'T BE
TRACED BACK AND THEY ARE
BECOMING INCREASINGLY COMMON --
AMONGST -- GANGS.
OKAY LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE MOTIVATIONS NOW SO I
TALKED ABOUT THE ACCESS ONE TALK
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE MOST COMMON
TYPES.
OF GUN RELATED HOMICIDES AND
AGAIN GOING BACK TO SAN DIEGO
AGAIN.
AS A WINDOW INTO THE INTO THE
REST OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND INTO THE COUNTRY.
AND AS TALK ABOUT CRIME -- SO
ABOUT 10% AND THIS IS JUST BE
JUST PRELIMINARY FINDINGS FROM.
THE CORONER'S OFFICE FILES I GOT
FROM OTHER QUARTERS OFFICE IN
THE DA'S OFFICE.
ABOUT 10% OF GUNS USED IN
HOMICIDES WERE A RESULT OF A
ROBBERY.
AND 3%.
WERE.
DRUG MOTIVATED AND LOW ALSO GIVE
YOU A VERY COMMON TYPE OF DRUG
RELATED -- ROBBERY THANK YOU SEE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO SO
INCREASINGLY IN SACRAMENTO THEY
HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN AS WE TRIPS --
EVEN THOUGH MARIJUANA IS LEGAL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
A LOT CHEAPER TO BUY IT ON THE
BLACK MARKET BECAUSE OF THE TAX
BECAUSE YOU GET IT BECAUSE IT
GETS TAX.
SO THERE'S A HUGE UNDERGROUND OF
MARIJUANA INFORMAL MARKET IN
SACRAMENTO AND LOTS OF PEOPLE
WILL GET ROB WILL SET UP OF A
FAKE DEAL.
PEOPLE WILL WILL GET ROB THEN
WHEN PEOPLE DON'T COOPERATE TO
GET KILLED SO CORPS IN THE SACK
PD THIS IS A VERY COMMON TYPE OF
GUN RELATED HOMICIDE THAT WE SEE
IN PLACES LIKE.
DEL PASO HEIGHTS OR IN CELL
SACRAMENTO -- OKAY MOVING ALONG --
GANG RELATED THIS SECTION IS ON
GAMING'S.
AND SO -- A SIGNIFICANT PERCENT.
OF GUN RELATED HOMICIDES -- OR
GANG RELATED 39% OF HOMICIDES
INVOLVING HOMICIDE OR FARMS WERE
GANG RELATED.
AT WERE IN THIS THE WAY THAT
THEY DETERMINE WHETHER WAS
GETTING THAT WAS THE SHOOTER AND
OR VICTIM IS DOCUMENTED
DOCUMENTED.
AS A GANG MEMBER GANG RIVALRIES
CONSTITUTED ABOUT 13% IN AGAIN
WHY WORRY WAS 8% LET ME JUST
PAUSE HERE FOR A SECOND -- WHEN
WE USE THE GANG THE THE TERM
GAINING -- IT'S I THINK IT'S
VERY PROBLEMATIC WE HAVE TO
APPROACH THIS CONCEPT WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF CAUTION.
WHY DO WE NEED TO PROCEED IN A
CAUTIOUS WAY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT?
GANGS.
WELL FIRST OF ALL GETTING IS A
FLUID CONCEPT THAT USE USE FOR
PROTECTION -- IN ITS
INCREASINGLY LESS IMPORTANT
SENSE NEIGHBORHOOD IDENTITY
OFTEN TRUMP'S GETTING A JENNY SO
USEFUL USES I'M GONNA GAME BUT
THEY'RE NOT REALLY JUST KIND OF
USE IT TO KIND OF PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
SO THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM THOUGH IS THE
TENDENCY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
SEE COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE GANG
LANDS AND I THINK WE NEED TO IT
REQUIRES.
GREATER - INVESTIGATION TO TRY
TO FIND OUT IF A SHOOTING WAR
CRIME IS IN FACT -- GANG RELATED --
AND SO THE CHALLENGE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND POLICY MAKERS IS
TRY TO UNPACK THE UNIQUENESS OF
GUN RELATED HOMICIDE AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE QUICK JUST TO SAY.
THAT IT'S GANG RELATED -- AND OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT -- YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO ADDRESS GAINES THAT
AS A AS A PROBLEM -- AS WELL.
OKAY SO THAT'S A GANG RELATED.
HOMICIDES.
AND THEN THE LAST MOTIVATION
THAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS --
WHAT I'M CALLING INTERPERSONAL --
GUN RELATED HOMICIDES. 40% OF A
FIREMAN HOMES INVOLVED
INTERPERSONAL CONFLICT. 21%.
OF THAT 40% WERE DOMESTIC -- AND
SO.
IF YOU'RE FOR POLICE OFFICER I'M
SURE I'M SURE YOU'VESEEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN POLICE OFFICERS GO
ON A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALL.
THESE ARE SITUATIONS IT CAN
ESCALATE VERY QUICKLY -- THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE THE INCIDENT THAT --
TERRACE ALL SOLVING THE MENTION
A NAME AGAIN WAS EXPOSED TO WIND
WHEN SHE WAS SHOT -- SO --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A OFTEN OF
COMMON WAY IN WHICH GUN BY ITS
CAN ESCALATE VERY QUICKLY IN IN
IT COMES UP IN A LOT OF THE DATA.
THAT I'VE SEEN AND THEN FINALLY
RELATED TO INTERPERSONAL
CONFLICT WE HAVE INCIDENTS --
THAT ARE NOT INTERPERSONAL OR
NOT DOMESTIC -- AND THEY'RE JUST
A RESULT OF PERSONAL BEEF SO
THOSE ARE THE THREE MOST COMMON --
MOTIVATIONS. FOR GUN VIOLENCE
AND NOW LET ME JUST.
GIVE A COUPLE OF THE SUMMARY
HERE ABOUT TWO MINUTES AND WE'LL
GO TO THE OTHER PANELISTS OKAY --
IT'S DIFFICULT TO EXAMINE GUNS
AND BUY IT SEPARATELY FROM GUN
VIOLENCE -- AGAIN JUST TO KIND
OF REITERATE WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE MOTIVATIONS AND ACCESS GUNS --
IN IT'S CRUCIAL TO ADDRESS
AMERICA'S CULTURAL LINES.
BY DEALING WITH THINGS LIKE A
MENTAL HEALTH POVERTY GANG
PREVENTION AND AGAIN WE CAN
IGNORE THE PORTS OF COMMUNITY
RELATIONS PLEASE COMMITTEE
RELATIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S A DOCTOR MARTINEZ THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS VERY
THOROUGH IN A LOT OF VERY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION.
SO I WANT TO GO TO THE REST OF
PANEL -- MISTER BOND -- YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIVE
SAN -- AS I MENTIONED MY NAME IS
SAM VINE SERVICE THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF
RICHMOND'S OFFICE NEIGHBORHOOD
SAFETY -- THE ALSO NEIGHBORS
SAFETY IS A NON LAW ENFORCEMENT
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY WHOSE SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO REDUCE A
ONE DAY ELIMINATE GUN VIOLENCE
IN THE CITY OF RICHMOND -- I WAS
EX TO BRING.
PERSONAL STORIES AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE TO GIVE THIS -- SOME
INSIGHT -- SO BEFORE I TALK
ABOUT THE OFFICE IN THE ROLE I
PLAY I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF.
I GREW UP IN THE CITY OF
RICHMOND AND THE SURROUNDING
AREAS THE MAJORITY OF MY LIFE I
LIKE MANY OF THE YOUNG MAN I
CAME FROM A BROKEN HOME.
THAT WAS EXPOSED TO POVERTY
VIOLENCE DRUG ABUSE DRUG SALES.
AT A VERY YOUNG AGE.
AND LIKE MOST A YOUNG MAN
GROWING UP IN THOSE CONDITIONS
WHAT WAS ASSN WAS A HEALTHY MALE.
HELPING ME GET THROUGH THE
CONFUSION THAT THAT ENVIRONMENT
BRINGS.
SO I GREW UP ANGRY.
BITTER AND FELL INTO THE SAME
TRAPS THAT ARE OUT THERE WAITING
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE STEP IN
TODAY.
I GREW UP DEPRESSED.
ISOLATED AND FULL OF RAGING
CONTENT.
AND BECAUSE OF MY ADOLESCENT
MIND EVERYTHING ABOUT MY LIFE
SHOWED ME THAT NO ONE CARED
ABOUT ME AND MY OBLIGATION WAS
TO FEND FOR MYSELF.
IN THE PROCESS OF LEARNING OR AT
LEAST BELIEVE IN THIS I BECAME
VERY SELFISH.
I BELIEVE NO ONE CARED ABOUT ME
SO WHY SHOULD I CARE ABOUT
ANYONE ELSE.
AND I JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
THIS IS THE MOST DANGEROUS PLACE
FOR A YOUNG PERSON TO BE.
IN BREACH LONELINESS NO SENSE OF
BELONGING AND SECURITIES AND LOW
SELF ESTEEM.
IT LITERALL CREATE SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS AND TENDENCIES.
AND THEY'RE VERY CLEAR BY THE
WAY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE LIVING
THEIR LIFE LIKE THEY ARE NOT
PLANNING FOR FUTURE.
IN A PUT IT PLAINLY -- LITTLE
WING SAYS IT THE BEST.
WAS THE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF
SOMEONE WHO HAS NO EXPECTATIONS.
THIS IS THE STATE OF MOST URBAN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND AS I'M SURE YOU ARE ALL
AWARE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
BEEN THE VICTIMS OF STATE
SANCTIONED VIOLENCE LONG BEFORE
THE INCEPTION OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS COME IN MANY DIFFERENT
FORMS FROM SLAVERY. TO JIM CROW
FROM EUGENICS TO REDLINING FOR
MORE ON DRUGS TO UNDER FUNNY
MINORITY SCHOOLS. TO
GERRYMANDERING ENGINES FOR CASE.
AND HOPEFULLY YOU WILL HAVE
OTHER SENATE COMMITTEES.
HEARINGS ON THOSE THINGS --
BECAUSE OF WHAT IT IS DONE IS
DAMAGE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND TO BE CLEAR ALL OF THESE AND
MUCH MORE PLAYED A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE STATE OF
URBAN COMMUNITIES.
AND SADLY MOST OF THE VICTIMS OF
THESE GOVERNMENT POLICIES AREN'T
EVEN AWARE OF THEIR EXISTENCE.
ALL THEY'RE AWARE OF HIS THIS IS
CUMULATIVE A COMMUNITY.
CAN YOU.
CUMULATIVE EFFECTS SKEWS ME.
IT IS NOW BEEN DEEMED BY
MAINSTREAM SOCIETY IT IS A CRIME
TO BE A PERSON OF COLOR IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE STATE OF OUR NATION.
I BELIEVE THIS GROWING UP IN NOT
ONLY ACCEPTED IT AS FACT BUT
THROUGH MY IGNORANCE I LIVED UP
TO IT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AS A
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD I WAS
ARRESTED TRIED AND CONVICTED FOR
ATTEMPTED MURDER. FOR THE NEXT
TEN YEARS I WAS INCARCERATED AND
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT MYSELF.
WHAT I LEARNED EVEN MORE ABOUT
THE SOCIETY THAT WAS BEING
PROTECTED FOR ME?
I SPENT MY YEARS DOING ANY SELF
HELP GROUP THAT HAS SPACE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FORMS I GOT
A COLLEGE DEGREE I BEGIN
MENTORING YOUNG PEOPLE ON THE
VERGE OF MAKING SIMILAR MISTAKES
TO MY OWN.
AND UNBEKNOWNST TO ME ALL OF
THIS WAS PREPARE ME FOR WHAT WAS
IN STORE UPON MY RELEASE.
SO TO GET BACK TO MY ROLE AT THE
OFFICE. NINE MONTHS AFTER MY
RELEASE I STARTED AS A PART TIME
PEACEKEEPER WITH THE AN S..
AND BEGAN THIS JOURNEY THAT I'M
ON TODAY.
AS I MENTIONED THE ONUS IS NOT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR WHOLE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO REDUCE AND
ONE DAY ELIMINATE GUN VIOLENCE
IN THE CITY OF RICHMOND.
AT THE DEPARTMENT WAS CREATED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AFTER
COMMUNITY OUTCRY -- HISTORICALLY
THE CITY HAS DEALT WITH WITH GUN
VIOLENCE ISSUES FOR DECADES
WE'VE BEEN ON THE TOP TEN MOST
DANGEROUS CITIES.
LIST AT LEAST A DOZEN TIMES OVER
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS.
AND FOR THE TWENTY YEARS PRIOR
TO THE OFFICES CREATION WE
AVERAGED OVER THIRTY SEVEN
HOMICIDES PER YEAR BY FIREARMS.
IN THAT IS WITH THE CITY
POPULATION UNDER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ON THE CITY LEADERSHIP
DECIDED. TO CREATE THIS FIRST OF
ITS KIND OFFICE WITHIN CITY
GOVERNMENT THREE DO STUDENTS
RELATED INJURIES OR DEATH --
STREET OUTREACH TEAM WAS
DEPLOYED IN APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND WHAT IS
CALLED THE IRON TRIANGLE WITHIN
OUR CITY -- BECAUSE THE YEAR
PRIOR TO THAT THE IRON TRIANGLE
HAD A TWENTY SIX OF THE FORTY
THREE SHOOTING HOMICIDES IN THAT
CITY -- SO IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
ALL OF OUR ENERGY WAS DEPLOYED
TO THAT AREA AND IS SEEN THREE
SHOOTING DEATHS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND THE CITY LOOK AT IT IS
SUCCESS SPREAD THE FOR OUTREACH
WORKERS TO THE WHOLE CD AND LOW
BEHOLD.
WE ENDED UP RIGHT WHERE WE
STARTED.%
SO IN THIS LEADERSHIP REALIZED
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK.
AND DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY TO MAXIMIZE
OUR IMPACT WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES -- DURING THAT TIME WE
ALSO REALIZE THAT ALTHOUGH THERE
WERE MANY PEOPLE IMPACTED IN
THESE COMMUNITIES BY GUN
VIOLENCE IS A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THEM WHO ARE
ACTUALLY CREATING THE STATISTICS --
IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO IN THE SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND
TEN WE TOOK A DIFFERENT APPROACH
AND WE CREATED WHAT WE CALL THE
OPERATION PEACEMAKER FELLOWSHIP.
THE FELLOWSHIP IS A NON MANDATED
INTENSIVE MENTORING INTERVENTION
DESIGNED FOR YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
AS BEING AT THE CENTER OF AND
MOST IMPACTED BY GUN VIOLENCE IN
THE CITY OF RICHMOND.
THE LAST MINIMUM OF EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND CONSIST OF SEVENTY
COMPONENTS.
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE FILLS WITH
TOOL SKILLS AND RESOURCES TO
LEAD HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE
LIVES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE WHO TRUST
US ENOUGH TO PARTNER WITH US ON
THIS JOURNEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
WITH DAILY CONTACTS.
WE WILL CONTINUOUSLY PROVIDE
HEALTH INFORMATION AND THEY
CAN'T BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN HAVE
A PRODUCTIVE FUTURE.
THEY CAN PLAN FOR THEIR FUTURE
AND GET CASTING HELP FEEDBACK
AND PRODDING AS WELL SERVICE
NAVIGATION TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE
GOALS -- WE BELIEVE THAT
EXPERIENCES PLACES THAT YOU
DIDN'T KNOW EXIST.
HELP CHANGE YOUR SOCIAL NORMS TO
BE ABLE TO GET OPPORTUNITIES
THAT YOU MAY NOT OF NO INTEREST
YOU.
CAN GIVE YOU A PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE.
AND TO BE EXPOSED IN
INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFERS OF
INFORMATION TO OUR ELDERS CIRCLE.
IN IN BEING REWARDED FOR YOUR
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION TO YOUR
PERSONAL PROCESS CAN CREATE HOLE
IN WHAT SOME WOULD CONSIDER A
HOPELESS SITUATION.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE PUT.
THE ONUS HAS LIMITED RESOURCES
SO IN ORDER TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE OUR FELLOWS MUST BE
SELECTED WITH THE UTMOST
PRECISION.
OF THE NCAA'S PUBLIC SAFETY
ORGANIZATION CBO'S AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE KEY TO PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO HELP WITH THIS
SELECTION PROCESS.
THE ONUS HAS A LASER FOCUS WHEN
DECIDING WHOM TO ENGAGE FOR THE
FELLOWSHIP AND ONE DONE RIGHT
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
COUNTRY CAN CREATE THE RESULTS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN AND REYES.
WE STARTED THIS PROCESS IN TWO
THOUSAND TEEN.
AND WE HAVE COMPLETED FIVE COAL
WORDS SINCE THE OF THOSE FIVE
COURSE WE'VE HAD A HUNDRED AND
SIX FELLOWS. 96% OF THOSE
FELLOWS ARE STILL ALIVE. 80% OF
THOSE FELLOWS HAD NOT BEEN
INJURED BY FIREARMS IS BECOMING
A FELLOW.
AND 70% OF THOSE FELLOWS HAVE
NOT BEEN SUSPECTED OF A FIREARM
RELATED CRIME SINCE BECOMING A
FELLOW.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS PROCESS HAS
ALLOWED YOUNG MAN IN THE CITY OF
RICHMOND TO BEGIN QUESTIONING.
HOW THE OF NORMALLY DEALT WITH
THEIR CONFLICT AND GIVEN THEM
COURAGE TO CHALLENGE THAT AND
DEAL WITH IT IN A MORE HEALTHY
AND PRODUCTIVE WAY?
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THESE YOUNG
MAN'S BETTER DECISION MAKING HAS
BEEN A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
MASS OF DECLINING SHOOTINGS IN
THE CITY OF RICHMOND.
IN SKEWS ME LAST YEAR -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WE RECORDED THE
LOWEST AMOUNT OF SHOOTINGS
LEADING TO INJURY OR DEATH IN
OVER FORTY YEARS.
RECORDING A 73% REDUCTION
COMPARED TO THE YEAR OFFICE
OPENED.
CAN I WANT TO PUT THAT INTO
PERSPECTIVE.
THAT'S TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
PEOPLE THEY DIDN'T GET SHOT IN
OUR COMMUNITY LAST YEAR COMPARED.
TO TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THIS IS A
PROCESS THAT CAN HELP
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HELP REDUCE THEIR GUN VIOLENCE
ISSUES.
SACRAMENTO IS WELL STOCKED AND
HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED THIS
PROCESS IN OUR THEIR PATH TO THE
SUCCESS -- THE ONLY PROBLEM IS
TO CREATE THE POLITICAL WILL. TO
TREAT THESE YOUNG MAN HIS ASSETS
AND VIABLE PARTNERS IN THIS
ENDEAVOR INSTEAD OF THE ANIMALS
THAT HAVE CREATED THE RISK.
THAT ALL OF US ARE DEALING WITH.
AND I SAY THIS [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
ANDI SAY THIS BECAUSE THERE'S
MANY THERE'S BEEN MANY SPEAKERS
THAT HAVE THAT HAVE COME UP AND
SO I ALWAYS -- BRING THIS TO
LIGHT.
LAST YEAR THERE WAS A YOUNG
WOMAN WHO WAS KILLED OVER
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUE SHE HAD
AN ABUSER IT WAS STALKING HER.
AND HE CAUGHT HER ON THE WAY TO
DROP HER TWO CHILDREN OFFICE
SCHOOL -- KILLING HER IN FRONT
OF THOSE TWO CHILDREN.
IN THE FIRST THING THAT I
THOUGHT ABOUT.
WAS IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T GET A
HOLD OF THOSE TWO CHILDREN.
RIGHT NOW EVERYBODY'S LOOKING AT
THEM AS VICTIMS AND GIVE PT IN
SORROW FOR THEM.
BUT IN FIFTEEN YEARS IF IT
HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED IN THEIR
RESPONDING IN THIS WAY THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ANIMALS
CRIMINALS TO DESERVE PUNISHMENT
AND INCARCERATIONS.
SO THAT IS A FAILURE ON THE
COMMUNITY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SEEN THESE THESE
DETAINMENT CAMPS AND A. O. C.
BECAUSE IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
WITH THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN BEING
MISTREATED -- DONALD TRUMP HIS
HIS ARGUED THAT THESE ARE IN
MISTER TEEN DRUG DEALERS RAPISTS
KILLERS THEY'RE COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY AND HE HAS TO PROTECT US
FROM THEM.
IF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DEALT
WITH CORRECTLY THEY WILL TURN
INTO EXACTLY WHAT HE'S ACCUSING
THEM OF IN AND WHAT HE'S GOING
TO BE SAYING TO SEE I TOLD YOU
SO.
BUT WHAT REALLY HAPPENED IS THEY
ARE CREATING THE CONDITIONS FOR
THESE THINGS TO TAKE PLACE.
<c.cyan>G AND IT'S IT'S A TRAGEDY</c>
BUT IT'S ALSO A SHAME ON US
MOMENT -- OUR OUR APPROACH IS
WHAT IS CONSIDERED A CRIME
INFORMED IN TRAUMA RESPONSE OF
APPROACH.
ANY WORKABLE WILL CONTINUE TO
STAY BUSY IF WE ARE TREATING THE
YOUTH IN THESE COMMUNITIES LIKE
THERE ARE FUTURE.
AND NOT THE FUTURE TO KEEP LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCARCERATION
BUDGETS THE STATUS QUO.
BUT FUTURE SCIENTISTS INVENT
INVENTORS ENGINEERS UTILITY
WORKERS AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN.
WE HAVE TO TREAT OUR OUR
CHILDREN HUMANELY THROUGH LOVE
WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO GIVE THEM
BLANK IS FULL OF SMALLPOX IN THE
IN THE QUEUES THEM AND BLAME
THEM AND PUNISH THEM.
FOR GETTING SICK.
AND SO WE HAVE TO DO BETTER THIS
IS A THIS IS A SOCIETAL ISSUE.
IS NOT A A CRIME AND PUNISHMENT
ISSUE WE CAN WE CAN CREATE
POLICIES WE CAN CREATED MAKE IT
HARDER TO GET GUNS.
BUT IF WE'RE NOT CHANGING THE
SOCIAL NORMS OF FOR NOT CHANGING
THE CULTURE OF THESE COMMUNITIES --
WHICH MEANS WE HAVE TO HELP THEM
CHANGE THEIR VALUE SYSTEM WHICH
MEANS WE HAVE.
TO ALLOW WOULD SEE THEM TO BE
VALUABLE AND VALUE THEIR INPUT
AND MAKE THEM A PART OF THIS
PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER VON
MISTER GREEN.
HEY ARE YOU GOING.
HOME.
WELL.
TODAY -- FIVE HOURS AGO -- THERE
WAS A FUNERAL.
OF A YOUNG MAN A TO YOUR YOUNG
MAN BY THE NAME JOSE RIVERA WAS
KILLED.
ON JUNE SIXTEENTH.
AND THAT WAS FATHER'S DAY.
SO THE MAGIC OF FATHER GETTING
THE NEWS ON FATHER'S DAY THAT
HIS SON WAS JUST KILLED FOUR
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
NO MATTER WHAT IS SOME WAS DOING
A MATTER WHAT HE WAS INTO.
THAT'S DEVASTATING NEWS -- YOU
KNOW IN A COUPLE IN A IN WITHIN
A WEEK WE'RE GOING TO BE --
BEARING ANOTHER YOUNG MAN.
AUDIBLE STOP COMING FROM HIS
GIRLFRIEND'S HOUSE.
CAUGHT UP AND GUN CHARGES THIS
IS ELEVEN O'CLOCK IN THE
AFTERNOON.
ON A THURSDAY -- HEARD THAT A
LOT OF THE DATA THAT MISSED ALL
PROFESSOR MARTINEZ WAS SPOKEN
ABOUT -- JUST A HARBOR DIVISION.
FROM MAY TWENTY SIX TWO JUNE
TWENTY SECOND.
THOSE POOR HOMICIDES.
IN A FOUR WEEK SPAN. NINE
SHOOTING VICTIMS.
OKAY.
BUT THERE'S A THIRD NUMBER THAT
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT.
SHOTS FIRED.
YOU KNOW THAT VERY WELL YOU'VE
BEEN A POLICE OFFICER.
SHOTS FIRED IS BECOMING MORE AND
MORE.
UNREPORTED BECAUSE BEING MORE
COMMON IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUT THOSE COULD BE POTENTIAL
VICTIMS OF HOMICIDE YOU KNOW
WHEN THEY KILLED OR NOT.
SO THIS GUN VIOLENCE IS IS WE'RE
NOT LOOKING AT THE WHOLE THING
ON OF THE POTENTIALS.
ON EIGHTEEN MURDERS [inaudible]
AND TWO YEARS JUST IN THE CITY
OF WILMINGTON.
YOU KNOW.
THAT'S A LOT.
OF THOSE TWO ONE HAPPEN ACROSS
THE STREET FROM WHERE I LIVE.
WHAT HAPPENED I HAVE A BLOCK
DOWN FROM WHERE I LIVE?
I LIVE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
ONE EATEN.
OR IT'S VERY.
LOT OF GANG SO FOR YOU KNOW THIS
BETTER THAN THAN I DO.
YOU KNOW YOU GREW UP IN A IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT -- TO CUT A
LOT OF VIOLENCE -- THEN YOU
PROBABLY HAVE FRIENDS.
THAT USED HER DIED GO TO JAIL
WHATEVER NOW I'M DEALING WITH MY
FRIENDS.
KIDS AND THEIR GRANDKIDS.
YOU KNOW SO THIS IS A A CYCLE
THAT SAW -- KEEP GOING NO MATTER
HOW MUCH YOU KNOW EVERYBODY'S.
DOING HIGH FIVES BECAUSE THEY'RE
SAYING THAT VIOLENCE IS GOING
DOWN.
HOMICIDES GONE DOWN.
BUT IT'S STILL THERE -- IN A
COUPLE YEARS AGO I HAD TWO
FRIENDS I GREW UP WITH.
VERY CLOSE TO THEM.
AND THE TWO GUYS WERE VERY CLOSE
TO EACH OTHER.
WELL ONE OF THE SONS KILLED THE
OTHER SON [inaudible]
JUST IMAGINE. TWO GUYS GROWN UP.
AND THERE'S ONE OF THOSE ONE OF
THEIR SONS KILLED HIS OFF
FRIENDS SIDE.
I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
YOU KNOW.
GOING TO A FUNERAL ONE GOING TO
COURT FOR THE OTHER.
THOSE FAMILIES WILL NEVER BE THE
SAME.
ARE ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
WANT TO RAISE UP IN HERE IS
TRAUMA.
YOU KNOW SERVICE TRAUMA.
WHEN YOU HAVE A?
KILLING ON THE STREETS WHEN
USUALLY HAPPENS CAR WASH RIGHT.
TO RAISE MONEY.
THEN THEY HAVE THE CANDLES
INDIVIDUALS.
WITH THE PERSON YOU KNOW GOT
KILLED.
HOW MUCH TRAUMA DO YOU CALLS
THAT COMMUNITY?
WHEN SOMEBODY DIED ON THEIR
BLOCK?
THEY HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
AND WHEN YOU GO TO WORKING YOU
KIDS GO TO SCHOOL THEY SEE
CANDLES OUT THERE AND PICTURES
OF SOMEBODY JUST GOT KILLED
[inaudible]
ESTHER MATIC.
SO YOU JUST KEEP THAT TRAUMA
GOING IN WITH FULL SAID DOES
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
MURDER.
IT IT HURTS EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
EVERYBODY -- YOUR COLLEAGUE JIM
COOPER SPOKE ABOUT HEALING
INSTITUTIONS.
I THINK HE WAS TALKING ABOUT ARE
FRAGMENTED INSTITUTIONS.
WHERE OUR FAMILY?
OUR CHURCHES ARE COMMUNITIES.
AND IN MOST SENSES ARE FAMILIES
HAVE LET DOWN OUR KIDS.
THOSE ARE FRAGMENTED
INSTITUTIONS.
WE NEED TO FIND A WAY TO HEAL
THEM.
WE REALLY NEED TO FIND A WAY HOW
TO HEAL THEM.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW.
I LISTEN TO THIS YOUNG MAN.
TWICE YOU KNOW ABOUT -- GUNS
ACCESS TO GUNS.
LOT OF THE COMMUNITIES IN YOUR
WEIGHT WHERE YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR ARM ARE VERY POOR.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THE DECISIONS
ON HOW MUCH FOOD THEY PUT ON THE
TABLE.
HOW MUCH GAS THEY PUT THE CARD
TO PAY THE REST OF THE BILLS?
HOW CAN A FAMILY LIVE LIKE THAT
BUT A KID IN THAT FAMILY CAN GET
ACCESS TO A GUN?
WHETHER IT'S HANDED DOWN TO HIM
OR THE HOUSES OF TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO GET A
GUN.
IT'S KIND OF RIDICULOUS.
HOW ARE THESE GUYS GET INTO THE
HANDS OF OUR KIDS?
AND AS I'VE I'VE BEEN WHERE I
WAS AT FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
IN IN THE BEGINNING -- HOUSE A
FIREFIGHTER.
JUST GOING TO ONE INCIDENTS
AFTER ANOTHER YOU KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
BE ENOUGH -- BY THIS BY CENTER
UP THERE.
SO WE'RE DOING.
GOING TO ONE INCIDENT PUT IT OUT
MEDIATING BACK AND FORTH BACK
AND FORTH.
BUT THAT'S ALL WE WERE FOR
THAT'S ALL I WAS FOR AWHILE TO
MY KIND OF STARTED FIGURING OUT
THINGS [inaudible]
IN ALL.
BEING REACTIVE.
IT'S NOT HAPPENING -- WE HAVE TO
BE IN A STATE WHERE WERE MORE
PROACTIVE.
I HAD TO LEARN YOU KNOW I
THERE'S A CITY ATTORNEY YOU
MIGHT NOR EVE SHADY.
SHE'S A CITY ATTORNEY THAT WAS
WITH THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
AND SHE BASICALLY RUNS THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
YOU KNOW SHE OVERSEEING THAT.
I HAD TO LEARN A LOT FROM HER
ABOUT THE V..
NOT THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COMPONENT YES.
BUT ABOUT VIOLENCE IN THE CYCLE
OF VIOLENCE AND HOW KIDS GROW UP
IN A HOME THAT THERE'S VIOLENCE
AND THEY DON'T GROW OUT OF IT.
AND WE WERE RAISING ANGRY KIDS.
LEARNING ABOUT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS YOU KNOW.
UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW OF AND I
NOTICED THROUGH THE TV THING.
OR WHAT OUR FRONTAL LOBES THE
LAST PART OF OUR BRING TO
DEVELOP.
THAT'S A PART OF THE BRAIN THAT.
DEALS WITH LOGICAL REASONING.
SO THEN WE ASK YOU KNOW WHY ARE
YOU MAKING.
THESE DECISIONS BECAUSE THEIR
BRAIN HAS A FULLY DEVELOPED.
IN A PART OF REASONING MAKE IT
LOGIC.
WHAT I'M GETTING TO WHEN I SAY
THAT YOU KNOW LEARNING ABOUT
TRAUMA?
WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT WAS THE?
THE THE THE KIDS A SENIOR MOMENT
DIE.
OR GET KILLED RIGHT. FIFTY YEARS
FROM NOW.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE UNRESOLVED
TRAUMA A RESOLVE ISSUES THAT
THAT ISN'T DEALT WITH.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
INTERVENTION WORKERS WERE OUT
THERE DO ADVICE INTERRUPTIONS.
WE CAN BE FIREFIGHTERS ANYMORE.
WE HAVE TO LEARN ABOUT THE
TRAUMA SO WE COULD DEAL WITH
THAT WE HAVE TO LEARN ABOUT THE
V. WE HAVE TO LEARN ABOUT ALL
THESE.
MENTAL HEALTH.
WE'RE IN COMMUNITIES THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IS OF A STIGMA ALL THESE
CRAZY HE'S THIS.
NOW THAT'S NOT THE CASE SO WE
HAVE TO RE EDUCATE OUR
COMMUNITIES. ONE THING I KNOW
ABOUT TO MIKE.
IS THAT YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
SILOS.
EVERYBODY HAS A EVERY BATTER HAS
A PART TO PLAY WHATEVER ISSUES
US IN OUR COMMUNITY.
GANG VIOLENCE IS A ISSUE THAT'S
PLAYING A SPECIALLY IN SOME OF
OUR COMMUNITY THAT ARE
CHALLENGES.
AND I KNOW YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
SILOS IN YOUR STAFF DON'T I KNOW
VICTOR CHRIS OF DIANA DENTAL
BELIEVE IN SILOS EITHER.
WE CAN'T CONTINUE WORKING THE
SILOS.
WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER.
EVERYBODY HAS A PART TO PLAY.
AND WATCHING YOU ALL THESE YEARS
I KNOW YOU BELIEVE THAT AS WELL.
YOU KNOW.
IF YOU'RE NOT A VIOLENCE
INTERRUPTERS YOU'RE NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WHATEVER PART YOU PLAY IN OUR
SOCIETY YOU HAVE A PART TO PLAY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN IN WHAT WERE
MEETING ABOUT TODAY.
EVERYBODY HAS A PART TO PLAY.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW HOW EASY IT IS TO GET A
GUN. TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO I WAS
A FIREFIGHTER TODAY I'VE EVER
LOOK AT MY EVOLUTION IS GROWING
INTO SOMETHING DIFFERENT TRYING
TO BE PROACTIVE BECAUSE WE GOT
TO DEAL WITH THIS ON THE FRONT
END.
WE CONTINUE DEALING WITH THE
STUFF ON THE BACK AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE GETTING IN ALL STUFF ON US.
WE DON'T SAY THAT.
I'VE WATCHED HOW.
ARE VICTIMS.
AND THE PERPETRATORS ARE GETTING
YOUNGER.
I GET A YOUNGER.
YOU REMEMBER THE CASE WITH --
ALEX SEBADOH.
WHAT DISCOUNTS FOR TEN FORTY
OWES ACCUSED OF HIS MURDER?
YOU KNOW WE JUST HAD THIS OTHER
OF GUY JUST COPY THE FORTY YEARS
OLD.
HAD A COUPLE OF MULTI SHOOTINGS.
SO WATCHING OUR KIDS GOING OUT
THERE.
NOT ONLY BE A VICTIMS.
BUT BEING A PERPETRATORS.
HOW DO WE LET OUR SOCIETY COME
TO THAT?
HOW DO WE DO THAT?
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I'M ON YOUR TEAM WHEN YOU SET WE
CAN'T WORK IN SILOS ANYMORE.
EVERYBODY HAS A PART TO PLAY. TO
GET THIS GUN ISSUE.
IN HIS GUN VIOLENCE.
WHERE YOU KNOW?
IT SHOULD BE AN ISSUE ANYMORE.
I KNOW YOU WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
ONE DAY OF VIOLENCE FREE.
YOU KNOW I'M SAYING.
WE NEED TO BRING BACK MORE DONE
BY BACKS.
THE YOU KNOW WE HAD ONE IN THE
HARBOR [inaudible]
WE SOURCES.
KIND OF STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING
A MORE.
GETTING GUNS OFF THE STREETS.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE SOME OF THE
GUYS YOU TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE JUST GUNS THAT
JUST FALL INTO THE WRONG HANDS.
SO WE NEED A LOT MORE INNOVATIVE.
WAYS OF FIRST OF ALL GETTING OF
THOSE GUNS OFF THE STREETS.
BUT RE EDUCATING OUR KIDS
PUTTING MORE INVEST INVESTING IN
OUR KIDS DIFFERENTLY.
SEAN WHAT A HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP
LOOKS LIKE BE A MORE SUPPORTIVE
GIVING MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS OUT
THERE GETTING MORE VIOLENCE
INTERRUPTERS A MORE.
MENTORS AND BIG BROTHER PROGRAMS.
WITH.
MENTORS ENBERG BROTHERS OF THE
KIDS THAT LOOK LIKE THEM.
THAT CAME FROM THE SAME CLOTH.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE ALL.
THE ALL HAVE A PART TO PLAY THIS
GUN VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS GREEN FOR
YOUR COMMENTS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT I WANT TO ASK
THE THE COMMITTEE OF THE PANEL A
QUESTION.
HOW DO WE GET THE -- JEEZ
INVOLVE -- BECAUSE THOSE THE
ONES THAT THE LITTLE WAS A
LOOKING UP TO AND WE STILL TALK
ABOUT GANG VIOLENCE -- WITH GUNS
HOW DO WE GET THE JEEZ INVOLVED
INTO HELPING -- NOT ONLY
SUPPRESS BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT THERE ARE -- TALKING TO THE
YOUNG ONES WHO'S COMING UP WAS
WATCHING THEM WHETHER YOU SPENT
SOME TIME IN PRISON AND NOW
YOU'RE OUT.
BUT HOW DO WE GET THOSE
INDIVIDUALS -- INVOLVED IN THIS
WORK AND NOT WORKING IN SILOS
BUT ALSO WORKING AS COMMUNITIES
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS BECAUSE
LISTEN I'M TIRED OF GOING TO
FUNERALS.
I'M TIRED OF MOTHERS CRYING OVER
LIFELESS BODIES -- AND FATHERS
WHO FEEL THAT THEIR POWERS
BECAUSE OUR SON BECAUSE THE
FATHERS OUT THERE TRYING TO WORK
TO MAKE ENDS MEET BUT AS HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO SPEND WITH HIS
SON AND HIS SON IS GET INVOLVED
IN GANGS AND DRUGS.
THE END UP HIM LOSING HIS LIFE --
BECAUSE OF ON THE STREETS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO INVITE THEM
INTO A GANG SO HOW DO WE GET.
EITHER -- JEEZ -- INVOLVED IN
THIS WORK THAT WE'RE DOING -- AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW REALLY BE ABLE
TO OF TEAR DOWN SOME WALLS --
FATHER BOYLE SAID THIS OF
HOMEBOYS WAKE BAKERY GIVE A MAN
A WOMAN A JOB STOP A BULLET.
GIVE ME A JOB.
STOP A BULLET AND IF YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK AT EVERYONE WHO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TAKEN
SOMEONE'S LIFE AND ASK THEM
WHERE DO YOU WORK.
I BET THE ANSWER IS I DON'T WORK.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY.
THEY'RE DOING THAT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING BECAUSE MY MOTHER ALWAYS
SAID I DON'T MIND IS IS IS THE
DEVIL'S WORKSHOP.
SO HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT.
IS THE VALUE OF HER YEAH WILL
FIRST AT AT I WOULDN'T ACTUALLY
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH OKAY.
JOB AND TAKE AWAY A BULLET I ME
YOU'RE RIGHT MOST FOLKS WHO
SHOOTING ARE WORKING BUT THEY
WOULD WORK.
BUT THEY COME HOME AND STILL DO
WHAT THEY DO IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ABOUT I'M JUST BORED IS ABOUT
THERE'S A REAL -- THERE'S A REAL
CONFLICT IN A REAL HATRED THE
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN THESE
COMMUNITIES -- YOU A JOB NOT A
CAN AFFORD MORE WEAPONS POSSIBLY --
SO DEEP BUT DO YOU SEE THAT
THERE ARE MANY NOT YOU KNOW I I
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE WHO'VE GOTTEN
SHOT AT THEIR JOB.
THEY'RE AT WORK I GOT A JOB IN A
STILL SMOKING AND THEY SAW ME
WORKING SO ME LEAVING FROM WORK.
AND SO NOW NEXT WEEK YOU FIND
FIRED AND I HE'LL WHEN I GET OFF
WORK BECAUSE I NEED MY JOB TO
PAY MY RENT.
BUT I'M STILL GETTING BACK AT IT
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S THE MIND SAID
NOT JUST THE EMPLOYMENT YES
POVERTY -- DEPRESSION AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ALL OF THESE
THINGS HAVE PLAYED A ROLE -- BUT
A JOB ISN'T GONNA STOP A BULLET
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THE MY SAID
BUYBACKS IS GONNA STOP A BULLET.
THE HARSHER GOING LOSS ISN'T
GONNA STOP A BULLET UNTIL YOU
GET TO A PLACE WHERE I DON'T
WANT TO SHOOT ANYONE.
BECAUSE I HAVE A VALUE A LIFE
AND I VALUE MYSELF IN A VALUE
OTHERS WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
SOCIAL NORMS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT'S GOING THINGS
GONNA STOP A BULLET FOR MY
OPINION.
YOU ONE OH JEEZ TO GET INVOLVED
GIVER TO GETTING ANSWERS.
BECAUSE I'M NOT HELPING BECAUSE
I HAVE A FAMILY I'M A TWO
STRIKER I DON'T WANT THESE
YOUNGSTERS TO KILL EACH OTHER
BUT I GET INVOLVED.
I HAVE THAT KIND OF AUTHORITY I
HOLD THAT KIND OF RESPECT I MUST
BE LEADER THAT GAY AND I GOT A
RICO ACT.
GOT YOU STUCK MORE TEARS RATE
YOU RAISE A POINT WHEN YOU GAVE
IT YOUR DIAGRAM -- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I MEAN YOU KNOW MOST
OF MY WORK THE ANYWAY -- BECAUSE
WE STILL HAVE NO FEDERAL GUN
LAWS INTERVENING CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES LEAD THE WAY WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO GUN CONTROL AND
YOU DEMONSTRATE THROUGH YOUR
ANALYSIS TO SHOW THAT YOU KNOW
GUNS COMING FROM ARIZONA.
COMING IN FROM THE BATTER INTO
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF OUR GUN
LAWS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET HIM
HERE AND THEN THEY'RE GOING TO
THE INTERNET.
OR THE GOING THROUGH THE THE
THREE D. PRINTER AND MAKING A WE
CALLED GOALS GUNS HAVE A BILL A
A. B. -- EIGHT SEVENTY NINE TO
HOPEFULLY ADDRESS -- THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE WE SEE
IT.
A HUSBAND WIFE WAS MANUFACTURING
GOES GUNS MY IN MY DISTRICT AND
BOTH OF THOSE ARRESTED OF OPEN
PLED GUILTY BUT THEN YOU ALSO
HAVE ANOTHER GERMAN WHO WAS
MAKING GHOST GUNS.
WHO PLED NOT GUILTY WHO WAS
SELLING GUNS THE CRIPS AND
BLOODS?
SO THROUGH THROUGH THAT I JUST
WANT TO RESPOND THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN BUT A LESSON
OF A NERVE THAT NEVADA OR
ARIZONA HAVE STRICT DRUNK YOU
KNOW GUN LAWS.
THEY WILL STILL HAVE THE
PROLIFERATION OF THAT COMING
INTO CALIFORNIA BUT THE REAL
ISSUE IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REFUSED TO ACT IN THIS SPACE
YOUR COMMENTS YEAH.
THAT'S A SEVERE LIMITATION OF
OFFERS ON THE BACK TO YOUR POINT
TO THE THE THE NORMS ARE.
PART OF WHAT I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT TODAY TO THE MOTIVATION.
TO HAVE THE GUN RIGHT IF YOU
HAVE IF YOU'RE BROKEN PERSON
YOU'RE ANGRY LIKE YOU SAID RIGHT.
THAT'S THAT'S A FACTOR SO THEN
THE ACCESS PART.
IS SOMETHING WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT TO BE.
AND SO DESPITE THE FEDERAL
LIMITATIONS RIGHT OF NOT HAVING.
A UNIVERSAL -- STANDARDIZE --
STRICT SET OF LAWS IN PLACE WHAT
WE CAN DO WE HAVE TO KIND OF
THINK ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO.
AND I REALLY THINK THAT HAVING A
DATABASE.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WHAT AT LEAST ALLOW US TO HAVE
BETTER DATA? TO GO AFTER THESE
DEALERS IN PLACES LIKE NEVADA.
OR ARIZONA BECAUSE WHY BECAUSE
THAT'S A FEDERAL CRIME
TRAFFICKING GUNS.
OVER STATE LINES RIGHT.
AND SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
PLACE TO START.
DESPITE THE LIMITATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN THERE'S A
HOMICIDE THESE DETECTIVES.
DATE THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT THEY WANT TO DO THIS WHAT
THEY'LL LONG FOR SIZE TALK TO ME.
IS -- GETTING THE GUN.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T REALLY
PROSECUTE ANYONE IN A COURT OF
LAW RIGHT SO THEY GET THE GUN.
AND THEN THEY WANT TO FIND OUT.
WHOSE GUN IS IT WHERE DID THE
GUN.
COME FROM HOW DID END UP IN YOUR
HAND SO THAT INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED.
WHEN THEY DO GET THE GUN AND BY
THE WAY LAW ENFORCEMENT TOLD ME
THEY ONLY GET THE GUNS IN
HOMICIDES ABOUT 40% OF THE TIME
MAYBE THIRTIES THEY DON'T ALWAYS
GET HIM?
BUT IF THEY KEPT BETTER DATA AT
THE STATE REQUIRED THEM TO KEEP
BETTER DATA AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND IF THE STATE MAINTAINED A
BETTER DATABASE OF THESE GUNS
AND WERE ABLE.
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
OTHER CITIES.
THAT WOULD EMPOWER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO PROSECUTE THE
STATE'S AND BRING THE ISSUE.
ELEVATE THE ISSUE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
TECHNICALLY A FEDERAL CRIME.
SO THERE IS THAT SO THAT WAS THE
FIRST ANSWER THE GHOST GUNS --
THAT'S A REAL CHALLENGE LIKE TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT YOUR BILL
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO SERIAL
NUMBERS I GUESS SO THEN THE
ISSUE WOULD BE THE THREE D.
PRINTER BUT ALL ALL ALL ALL I
WANNA LEARN FROM YOU ON THAT BUT
THAT'S MY ANSWER TO THE FIRST
PART OF YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU REVISED YOU KNOW EVERY
TIME MY COLLEAGUES ON THAT THE
ACROSS THE AISLE -- AND DOES NOT.
A LET IT -- THEY HAVE ALWAYS
PUSHED BACK AND THEY SAID.
PEOPLE KILL PEOPLE GUNS DOESN'T
KILL PEOPLE WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE
TO THAT.
GO BACK TO MY DEFINITION OF GUN
VIOLENCE AT THE BEGINNING RIGHT.
VIOLENCE THE PROPENSITY THE
VIOLENCE IS WHAT DRIVES -- GUN
VIOLENCE RIGHT THAT'S THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE VIOLENCE YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THIS VIOLENCE WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS VIOLENCE.
IN SO WHAT GUNS DO IS THEY
INTENSIFY THE VIOLENCE GO BACK
TO MY THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ISSUE YOU HAVE SOMEONE THAT'S
PREDISPOSED.
TO COMMIT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AGAINST THEIR PARTNER IT'S GOING
TO GET VIOLENT BE PUT A GUN IN
THEIR HANDS.
AND THEN DOUBTS WOULD THAT'S THE
GAME CHANGER RIGHTS OF GUNS
INTENSIFIED VIOLENCE.
AND YOU NEED TO AND THAT'S HOW
WE GET HIGHER HOMICIDE RATES
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT --
WITH POINT ONE TWO FINAL
THOUGHTS REAL QUICK AND THEN WE
WANT TO OPEN UP FOR ANYONE -- TO
TO AN AUDIENCE TO HAVE AND ASK
US ANY QUESTIONS OR MAKE
COMMENTS SO -- FINAL THOUGHTS
MISTER GREEN YEAH ON JUSTANSWER
BACK ON THAT -- GTA.
ALL.
LIKE I SAID EVERYONE IN THIS
SOCIETY HAS A ROLE EVEN THE JEEZ.
BUT WE WE CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THOSE FOLKS TO COME IN AND
AND HELP ADDRESS THE ISSUES WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE CREATE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES WERE.
ARE FOLKS THAT ARE COMING IN TO
HELP OUR SUCCESSFUL.
WE CAN'T TALK -- TO WITH WITH IN
A GROUP SETTING.
AND AND AND AND TRY TO MAKE A
CHANGE THAT HAS TO GO BY
INDIVIDUAL BY INDIVIDUAL.
ON THE FATHER GREG BOYLE --
NOTHING STOPS A BULLET LIKE A
LIKE A LIKE A JOB.
HE GAVE ME A VERY COLORFUL STORY
WHY HE IS NOT A 100%.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT AFTER THIS
MEETING.
BOUGHT LIKE MISTER BOND SAID YOU
GIVE A PERSON A JOB YOU STILL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT PERSON'S.
ALL.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE PERSON
HAS SOFT SKILLS YOU GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PERSON THE THE METAL
IF HE HAS OR SHE HAS ANY MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
OF SOCIAL SKILLS EVERYTHING ELSE
HAVE TO BE IN PLACE.
BECAUSE OF NOT WE WE HAVE
WEEKEND WARRIORS WE HAVE GUYS
THAT FALL BACK WE GRASS SLIP.
SO IT'S A WHOLE BUT IT'S NOT
JUST GIVING A PERSON A JOB AND
YOU KNOW THERE GOES THE A
BEAUTIFUL FAIRY TALE STORY.
BUT I CAN'T.
STRESS MORE THAT EVERYBODY HAS A
PART TO PLAY IN THIS ISSUE THAT
YOU BRING IT UP.
THANK YOU DOCTOR MARTINS YOU
HAVE ANY FINAL THOUGHTS.
THAT'S THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT FOR
ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BOND.
I JUST THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
WHEN WE SPEAK ABOUT THIS ISSUE
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THEY WE GOT TO REALIZE THAT
WHERE WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING INTO
THE SHADOWS AND INTO THE DARK
AND IN THE PROCESS OF GOING INTO
THE DARKENED TRYING TO PARTNER
WITH THESE FOLKS THERE'S A LOT
OF THINGS THAT THEY'RE DOING
THAT.
MAY NOT BE ACCEPTABLE TO
MAINSTREAM SOCIETY BUT WE'RE
ASKING THEM NOT TO HARM ONE
ANOTHER WE'RE ASKING THEM NOT TO
BE WILLING TO KILL ONE ANOTHER
SO CERTAIN THINGS ALTHOUGH MAY
NOT BE LEGAL.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THOSE
CONSEQUENCES ON THEIR OWN.
WE GOT IT WE HAVE TO GET TO A
PLACE WHERE NOT ACCEPTED BUT
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT A LOT OF
THINGS GOING ON IN THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE THEIR REALITY.
AND WE HAVE TO GO IN THERE AND
ACCEPT THEM FOR WHO THEY ARE AND
STILL AND BREAKS DOWN TO IT.
TRY TO ENCOURAGE THEM THE DEAL
IN WHICH A CONFLICT WITH A
FIREARM SHOULD BE AN ACCEPTABLE.
I WANT TO THANK THE PANEL FOR
ONE SECOND SOMEBODY BRIDGES
SCHEDULING SHARE WITH US AT THIS
HEARING WE APPRECIATE IT WE HAVE
CAPTURED AS AS MUCH AS
INFORMATION AS WE POSSIBLY COULD
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INPUT.
IS BEEN INVALUABLE AT THIS POINT
TIME WE WANT TO OPEN THE UP
PUBLIC HEARING.
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION --
SO PLEASE IF YOU -- BECAUSE STEP
TO THE MICROPHONE AND PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR NAME IF YOU WITH AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE SHARE THE
ORGANIZATION AND PLEASE SHARE
YOUR COMMENTS.
WELL MISTER GIBSON -- AT THE
ROLE THAT THE U. JUST COALITION
IS ONE THANK YOU ALL WE CAMPAñA
HAD HAD -- HI.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS DO IT
ALONE.
YEAH.
WILL THIS IN -- YET THANK YOU
FOR CREATING THIS COMMITTEE IN
ADDRESSING THIS THIS ISSUE --
AND INCLUDING THE PART ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL THINK THESE
ARE COULD COME CONVERSATION THAT
NEEDTO BE HAD FOR A COMMUNITIES
BUT YOU BACK ABOUT COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE HE'S ALWAYS BEEN A A
TOUGH ISSUE FOR US -- BUT FIRST
OF ALL JUST LIKE START BY SAYING
THAT GUN LAWS RESTRICTIVE GUN
LAWS ARE INHERENTLY RACIST.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK BACK
AT THE MALL FOR IT ACT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN WHICH WAS
INTRODUCED -- AND PASS AND
SUPPORTED BY RONALD REAGAN.
AND THE NRA THAT BANNED OPEN
CARRY IN CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
YEAH BAND OPEN K. FOR EVERYBODY
BUT IT WAS SPECIFICALLY TO
ADDRESS THE BLACK PANTHERS TO
STORM THE CAPITOL WITH UNLOADED
GUNS.
ON AND YOU KNOW AS WE KNOW THE
BLACK PANTHERS WERE WERE ARMED
TO PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES
FROM POLICE BRUTALITY.
AND SO YOU PASSED FOR TODAY AND
NOW THE NRA IS ALL ABOUT OPEN
CARRY ON BUT THE SAME TIME
DIDN'T SPEAK UP UPLAND OKAY
STILL WAS KILLED WHO -- IF YOU
KNOW FERNANDO COULD STILL STORY
ON THEN ALRIGHT AND SPEAK UP FOR
HIM TO KIND OF SHOW THE RACISM.
OF A AND I THINK RESTRICTIVE GUN
LAWS -- SOMEBODY SAID A PURELY
RESTRICTIVE GUN LAWS ARE GONNA
STOP COMBINE AND DAYS
NEIGHBORING STATES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THE BRING A MAN --
ALSO WITH THE RISE OF
AUTHORITARIANISM THE RISE OF
FASCISM IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
I'M VERY [inaudible]
I'M VERY.
CONCERNED ABOUT TAKING PEOPLE'S
GUNS AWAY WHILE GOVERNMENT A
GOVERNMENT TO BECOME A MORE
AUTHORITARIAN -- SO AS
CONCENTRATION CAMPS ARE BEING
EXPOSED IN AMERICA OR TIME UP
TAKING PEOPLE'S GUNS AWAY AND I
DON'T KNOW IF ON IF THAT'S A
SMART MOVE.
BUT ANYWAYS I THINK FOR SOME
SOLUTIONS -- TO COME BACK ON
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES THE
FIRST THING I THINK WOULD BE TO
END THE WARRING GANGS SO I MEANS
ENDING GANG INJUNCTIONS ENDING
GETTING ENHANCEMENTS ENDING
GETTING DATABASES.
ENDING GETTING -- REGISTRATION --
STOP CRIMINALIZING NEIGHBORHOODS
OR OR WHAT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
STAKEHOLDER GANGS I'M IN
RESOURCE THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS WE
COULD LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID IN
ECUADOR -- THEY ACTUALLY ALLOWED
TO GANGS TWO WERE JUST RECENTLY
THEY ALLOWED GANGS TO REGISTER
IS CULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS WITH
THE ALLERGY BULL TO APPLY FOR
FUNDING. TO PROVIDE SOCIAL
PROGRAMMING A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND I THINK IF WE
COULD IF WE COULD ALLOW
NEIGHBORHOODS TO DO THAT BECAUSE
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE GANGS ARE
ASSOCIATION THE PEOPLE.
WHO USUALLY COMPANY BUT WITHOUT
RESOURCES THINGS LIKE THAT WHICH
IS WHY THEY CONGREGATE TOGETHER
AND AND GET INTO TO THESE OTHER
ACTIVITIES -- TO ALSO NEEDS TO
BE A LOT OF HEALING ON TODAY
THERE IT DOES NEED TO BE A LOT
OF THE TRANSFORMATIVE JUSTICE
CIRCLES PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER --
WITH THE DEATH OF NIPSEY HUSSLE
WE KNOW NOW LAY THAT PEOPLE ARE
COMING TOGETHER TO TRY TO BRING
PEACE TO HAVING PEACE TALKS IS
HISTORIC HASN'T HAPPENED SINCE --
NINETEEN NINETY TWO NOTING
FACILITATING A SUPPORTING MORE
THAT IS THE CENTRAL AND THEN --
SUPPORTING YOU THINK COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT I'M A YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT YOUTH
CENTERS YOUTH EMPLOYMENT HIRING
PEACE BUILDERS -- JEEZ FROM THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ON THAT ARE
CONNECTED WITH COPS BECAUSE AND
PEACE BUILDERS AGAIN
INTERVENTION THIS ARE CONNECTED
TO POLICE THEY LOSE THEIR
CREDIBILITY WITH THE YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO MESS WITH THEM SO WE NEED.
PEOPLE THE THE INDEPENDENT OF
THE SYSTEM INDEPENDENT OF OF
GOVERNMENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AND AND POLICE WHAT THEY NEED TO
BE RESOURCE -- ALSO MENTAL
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE SOMEBODY
POINTED OUT -- AND YEAH AND THEN
ALSO FOR THE FOR THE GUN
VIOLENCE BETWEEN POLICE AND OUR
COMMUNITIES -- SUPPORTING AN
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
ARM AT A TO IMPLEMENT HOPEFULLY
WHICH WILL BE THE NEW USE OF
FORCE STANDARD IF AB THREE NINE
TWO PASSES ON AND THEN STRENGTH
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SO.
WE CAN EXPOSE POLICE WHO ENGAGE
IN THIS KIND OF MISCONDUCT --
BUT YEAH I'D REALLY HIGHLIGHT
SUPPORTING INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AFTER IF YOU
CAN PLEASE OF SHARE WITH YOU
WERE READING OFF OF THEM SURE
YOU YOU WROTE THAT WITH OUR TEAM
EMAIL THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE CAPTURE ALL THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN I STATUS
IS VERY REAL WITH ME BY SALINAS
ALSO REPRESENTED SEE YCJA
CALIFORNIA LAST FOR YOU THANK
IMMUNITY JUSTICE.
I MEAN I WAS TOLD I ONE TIME
THEY DOING THE SAME THING OVER
AND OVER EXPECTING DIFFERENT
RESULTS IS INSANITY I WAS TOLD
THAT FOR A LONG TIME.
BECAUSE I WAS DO UP TO NO GOOD
FOR A LONG TIME -- I'VE ALSO
DONE ALMOST EIGHTEEN OUT OF
FORTY ONE YEARS INCARCERATED I
KNOW THE SYSTEM VERY VERY VERY
WELL -- I NO PART OF THAT SYSTEM
EVER HELP ME.
AND THEN HEAR THE WORD
TRAUMATIZED STARTED WORKING AT
ME BY.
THIS TIME OUT SO THAT MEANS
THERE WAS NEVER A QUESTION IT
WAS NEVER ADDRESSED.
OUR SYSTEM OVERALL IS A FAILED
SYSTEM IT'S A SYSTEM BASED ON
KAPLAN IS MAKING A WHOLE CRAP
LOAD OF MONEY OFF THE CARTER IN
OUR FOLKS UP IN CARTER IN OUR
KIDS.
SO I THINK IT'S THE SAME FOR
CONTINUE TO THE SAME THING AT
THE WHEN YOU QUIT BSE.
AND LET'S JUST HAVE SOME REAL
TALK IS SAID WE GOT STIFF THE
MATIC RACISM INGRAINED IN THE
NUMEROUS SYSTEMS.
THROUGHOUT THEIR POLICIES THAT
IMPACT OUR PEOPLE OF COLOR VERY
NEGATIVELY VERY ADVERSELY -- I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A TALK
ABOUT A LEGISLATION TO OUR
NORMAN 25% OF A CITY OR COUNTY
BUDGET GOES TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
ON AVERAGE IS FIFTY OR MORE
RIGHT OF THE BUDGETS MEANING
THEY'RE CONSUMING ALL OF THE
MONEY.
AND IT'S NOT GOING TO PARKS IS
NOT GOING TO REX IS NOT GOING TO
NOTHING BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT I
KNOW THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH IN SALINAS IT'S OVER 50% --
THE MAJORITY OF OUR LAW FORCES
ARE NOT LOCAL THEY DON'T GIVE A
CRAP OF OUR COMMUNITY I COME
FROM A PREDOMINANTLY LATINO
COMMUNITY AND TWO YEARS AGO A
FELLOW OFFICER TOLD ME.
THAT THERE WAS SEVEN OFFICERS
AND YOU SPANISH.
RIGHT OUT OF THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENT SO WE NEED CULTURALLY
RELEVANT FOLKS WE NEED.
LOCAL.
OFFICERS WHO COME FROM OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE NEED GOOD
OFFICERS NOT THERE'S THERE'S
SOME GOOD ONES I DON'T KNOW I
HAVEN'T MET TOO MANY GOOD ONES
IN MY LIFE RIGHT SO MANY GOOD
LOCAL OFFICERS -- AGAIN WE KNEW
WE NEED THIS WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THEIR BUDGETS AND THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
INSANE TO CONTINUE TO SPEND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DAUGHTER NORTH
SALINAS WE GOT.
TO HUGE TAX I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE OTHER.
FOUR WE SPEND THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A SHOT
SPOTTER.
THAT'S BODY SHOTS BUT ANY
STOPPING NOTHING YOU KNOW --
AGAIN WE NEED INVESTMENT ROOT
CAUSE ISSUES WHICH WITH ADDRESS
TODAY AND POVERTY AND MENTAL
HEALTH IN IN JOBS OPPORTUNITIES --
I THINK WHEN YOU CAN TO THE THE
THE CURRENT PATH THAT WE'RE
GOING IN BANNING THE BOX.
ON A BUNCH OF OTHER GOOD
LEGISLATION THAT'S MOVING
INCLUDING POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THREE TWO FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SO
ON AND SO BUT THE WHEN YOU'RE
CONTINUE TO PUSH THAT LINE --
AND THEN ALSO WE'RE CURRENTLY
CALL SPONSORING A. B. SIX FIVE
SIX TWO TRYING TO CREATE A NEW
OFFICE.
OF HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON VIOLENCE
PREVENTION.
PEACEMAKING AND HEALING RIGHT --
WE'RE TRYING TO GET ALL
DIFFERENT FORMS OF VIOLENCE ALL
UNDER ONE ROOF BECAUSE AS IT
STANDS THERE'S VERY LITTLE
INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES.
AND THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE ARE SCATTERED ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
AND BUT FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FORM OFTEN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE.
RESOURCES WE HAVE.
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR BODY
WAS IN OUR BLOOD SO IF YOU WANT
TO CALL IT.
WE'RE NOT WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THOSE RESOURCES YOU HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE PUBLIC AGENCY OR
YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
TO QUITE FRANKLY -- WE DON'T
REALLY SEE I DYED MY LOCAL
COMMUNITY -- AND I COULD GO ON
AND NOT BROUGHT THINK THAT'S
THEIR RIGHT THERE AT THE GO
AGAIN THIS NEW OFFICE OF HELPING
SAVE COMMUNITIES IS A GOOD
DIRECTION.
I HOPE THAT WE MANAGE TO PASS
THIS TO AGAIN.
HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES OF ALL
DIFFERENT FORMS OF VIOLENCE NOT
JUST GOING BY THIS BUT DOMESTIC
EITHER BE SO ON AND SO FORTH AND
AND ALSO.
VERY VERY IMPORTANT I LEARNED
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IS A HEALING.
ADDRESSING THAT TRAUMA THAT I
TOOK AWAY FOR OVER TWO DECADES
YOU KNOW.
ADDRESSING THAT TRAUMA -- FOR US
WE GO TO CEREMONY NO WE GO TO
SWEAT LODGES OR TP SO OUR
CULTURE IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
SO CULTURALLY RELEVANT PROGRAMS
ARE ALSO VERY IMPORTANT FOR YOU
THEIR CULTURAL IDENTITY YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS
WITHOUT A WHOLE BUNCH ALIVE THEY
TOLD ME COLUMBUS DISCOVERED
AMERICA.
BUT MY PRIMOS WORRY HERE RIGHT
SO THEY TRY TO STRIP OUR
IDENTITY.
COLONIZATION SO WHEN YOU DE
COLONIZE ALL THE WAY AROUND
INCLUDING IN THIS BAD BOY RIGHT
HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INPUT.
MY NAME IS ABRAHAM MEDINA I
REPRESENT -- CALIFORNIA LINES.
ON YOU FOR YOU THE COMMUNITY
JUSTICE ALSO -- REPRESENT
RECENTLY SO MUCH COUNTY I LIVE
IN STOCKTON NOW BUT I GREW UP --
MOVING AROUND HOW FREQUENTLY IN
SOMETIME NOT GARDEN GROVE
ANAHEM -- WHEN I WAS A
SOPHOMORE I THAT WAS THE FIRST
TIME I HAD A GUN ON ME -- THAT
YEARS LATER -- MY FRIEND ABRAHAM
ORTEGA WAS KILLED WALKING
OUTSIDE OF THE SOCCER FIELD.
I REMEMBER JUST TALKING TO HIM
SHORTLY AFTER HE WALKED. TO THE
SOCCER FIELD -- WHEN I GRADUATED
MY MOTHER FRIEND TO FIGURE SEAL
WAS KILLED ON HIS BIRTHDAY?
ARM IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ISRAEL
VIA WAS KILLED BY TESTING PD.
ARM AND IN.
TWENTY TWELVE I WAS I LIVED
THROUGH THE ANAHEIM UPRISINGS.
AM THAT WAS MY FIRST EXPERIENCE
OF SEEING MILA TRIED IT MILITARY
OCCUPIED WHOLE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND I HAD A MACHINE GUN POINTED
AT ME.
BY POLICE OR MILITARY.
SO PART OF A IS LIKE
[inaudible]
OR WE'RE ASKING FOR THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HI WHERE IS THAT KIND ABILITY.
OF OUR POLICE OFFICERS AND I
THINK FOR THAT WE WE DEFINITELY
SEE THAT ARE IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY OVER HALF OF THE
BUDGET GOES TO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AS SO WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE
CITY TO INVESTING YOU.
AND AND WE YOU KNOW HOW IS IT
THAT THAT THE NUMBER ONE THE
NUMBER ONE RESPONSE.
TO PUT THAT TO YOUTH BEHAVIOR
THAT THE CITY HAS AS A POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
SO WHAT WE'RE ADVOCATING IS A
QUEEN FORMER -- THE WHAT WHAT
WAS WHAT WAS SAID EARLIER WHERE
WE WANT TO SUPPORT THE CREATION
OF DEPARTMENTS OF YOU THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AT THE
CITY LEVEL AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT
LOOKS LIKE A B..
SIX FIFTY SIX OFFICE AND HEALING
AND SAFE COMMUNITIES AS WELL AND
PART OF THAT IS LIKE -- YOU KNOW
WHY DO YOU SEE AS AN EXAMPLE OF
OF THIS EFFORTS TO INTEGRATE NOT
JUST COMMITTEE INTERVENTION
WORKERS BUT TRANSFORMATIVE
COMMUNITY WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE DOING WORK
AROUND.
SHARE INFORMATION OF WHAT IT IS
TO HAVE TO BILL TRANSFORMATIVE
CON ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO HOW CAN
FAMILIES GENERATE ELK COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE.
INDIVIDUAL RESILIENCE WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE RISK FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO GUN VIOLENCE IN A
TRANSFORMATIVE WAIT THAT LEADS
TO CHOP SELF TRANSFORMATION
THAT'S CULTURALLY ROOTED.
TRAUMA INFORMED IT'S WERE
TALKING ABOUT HEALING AND CELL
TRANSFORMATION I AGAIN I HAD
CALLED EFFORTS AND AND THAT --
THE SUGGESTIONS -- TO AND WITH
THE WAR ON GANGS THAT'S ONLY
GONNA CONTINUE TO CREATE IN A
MISTRUST AMONG IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH THE JUSTICE SYSTEM A WHAT
WE CALL THE PUNISHMENT SYSTEM --
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY AS WELL I
THINK THAT IN THIS CONTEXT RIGHT
NOW WE WE HAVE THE CASE OF
ANTHONY NOON YES AND IN SAN JOSE
AND CURRENTLY I ALTHOUGH THE
JURY'S GOING TO REACH A VERDICT
ANYTIME SOON THIS WEEK.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE PASSING OF
AB THREE NINETY TWO ODD.
LET US LIVE SAVE OUR BILL SAVE
SAVE OUR LIVES AND THE USE OF
FORCE BILL SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID I THINK THAT WE WE ARE --
ON THE JOURNEY INA PATH FOR
FORT SUB TRANSFORMATION AS WE
CONTINUE TO BE TO TRY TO AND AND
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN EFFORTS. TO
ADDRESS THE CYCLES OF BONDS IN A
COMMUNITY AWAY DOLLARS SO HOLD
Z. SYSTEMS ARE ACCOUNTABLE
SPECIFICALLY THE SYSTEMS I HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE BONDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR INPUT.
JULIE'S THIBODEAU ADVANCE PEACE
SACRAMENTO MY COLLEAGUE OVER
THERE ROTH SAM GONNA.
SO I'M SITTING HERE IN ARMS
LISTEN IN.
I'M HOLDING THIS IPHONE ARE
MEMBER OF THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE THAT I WOULD BE ABLE
TO FACE TIME SOMEBODY ACTUALLY
SEEN WHEN I WAS TALKING.
TO I WAS SOME YEARS AGO.
I STILL SEE A YOUNG MAN TO
SUSPENDED FROM SCHOOL FOR FIVE
AND THERE'S NO ANGER MANAGEMENT
AFTER THAT.
I STILL SEE EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE IS NOT AN OPTION IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
I STILL SEE AS MANY PEOPLE HAVE
GOT UP HERE SPOKEN ABOUT.
IF I'M IMPACTED BY TRAUMA.
NOTHING HAPPENED NO ONE COMES TO
TALK TO ME.
ALL I KNOW IS ON ME TO MAN A
STRAP A QUICK CRYING.
AND DON'T EVEN KNOW.
YOU KNOW THIS IS WHAT I'D.
MARK I'M GONNA BE DEFINED AS
BEING A MAN I HILL BACK MY TWO
YEARS.
AND I KEPT PUSHING THROUGH.
A CABLE OUT ANGER INSIDE AND
GUESS WHAT IS GOING TO GROW UP
LIKE A VOLCANO ONE DAY.
IT IS GOING TO COME OUT IN
INDIANA AND HEALTHY MAN.
SO THAT'S ONE ISSUE I DON'T SEE
WHY WE GOT I CAN TAKE A PHONE.
AND WE GOT ELECTRICITY WE
TALKING ABOUT PUTTING THE CARS
IN A I DON'T KNOW HIGH AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL IS GOING TO DO
WITH THAT BUT HEY WE TALKING
ABOUT DOING.
WE CAN PUT ANGER MANAGEMENT IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
BECAME PRETTY EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEMS ESPECIALLY WHEN I'VE
BEEN RAISED BY A SINGLE MOTHER.
WHO DOING HER BEST?
I THINK SHE'S DOING THE RIGHT
THING BY TELLING ME NOT TO CRY.
WHEN I'M THREE NO MAN I'M BEING
TOLD TO BE A MAN AT?
THREE THAT'S ONE ISSUE
[inaudible]
ANOTHER ISSUE.
YOU HEAR THE NEWS I HEARD IN
THIS ROOM SEVERAL TIMES.
GUNS ARE GETTING IN THE HANDS OF
WRONG P. O. THE WRONG PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT WHAT YOU
THINK YOU THINK GUYS GET IN THE
HAVE IN THE HANDS OF CRIMINALS
GANG BANGERS NOT AT DAY DOESN'T
STOP THERE?
GUNS ARE BEING HANDED TO
OFFICERS WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE
WILL DO.
HE'S NOT QUALIFIED. TO HAVE A
GOOD HE'S NOT EMOTIONALLY
INTELLIGENT ENOUGH OR MENTALLY
STABLE ENOUGH.
HE HAS BEEN DEEMED COMPETENT NOT
YOU HAVE THESE COMPETENCY TRIAL
THURMOND AND STUFF TO SEE A BOMB
BEING COMPETENT. TO STAND TRIAL.
WELL WE DON'T DO THIS FOR A LONG
FORCE.
THE BROTHER GOT UP DEAR HE
TALKED ABOUT DRUG TESTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON NOBODY STEM FROM
BECAUSE THEY THEY DRUG
TESTIFYING CLARK.
RATING GET TODAY BUT I KNOW
THAT'S WHAT HE STANDS FOR MY NO
BEARD.
AND WE WERE ALL SHOCKED LIVE.
HE'S THE VICTIM.
WHY WASN'T THE PERSON WHO
MURDERED HIM OR THE PEOPLE WHO
MURDERED HIM WHY WEREN'T THEY
DRUG TEST?
SO SO A LOT OF FLORA THINGS THEY
SEEM LIKE AN EASY FIX TO MEAN
DROP WOULD BE.
THAT MY SUSPICIONS ARE CORRECT
WHEN I THINK THIS IS SYSTEM.
I THINK THAT WHEN I THINK THAT.
WITH ALL THIS TECHNOLOGY AND ALL
THE WISE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT THEY DON'T REALIZE.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN WHAT COULD BE
EASILY PUT A STOP TO THIS.
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
BECAUSE ONE THING WE KNOW FOR
CERTAIN [inaudible]
MORE BENEFITING.
I JUST SAW ARTICLE -- IN THE
PAPER ABOUT -- OPENED A REGULAR
BEAT COP.
MAKING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
OVERTIME MILLIONS.
THEY PROFIT OFF OF US KILLING
ONE ANOTHER.
WHO FEELS THREATENED?
THAT'S ALL I ASK WHO FEELS
THREATENED BY US HAVING PEACE IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WE ARE THREATENING
SOMEONE'S LIVELIHOOD.
SOMEONE WHO HAS AN EXTRA HOME AN
EXTRA BOWL THE MINISTERS
[inaudible]
ON I'M JUST SAYING SO THESE ARE
THESE ARE TO ME.
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO.
AND I DON'T WANT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S
CHALLENGES IN ROLE BLOCKS WHEN
WE TRIED WE MAKE AN ATTEMPT TO
DO THESE THINGS.
SOMEBODY ELECTED DATING GUY
REPEAT.
YOU KNOW SO WE DON.
BODY HAVING GET YEAH I HAD A
YOUNG PART HE HAD A STROKE A
THIRD.
BECAUSE WE SITTING UP PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES AND ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS BUT WE CAN'T.
KEEP THE THINGS IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOW US TO BE THE BEST
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE CAN BE.
HEALTHY.
AND I'M TALKING MIND BODY AND
SOUL.
THESE THINGS SEEM LIKE EASY FIX
TO ME.
BUT FOR WHATEVER REASON WE
AREN'T DOING.
AND I JUST HAVE TO WONDER WHO'S
PROFITING.
OFF OF A OUR OUR NEGLIGENCE.
ARE BEING STAGNANT OR
UNWILLINGNESS TO DO SO OR AGAIN
I CAN GET ALL INTO THE WORD THE
CLAUSE IN THE WORD THE FACT.
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ATTEND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAVE THEY BEEN DEEMED
WORTHY ENOUGH FOR THE SERVICES.
SAAD I COULD GO ON AND ON LIKE
OTHER BROTHERS SAVE.
WHEN I'M CLOSE WITH THAT I THINK
IT BEARS SOME EASY THINGS THAT
WE COULD DO? TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
ARMING OPERAS WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION BROTHERS AND
SELLS COALITION -- MY FIRST
ENCOUNTER WITH POLICE WAS WHEN I
WAS TWENTY ONE LAPD.
THE FIRST THING THE OFFICERS DO
A PULLED UP BEHIND ME -- ONE OF
THEM RUNS FROM THE PASSENGER
DOOR HE OPENS IT UP AND HE
JUMPED UP TOP OF THE HOOD OF THE
JAGUAR THAT I WAS DRIVING.
AND HE TOLD ME DO ANYTHING
STUPID I'LL I'LL KILL YOU.
AND YOU KNOW THESE WORDS JUST
STILL RESONATES SO AS THEY
BECAUSE LIKE.
THIS WHERE LAPD IS ABOUT YOU
KNOW KILLING.
LIKE WE CAME BE WRITING IN A
NICE CAR OR BE ANYWHERE IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT BEING
THREATENED OR YOU KNOW.
HAVING LIBERTY OF DO ANYTHING WE
WANT THESE ARE CALLING
COMMUNITIES AND I'M SAYING AND
ANY TEAM THAT FEELS THAT TYPE
AWAY.
THERE WOULD BE COMPELLED TO
CARRY A GUN BECAUSE THEY'RE LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT HE THREATENED ME
ALREADY.
HE ALREADY THREATEN ME IT'S
ALWAYS AND KILL ME.
SO WHAT AM I WAITING FOR WHEN
THE KILL ME.
SO -- YOU KNOW THESE THESE TEAMS
THE A LOT OF RESOURCES.
MENTALLY EMOTIONALLY AND
PHYSICALLY ANY TO BE HEALED AND
LIKE THE BROTHER FROM ME BY HERE
YOU KNOW THEY THEY THEY HELP THE
KIDS OUT ALL THE TIME AND YOU
KNOW ALWAYS BEEN SUCCESS IN
TRACK RECORDS THAT THIS HELPS.
AND THEY NEED MORE FUN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST.
THAT ONE LITTLE KID A THERE'S A
LOT OF THESE LITTLE KIDS THAT
ARE OUT THERE GETTING
TRAUMATIZED BY COPS IN A
THREATEN.
EACH AND EVERY DAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO WE HAVE NO THIS WEEK
[inaudible]
YES PLEASE.
YOU WILL BE THE FIRST FEMALE WAS
SPOKEN HERE TODAY.
SO IF AT ALL ALL MEN.
IF YOU HAVE A LOT OF PRESSURE.
TO MAKE A STELLAR SPEAK -- WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING I THINK IT'S
HISTORIC I DON'T REMEMBER EVER
THERE BEING HEARING ON THIS
TOPIC BEFORE -- I THINK THAT FOR
ALL OF US THAT BEEN THROUGH THE
SYSTEM THIS IS A LONG TIME
COMING AND FOR SURE WE WERE
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE LONG BEFORE
WE EVER HEARD ANYBODY ELSE AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY THE UNTOLD
STORY OF THE CRIMINAL AND
JUVENILE IN JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
OUR COUNTRY -- THERE IS SOME
OBVIOUS THINGS THAT I THINK WE
CAN SAY ABOUT WHY GUNS HIT OUR
STREETS BUT MAYBE IT'S NOT.
SO COMMONLY TALKED ABOUT SO I
MIGHT SAY THINGS AND I'M SURE
EVERYTHING I'M GONNA SAY
EVERYBODY HERE ALREADY KNOWS.
THE FIRST THING TO KNOW IS THAT --
LA COUNTY HAS BEEN EPICENTER OF
HANDGUN MANUFACTURING AND
DISTRIBUTION FOR THE WORLD FOR A
LONG TIME.
UNTIL JUST A FEW YEARS AGO THERE
THAT AREA OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
LA COUNTY AND I'M RIVERSIDE
COUNTY WAS KNOWN AS THE RING OF
FIRE.
EVEN THE FBI SAID THAT ABOUT 86%
OF THE HANDGUN CRIMES IN UNITED
STATES WERE ATTRIBUTED BACK TO A
GUN CREATED RIGHT THERE.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS OF THOSE
COMPANIES MANY OF THEM HAD --
DOCUMENTS THAT STATED THAT A LOT
OF THEIR GUNS DISAPPEARED ON THE
WAY TO THE TRAIN YARDS -- IN THE
EAST SIDE OR ON THE WAY TO THE
ON PORTS ON THE SOUTH SIDE.
AND YET WHO GOT BLAMED FOR GUN
VIOLENCE IN LOS ANGELES IN THE
NATION YOUNG BLACK AND BROWN
YOUTH ESPECIALLY MEN -- THOSE
COMPANIES MADE HUGE PROFITS AND
STILL HAVE YET TO PAY A PEACE
DIVIDEND BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
GOT SO HURT -- FOR MYSELF BEING
WHITE COMING UP KNOWS CAN USE
ALL THE LEAST IMPACTED BUT GUN
VIOLENCE IN IN MY FAMILY AND IN
MY COMMUNITY WAS AN EVERYDAY
REALITY SO.
WHETHER IT WAS RUNNING FROM GUNS --
BEING ONE TIME IN A CAR WHERE
SOMEONE PUT A GUN OUTSIDE TO MY
FOREHEAD AND THEN -- CHASED US
FOR BLOCKS OR FINDING MY OWN
FAMILY'S GUN BEHIND THE LIQUOR
BOTTLES -- BECAUSE IT WAS REAL
CLEAR IN OUR HOUSE THAT -- AND
IN MOST HOUSES THAT WHEN
VIOLENCE HAPPENS IS USUALLY
LIQUOR INVOLVED AND THAT'S THE
WORST PLACE TO PUT A GUN BUT
OFTEN A COMMON PLACE TO PUT A
GUN.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT -- LA COUNTY ALSO HAS BEEN
THE EPICENTER FOR POLICE
VIOLENCE FOR NOT ONLY THE NATION
BUT THE WORLD -- WE HAD POLICE
VIOLENCE GOING ALL THE WAY BACK
TO EARLY HISTORY EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT SO FROM EIGHTEEN FORTY
EIGHT TO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE LA
COUNTY HAVE THE HIGHEST LYNCHING
RATE IN THE NATION IT WAS
CALLEBAUT MANAT ALABAMA THAT HAD
THAT THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE.
AND THAT THAT'S WHERE THE
ORIGINAL TERMS AROUND GANG
VIOLENCE CAME FROM.
SOMEONE BROWN PEOPLE FOUGHT BACK
TO TRY TO RECLAIM LAND THAT WAS
TAKEN ILLEGALLY THEY WERE
IMMEDIATELY LABELED AS BANDITS
AND THAT'S WHERE THAT LYNCHING
RAY CAME FROM.
WHEN CHINESE PEOPLE WERE SEEN AS
A THREAT BECAUSE THEY WERE
MOVING INTO LA COUNTY USED IN
TERMS OF NUMBERS -- AND THERE
WAS A TONGUE MASS A TONGUE
CHEWED OUT WHERE A WHITE PERSON
WAS ACCIDENTALLY KILLED.
THAT WAS USE AN EXCUSE TO TO
BURN DOWN CHINATOWN AND STILL BY
MATT ELIAS MASS LYNCHING IN US
HISTORY EIGHTEEN PEOPLE LYNCHED
AND AS MANY AS EIGHTY THREE
PEOPLE KILLED THAT NIGHT.
AND SO LAW ENFORCEMENT LED THOSE
EFFORTS IN LA COUNTY AND IN
CALIFORNIA -- IT WAS ALSO THE
TIME OF THE MORE THE HIGHEST
EXTERMINATION NATIVE PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES NOT TO SAY IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN EVERYWHERE BUT 90%
THE NATIVE POPULATION WAS WIPED
OUT.
AND ALL OF THAT HAPPENED RIGHT
BEFORE THE CREATION OF OUR USE
OF FOR STANDARD SO ARE YOU SO
FOR STANDARD WAS USED AS A AS A
OPPORTUNITY OR IS A RESOURCE TO
EXCUSE ALL THOSE ACTIONS BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND WE'VE BEEN LIVING WITH THAT
CULTURE OF VIOLENCE EVER SINCE
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT YOUNG
PEOPLE OR COMMUNITIES BEING
VIOLENT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHERE
THE VIOLENCE COMES FROM -- THE
SECOND THING I THINK IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL TO TALK ABOUT IS HOW
MILITARIZATION OF POLICE STILL
EXISTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
UNLIKE ANTHONY I DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE ARMED I DON'T
WANT ANY OF US HAVE GUNS HAVING
HAD GUNS PULLED ON ME.
I'M VERY AFRAID OF GUNS AND I'M
ALSO VERY RESPECTFUL OF WHAT
THEY CAN DO AND I PERSONALLY
DON'T TRUST ANYBODY WITH A GUN --
SO I I WOULD BE HAPPY OF ALL
GUNS REMOVED FROM THE PLANET AND
I I AND I'M GLAD FOR TOUGH GUN
CONTROL.
BUT THAT BEING SAID WE'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASED MILITARIZATION OF
POLICING.
SO FOR EXAMPLE -- OUR SCHOOLS
LOOK AND OPERATE A LOT MORE LIKE
PRISONS -- THAN THEY USED TO
WITH SECURITY FENCING
SURROUNDING THEM WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WALKING THROUGH METAL
DETECTORS WITH POLICE TAKING
OVER SCHOOL SECURITY.
MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOW HAVE
POLICE SCHOOL DEPARTMENTS -- LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED AS A LARGEST
SCHOOL POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE
NATION WE HAVE MORE POLICE AND
PROBATION OFFICERS ON OUR
SCHOOLS THAN WE DO GUIDANCE
COUNSELORS.
AND CALIFORNIA BEING THE RICHEST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY AND THE
FIFTH WHAT IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD NOW -- WE
HAVE THE LOWEST RATIO -- SCHOOL
COUNSELORS TO STUDENTS WITH ONE
COUNSELOR FOR EVERY ONE THOUSAND
SIXTEEN STUDENTS THEN YET WHERE
THE MOST MILITARIZED SCHOOLS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY TO
THAT A LOT OF THIS CAME AFTER
COLUMBINE -- BUT IN CALIFORNIA
IT CAME PRE COLUMBINE.
WE WERE ALREADY MILITARIZE IN
OUR SCHOOLS LONG BEFORE THERE
WAS A SCHOOL VIOLENCE CRISIS.
AND THEN EVEN IF YOU TALK ABOUT
COLUMBINE AS A SCHOOL SHOOTING
EPICENTER LIKE A BEGINNING OF A
CONVERSATION ABOUT LOCKING DOWN
SCHOOLS WE LOOK MORE LIKE
PRISONS.
IF YOU LOOK AT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS IN THE UNITED
STATES 98% THE SHOOTERS WERE
WHITE 9896% OF THE VICTIMS WERE
WHITE ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS.
YET THE SCHOOL THEY GET LOCKED
DOWN OUR COMMUNITY IN INCOME IS
A COLOR COMBINE STILL DOESN'T
HAVE FENCING AROUND IT STILL HAS
ONLY ONE METAL DETECTORS SANDY
HOOK THOSE SCHOOLS IN THAT
DISTRICT.
STILL HAVE NO METAL DETECTORS
AND FENCING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THAT KIND OF CLIMATE IS NOT
CONDUCIVE TO LEARNING.
AND MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES NEVER
GET TO NEVER INDOOR THOSE KIND
OF QUALITIES AND SO THESCHOOLS
THAT HAVE NOT HAD POLICE
VIOLENCE HE'S HUGE MASS
SHOOTINGS.
HAVE GOTTEN ALL THE LOCKDOWN --
POLICE IN SCHOOLS SO WE NEED TO
MAKE A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
REMOVE POLICING FROM SCHOOLS AND
TO DEMILITARIZE OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES.
SIMILARLY OUT OF LA COUNTY CAME
MILITARIZED POLICING SO THE
FIRST CREATION OF SWAT OUT OF LA
COUNTY THE FIRST USE OF
HELICOPTERS BY THE SHERIFF'S
AGAINST A CIVILIAN POPULATION --
TAKE DOWN DOORS AND THOSE THOSE.
THOSE ARE MECHANISMS OF POLICING
HAVE NOW SPREAD NATIONWIDE AND
WORLDWIDE IT'S WHAT WE'VE
EXPORTED TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
SIMILARLY YOU KNOW LA COUNTY IS
CALLED LIKE THE YOU KNOW THE
BEGINNING A GANG ACTIVITIES CALL
GANG ACTIVITY WOULD I WAS A
NEIGHBORHOOD ACTIVITY.
BUT FOR DEPORTATION WE NOW HAVE
TAKEN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
INTERNATIONAL TO ALL BECAUSE
WE'VE DEPORTED PEOPLE OUT OF ALL
THE COUNTY INSTEAD OF DEALING
WITH OUR VIOLENCE AT HOME --
LASTLY I WOULD SAY THAT THERE IS
A MYTH THAT KEEPS GIVING POP
PROMOTED EVERY TIME WE BRING UP
POLICEVIOLENCE -- WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR OTHERS IN LA
COUNTY HAS BY FAR THE HIGHEST
USE OF FORCE RESULTING IN
HOMICIDE IN THE NATION -- IT
WITH AT LEAST EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR PEOPLE KILLED IN LA
COUNTY BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BETWEEN
200-020-0017 EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR AT LEAST KILLED -- WE
HAVEN'T EVEN DONE THE NUMBERS AS
WELL WE CAN'T GIVE AN EXACT
ESTIMATE EXACT NUMBER FOR THE
LAST YEAR -- SO WE'RE NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO NEW YORK NOT EVEN CLOSE --
TO CHICAGO AND OTHER CITIES
WHERE THEY HAVE POLICE VIOLENCE
PROBLEMS.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE KEY
REASONS FOR THAT IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE WARRING GANGS IN THE
WAR ON DRUGS CAME OUT OF LA
COUNTY THAT WAS SPREAD WORLDWIDE.
AND IT CREATES A CULTURE OF
LOCKDOWN CONTAINMENT AND CONTROL
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS
FOR COMMUNITIES.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO IF WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THAT NARRATIVE IS CHANGE
THE NARRATIVE ABOUT BLACK ON
BLACK AND BROWN AND BROWN
VIOLENCE -- BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE
IS A CULTURE OF VIOLENCE THAT
COMES FROM OUR GOVERNMENT AND
THE WAY THAT COMMUNITIES ARE
PATROLLED.
AND THEN THAT THAT -- CREATES A
DESPERATION THAT THAT FEEDS INTO
THE VANS WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES -- AND IF WE LOOKED
AT VIOLENCE ACROSS THE SECTOR
MORE WHITE PEOPLE KILL WHITE
PEOPLE MORE ASIAN PEOPLE KILL
ASIAN PEOPLE BUT YOU NEVER HEAR
THE TERM WHITE ON WHITE VIOLENCE --
SO I THINK THAT REALLY AGAIN --
APPLIED THIS HEARING.
AND HOPE IT COMES WITH -- REAL
LEGISLATION TO FOLLOW AND
APPRECIATE YOUR COURAGE AND IN
HAVING.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FIRST OF ALL -- LET'S GIVE
EVERYONE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
ONE BEING HERE AFTER SEPARATING.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS THAT -- I
RECEIVE YOU KNOW A LOT OF
INFORMATION I APPRECIATE THE
VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION I DON'T
WANT THIS JUST TO BE A A ONE
NIGHT WONDER KIND OF SELECT
COMMITTEE I WANTED TO BE IN.
A SELECT COMMITTEE -- THAT IS
ACTIVE BUT IS PRO ACTIVE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO CREATE REAL
SOLUTIONS SO THAT -- ONE THAT WE
CAN BRING A WHITE PAPER -- THAT
MAKES SENSE THAT A SIGNIFICANT
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR THEM TO
PONDER OVER AND HOPEFULLY
IMPLEMENT POLICIES -- ACT AS A
WAY IN A VOICE TO CREATE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND WE TALKED ABOUT
A LOT ABOUT HIS STREET IN THAT
TODAY.
AND I APPRECIATE -- ALL THE
AGREE OX IN THE ROOM OF THOSE
HISTORY MAKERS WHO OF
REGURGITATED WHO'VE STUDIED VERY
LEARNED IN THIS AREA IN TERMS OF
THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES AWARE OF CUT
WHERE ALL THE STUFF HAS COME
FROM.
BUT I WANT TO CHALLENGE EACH IN
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF US TO MAKE
HISTORY TODAY BY WRITING A NEW
NARRATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT BASED ON WHAT YOU SHARE
TODAY WE CAN WE HAVE THE
EXPERTISE WE HAVE THE THE WHEEL
HERE IN THIS ROOM -- TO RIDE IN
THE NARRATIVE OF CALIFORNIA WE
TALKED ABOUT BATTERING RAM TO
TALK ABOUT -- LACK OF FUNDING IN
SCHOOLS AND COUNSELORS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE WHAT HELP
US RIGHT A NEW NARRATIVE SO THAT
THAT WON'T BE THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES -- THIS TIME NEXT YEAR OR
THIS TIME IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
HOPEFULLY FIND OUR SCHOOLS WE
HAVE EVERY SCHOOL -- YOU WON'T
BE ONE CONCERT FOR EVERY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS BUT IT TO BE A
A NICE RATIO THAT'S MANAGEABLE
SO WE CAN HAVE COUNSELORS ON
CAMPUS.
AND ALSO THE WE HAVE
SENSITIVITIES IN TRAINING WERE
POLICE OFFICERS CAN RECEIVE THE
KIND OF TRAINING TO GOING TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT INDIVIDUALS.
AS INDIVIDUALS AND NOT EVERYONE
LOOKING AT LOOKING AT SOMEONE
WHO HAS -- AS A SUSPECT -- WE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW
POLICE VERSES GET PLACING GANGS
WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT PUT ALL THE
BLAME WHEN IT COMES OUT TO
POLICE WE ALSO LOOK ON A BLACK
ON BLACK CRIME BLACK ON BLACK ON
BROWN.
CRIME AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
IT'S ALL OF US AND WE WE LOOK AT
THE OLD -- AFRICAN ADAGES TAKES
ENTIRE VILLAGE TO RAISE A CHILD
WHO WE ARE THAT VILLAGE AND WE
NOW HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER IN
ORDER TO TRY TO ADDRESS.
THE ISSUES WITH IN THAT BILL IS
IN ORDER FOR THE BILL IS TO HEAL
AND SO THAT WE CAN DECREASE THE
AMOUNT OF GANG VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND SO.
EACH OF YOU HAVE BROUGHT SO MUCH
INFORMATION SO MUCH CLARITY THAT
WE WE'VE GONE CHRONICLING THIS
INTO A WHITE PAPER -- WE HAVE
NOT YET SET THE DATE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES -- HEARING ON SELECT
COMMITTEE ON GUN BUYERS WILL BE
MOVING THE NEXT HEARING IN LOS
ANGELES AND THE OAKLAND AND IN
OTHER AREAS AND WE INVITE YOU TO
BE PART OF THAT BUT ALSO.
ANY IDEAS THAT YOU HAVE NOT HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH US WE
INVITE YOU TO REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE SINCE THE EMAIL SO WE CAN
CAPTURE THAT AS PART OF OUR
WHITE PAPER MOVING FORWARD.
I ALSO WANT TO PAUSE LET YOU
KNOW -- I KNOW THEIR BROTHER
BOND AND ALSO -- MISTER GREEN --
TALKED ABOUT WITH THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING WELL IN MY DISTRICT
WE HAVE AND WE'VE BEEN DOING --
COST SAVING OUR SONS -- I
STARTED THIS I WAS ELECTED TO
THE CARSON CITY COUNCIL AND
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO CONTINUE TO
DO THIS -- FROM THAT PARTICULAR --
VEIN SO SAVING OUR SON JUST FIVE
HUNDRED A YOUNG MALES ON THE
CAMPUS OF HOUSE THE UNIVERSITY
MAKE IS HILLS ON SATURDAY AUGUST
THE THIRD -- I BELIEVE STARTS AT
EIGHT O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING AND
THIS COPPERS IS SPECIFICALLY --
FOR YOUNG MALES FROM THE AGES OF
TWELVE TO TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF AGE AND
WE'RE TAKING YOUNG MAN FROM FIVE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES.
GROUP HOME CONTINUATION SCHOOL --
WAR THE COURT PROBATION AND
THOSE WHO DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL
AND SO IT IS RAN BY MALES -- AND
WE HAVE BREAK OUT CLASSES SO
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO POUR
INTO THESE OUNG A MAN SO THAT
THEY CAN HEAR INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE MADE MISTAKES IN THEIR
LIVES BECAUSE EVERYONE SEE --
CELEBRITIES -- YOU KNOW SO THE
THE GLORY BUT YOU DON'T KNOW
THEIR STORE WHICH YOU HAD TO DO
IT AND STRUGGLE IN ORDER TO GET
TO WHERE THEY ARE.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WITH SHARING --
COMMUNITY SHARING SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WILL HOPEFULLY TURN
THOSE YOUNG MEN'S LIVES AROUND
SO WHEN BY SHOULD BE PART OF
SAVING OURSELVES ON AUGUST.
ON THE THIRD AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY BEING A SALES EIGHT
O'CLOCK WE INVITE YOU ALSO TO OF
ANY YOUNG MAN IS A BIT IN THOSE
CATEGORIES INVITE THEM TO BE.
A PART OF THAT CONVERSATION AND
THAT CONFERENCE AND SO WITH THAT
I WANNA POSSIBLE MOMENT WE HAVE
OUR OUR OUR CHAIRMAN OF OURS --
A PUBLIC SAFETY WHO JUST WALKED
IN -- REGINALD JONES BY RESTORE
YEAR JUST CAME IN SO WHAT IS IT
WORSE FOR CONCLUDE.
I'M A VERY FEW BECAUSE IT YOU
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN HERE ALL DAY ON
AS CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY IN
NASSAU ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. TO IN THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
THIS SUBJECT IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME IS OPPRESSION
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
LOOK LET'S BE REAL HONEST --
WHEN IT COMES TO GUN VIOLENCE
AND I'M TALK ABOUT GUN?
VIOLENCE -- IT IS A DRAMATIC
ALMOST DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE DON'T GO DUCK HUNTING.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT HUNTERS WE
DON'T COLLECT A WHOLE LOT OF
GUNS BECAUSE WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
HAVE A THOUSAND GUNS IN OUR HOME
AND LIVE IN BEVERLY HILLS.
WE DON'T DO THAT AND SO -- I'M A
GUN OWNER. FOR MY PROTECTION SO
WE'RE NOT ABOUT TAKING.
RIFLE LEGAL GUN OWNERS WHO ARE
WHO ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
JUST KEEP THEIR HOME SAFE FROM
NOT TALKING ABOUT THEM.
WHICH ABOUT INDIVIDUALS WHO TAKE
HIGH POWER WEAPONS TO TAKE
ASSAULT WEAPONS AND GUNS AND
BETTER REALLY MEANT. TO KILL.
HUMAN BEINGS OUT INTO OUR
STREETS DISCRETION TO OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS MOST
AFFECTED PEOPLE OF COLOR --
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
THAT I'M SORRY I'M LATE BUT
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE BECAUSE I I
THINK THIS IS.
A SUBJECT THAT UP ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON IS HIGHLIGHTING THAT HAS
LONG BEEN OVERLOOKED.
AND WE NEED TO FOCUS LIKE A
LASER ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THE THE DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU
HAVE.
AND THE LEGISLATION THAT WILL
COME FROM THIS WILL HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES IN WAYS THAT.
THAT WE WE DON'T EVEN SEE RIGHT
NOW -- BUT WHEN WE FINISH THIS
AND WHEN.
MR GIPSON DOES A WHITE PAPER AND
TALKS ABOUT SOME OF THE ISSUES
YOU BROUGHT UP IN THERE AND SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME OUT OF
THIS -- EVERYONE I CAME
DISBURSEMENT WILL BE EXTREMELY
PROUD THAT YOU WERE HERE FIRST
AND SO -- I COMMEND THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
AND I WILL OBVIOUSLY KEEP TABS
ON IT AND TRY TO MAKE AS MANY
MEETINGS AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WHAT YOU DO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND I'M GONNA CONCLUDES THE
SIMPLY SAYING WHAT THINK MY TEAM
FOR BEING HERE -- FOR BILLING
YOURSELVES -- PART OF THIS FIRST
DISCUSSION AGAIN THIS IS NOT THE
END BUT IT'S STARTING TO IS JUST
THE BEGINNING AND WE INVITE.
EACH EVERYONE OF YOU TO HELP
ROLL UP YOUR SLEEVES AND HELP US --
WHEN WE -- PUT PEN TO PAPER TO
WRITE THIS WHITE PAPER WE WANT
TO SOLICIT EVERYONE'S INPUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAPTURE I
NOTICE PROBABLY SOMETHING YOU'VE
NEVER HEARD SOMEONE SAY WE WANT
INVITE.
ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE ARE WHO HAVE
SPOKEN TODAY -- WE WANT TO
CAPTURE YOUR THOUGHTS BECAUSE WE
WANT TO GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST
TIME AND SO WE COULD INCLUDE
THESE HEARINGS WE WANT TO HAVE
ANOTHER MEETING -- BROTHER BOND
AND A BROTHER GREEN IN A DOCTOR
MARTINEZ AND OTHER WE WOULD HAVE
A CONVERSATION ON WHAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED SO WE CAN PUT THAT
INCLUDE THE INTO THE WHITE PAPER
SO WE CAN HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE.
WHITE PAPER THAT WE CAN PRESENT
TO THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY BUT
THEM TO LOOK AT AS A ROAD MAP IN
TERMS OF FUNDING AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE SO WE CAN TRY TO GET
THIS -- RIGHT SO WE WON'T BE
REVISITING THIS ISSUE WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO THIS TIME NEXT
YEAR SO AGAIN I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOD BLESS
MEETINGS ADJOURNED